I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THE JANUARY ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. AT
THIS TIME WE DO HAVE ENOUGH
MEMBERS PRESENT TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HERE.
I DON'T CARE.
HERE WOULD.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
I WANT TO WELCOME OUR COMMITTEE
I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING. ONA BE
FIFTEEN OH SIX AND LET ME FIRST
START BY WELCOMING.
THE MANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC%
BOTH HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
AS WELL AS.
OUTSIDE.
TO.
THE CAPITAL TO THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE ARE AND I WANT TO ALSO
JUST THINK ALL OF YOU FOR
ENGAGING IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS.
THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRACY IS ABOUT
AND I KNOW WE HAVE A VARIETY OF
PERSPECTIVES AND VIEWPOINTS ON
THIS ISSUE BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
LET ME ALSO SAY AT THE OUTSET.
THAT I ASK EVERYONE TO BE
RESPECTFUL OF THE PROSPECTIVE
SPA THAT WE WILL BE HEARING
TODAY AGAIN I KNOW THEY'RE VERY
STRONG FEELINGS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE AND I ASK FOR THAT
RESPECT.
LET ME START WITH SOME
HOUSEKEEPING MATTERS DUE TO THE
VERY HIGH TURNOUT AT THIS
HEARING IN FACT WE'RE ESTIMATING
WE HAVE PROBABLY. AT LEAST TWO
OR THREE TIMES AS MANY PEOPLE AS
CAN BE SEATED IN THIS HEARING
ROOM.
I'M GONNA TAKE A MOMENT TO TAK
ABOUT THE ORDER OF BUSINESS
WE'RE GONNA FIRST OPEN TODAY'S
HEARING WITH TESTIMONY FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RICHARD BLOOM WHO
IS THE BILL AUTHOR. AS WELL AS
FROM WITNESSES REPRESENTING THE
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. ARE WE
WILL THEN BEGIN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF THE HEARING.
AT THE BEGINNING A PUBLIC
COMMENTS I'M GONNA FIRST GIVE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO DO NOT
WISH TO SPEAK THE OPTION TO JUST
RAISE YOUR HANDS. TO INDICATE IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WILL THEN BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION THE
HEARING.
WE'RE ESTIMATING OVER A
THOUSAND FOLKS ACCORD HERE AND
DUE TO THE NUMBER PEOPLE WHO
WISHED TO BE PART OF PUBLIC
COMMENT AND OUR DESIRE TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE. IS ABLE TO
EXPRESS THEIR PERSPECTIVE WE
WILL BE LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT
SIMPLY TOYOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
REPRESENTING ONE OR WHAT CITY
YOU'RE FROM AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT THE
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE A VOTE ON
THE BILL. AYE AND AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
COOPERATION.
I'M GONNA START WITH SOME
OPENING COMMENTS.
AS OUR COMMITTEE KNOWS AS MANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC KNOW LAST
YEAR WE PASSED A HISTORIC
HOUSING PACKAGE REALLY THE FIRST
TIME THAT THIS LEGISLATURE. HAS
BEGUN TO TACKLE THE STATEWIDE
HOUSING CRISIS FIFTEEN BILLS ARE
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY BEGIN TO
MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT TOWARD
ADDRESSING. THE WORST CRISIS OUR
STATE HAS EVER EXPERIENCED.
BUT THAT BEING SAID WE ALL KNOW
THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET IT IS
GOING TO TAKE A MULTI PRONGED
EFFORT A MULTI YEAR EFFORT TO
ADDRESS THE AFFORDABILITY.
CRISIS.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
HOUSING COSTS ONTINUE TO SOAR.
OUR STATE IS THE SIXTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD BUT WHEN
YOU FACTOR IN HOUSING COSTS
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATE. IN THE COUNTRY
THAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
WE KNOW ALSO. AND LET ME ALSO
ASK FOR QUIET IN SILENCE ARE WE
DO NOT.
AB JUST GONNA MAKE ANOTHER
HOUSEKEEPING RULE.
WE DO NOT PERMIT PEOPLE OUGHT
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTARY DURING
THE HEARING ARE AGAIN OUT OF
RESPECT FOR.
THE TESTIMONY AND FOLKS WERE
SPEAKING.
WE NOT ONLY HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS WE ALSO HAVE A TENANT
CRISIS.
AT THIS TIME ONE THIRD OF ALL
RENTERS PAY MORE THAN A HALF OF
THEIR INCOME TOWARD RENT. WHEN
YOU ADD TRANSPORTATION COST
NUMBER JUMPS DRAMATICALLY.
AS WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY IS OUT PACING
INCOME GROWTH AT A LEVEL THAT IS
SIMPLY UNSUSTAINABLE.
AS OF THE END OF THIS PAST YEAR.
IN MY CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO YOU
SAW ONE BEDROOM APARTMENTS THAT
ARE RENTING FOR ALMOST THIRTY
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH ON
AVERAGE.
TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT RENTS ARE
AVERAGING CLOSE TO FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
A RECENT STUDY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PROJECTS TRIPLE DIGIT
RENT INCREASES TO HIT MUCH OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION.
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS
ACCORDING TO APP I SEE SURVEY
FROM THIS PAST FALL.
RENTERS ARE TWICE AS LIKELY AS
HOMEOWNERS TO SAY THAT THERE
HOUSING COSTS ARE CAUSING A
FINANCIAL STRAIN SIXTY ONE
PERCENT COMPARED TO THIRTY
PERCENT.
A AT THIS TIME A THIRD OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE SAYING THAT THE
COST OF HOUSING IS MAKING THEM
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER MOVING OUT OF
THE STATE.
OVER HALF OF ALL RENTERS ARE
CONSIDERING LEAVING THEIR REGION
OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS A
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF OUR
COUNTRY'S HOMELESS.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
HOMELESSNESS HAS RISEN STE
FIFTEEN PERCENT STATEWIDE.
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS FOR THIRTY
ONE PERCENT OF ALL PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ALL KNOW THE IMPACTS OF THIS
CRISIS ON TENANTS WHO COULD BE
PRICED OUT OF THEIR HOMES
DISPLACED FROM THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
AS A RESULT.
BOB WE'RE GONNA SEE HEAR ABOUT
THE DETAILS OF THIS PROPOSAL BUT
I THINK EVERYONE HERE KNOWS THAT
AB FIFTY NO SIX WOULD REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS WHICH HAS BEEN ON
THE BOOKS SINCE NINETEEN. NINETY
FIVE
THERE HAS BEEN MOMENTUM AT BOTH
THE LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT OUR SKYROCKETING
HOUSING COSTS.
I THINK EVERYONE HERE KNOWS
WHERE NUMBER OF US STAND I AM A
CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION ON THIS TOPIC MY
CITY IS IN CRISIS ARE AND THAT
WAS REFLECTED BY THE FACT THAT
EVERY MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
HAS VOTED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
UP BUT MY CITYLIKE MANY CITIES
AND AREAS AROUND THE STATE ARE
ARE IN A CRISIS AND AND AND ARE
RANCHERS NEED RELIEF SO WITH
THAT. LET ME ASK IF THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WHO
HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS.
AND IF NOT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
AND AT THIS TIME ALSO ASK.
WITNESSES ARE ON THE SUPPORT
SIDE IF YOU WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
JOIN A MISTER BLOOM AT THE DíAS
OF THE WITNESSES ON EACH SIDE
WILL BE ABLE TO TESTIFY FOR NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. ARE AND A
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY WITNESSES
COULD FIELD QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
MISTER BLOOM WELCOME.
MORNING AND THANK YOU UP OF
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE AND WHO ARE
WATCHING AND OR LISTENING IN TO
THIS VERY IMPORTANT
DEBATE.
MISTER CHAIR YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
ME REPEAT SOME OF THE VERY
REMARKS THAT YOU JUST MADE.
.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COAUTHOR SHIP
OF THIS BILL BUT I THINK THE
THINGS THAT YOU JUST SAID MANY
OF THEM BEAR REPEATING BECAUSE
THEY ARE SO IMPORTANT AND SO
CRITICAL. A IN THE DEBATE AND IN
FACT IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN
LARGE PART DUE TO YOUR WORKS
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE GOOD WORKS
OF THIS COMMITTEE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGN NUMEROUS
PIECES OF LANDMARK LEGISLATION
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S RAPIDLY
ESCALATING HOUSING CRISIS.
WE CREATED NEW FUNDING STREAMS
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BEGAN TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
LAND ZONED FOR A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT MANY AREAS OF THE
STATE. AND WE REMOVE BARRIERS TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING AT
ALL INCOME LEVELS.
SO WE CAN BE OPTIMISTIC THAT
OVER TIME THESE MEASURES WILL
MAKE A MEANINGFUL DENTON THE
CONSTRUCTION SHORTFALL THAT HAS
BEEN YEARS IN THE MAKING.
BUT WE HAVE TO BE FRANK WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
NEW UNITS INSUFFICIENT
QUANTITIES WILL TAKE YEARS TO
BUILD.
IN THE MEANTIME.
CURRENT DRAMATIC SHORTAGE OF
UNITS CONTRIBUTES TO RAPIDLY
ESCALATING RENTS IN MUCH OF THE
STATE AFFECTING A VAST RANGE OF
CALIFORNIANS ON A DAILY BASIS
FROM YOUNG TO OLD. ACROSS ALL
ETHNIC GROUPS AND EVEN INCLUDING
THOSE HOLDING GOOD MIDDLE INCOME
JOBS.
NOT SURPRISINGLY.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO
WEATHER THE ECONOMIC STORM OF
THIS CRISIS ARE THE WEALTHY.
ALSO NOT SURPRISINGLY POOR AND
DISADVANTAGED CALIFORNIANS ARE
MOST DRAMATICALLY AFFECTED.
AS RENTS INCREASE ON THOSE WITH
LIMITED INCOMES
QUALITY OF LIFE DECREASES IN
INVERSE PROPORTION DIRECTLY
AFFECTING THEIR ABILITY TO PAY
FOR FOOD. UTILITIES MEDICATION
FUEL SCHOOL SUPPLIES AND OTHER
ESSENTIALS.
FREQUENTLY IT EVENTUALLY LEADS
TO DISPLACEMENT.
PERHAPS TO COMMUNITY FAR AWAY
THAT REQUIRES LONG COMMUTES THAT
INCREASES TRAFFIC AND GREENHOUSE
GASES.
OR IT MAY MEAN TEMPORARY
QUARTERS ON A FRIEND OR
RELATIVE'S COUCH.
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO OTHER
AFFORDABLE UNITS AVAILABLE FOR
RENT.
FOR MANY.
FAR TOO MANY THE NEXT STOP IS
HOMELESSNESS.
AND UNDOUBTEDLY WILL NOT THE
ONLY BECAUSE THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTING BECAUSE OF THE
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS. THAT WE HAVE SEEN
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OR MORE IN
MANY AREAS JUST IN THE PAST
YEAR.
I NEEDN'T REMIND YOU THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY ONE
QUARTER THE NATION'S HOMELESS
AT A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND AND THAT'S UP FROM. ONE
FIFTH.
ONLY A FEW YEARS AGO.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE STRUGGLING TO ADDRESS
THIS GROWING CRISIS.
THEY NEED ADDITIONAL TOOLS
CRAFTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
HELP SLOW RAPIDLY INCREASING
RATS AND PROTECT RUNNERS WHO ARE
FACING DISPLACEMENT.
THIS IS CRITICAL NOT ONLY TO
PROTECTING FAMILIES FROM BEING
UPROOTED. BUT ALSO TO ENSURING
AN ADEQUATE LOCAL WORKFORCE.
AND MAINTAINING DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES.
CONTINUING TO PRICE EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIANS OUT OF THE HOUSING
MARKET.
WILL DAMAGE OUR ECONOMY HAS
COMPANIES FIND IT HARDER AND
HARDER TO RECRUIT TO RECRUIT
EMPLOYEES.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIA HAVE
LOOKED TO RENT CONTROL.
AS ONE TOOL.
FOR HELPING.
NOW EVERY ADOPTED RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE IN CALIFORNIA'S
DIFFERENT WHY.
BECAUSE LONG BEFORE THE STATE
INTERCEDED IN THE MATTER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND VOTERS WERE
CRAFTING ORDINANCES UNIQUELY
TAILORED TO THEIR LOCAL
CONDITIONS.
SOME PROVIDED FOR VACANCY DE
CONTROL LONG BEFORE COSTA
HAWKINS MANDATED.
MANY EXEMPTED NEW CONSTRUCTION.
ON THIS ISSUE I BELIEVE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND VOTERS
KNOW HOW TO BEST ADDRESS LOCAL
NEEDS.
GIVEN THE CURRENT CRISIS.
I THINK WE HAVE TO RETURN LOCAL
DECISION MAKING TO WHERE IT FITS
BEST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AGAIN AB FIFTEEN NO SIX SEEKS TO
HELP CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
AFFECTED.
A DAY.
BY EXORBITANT AND UNAFFORDABLE
RENT INCREASES THAT THREATEN
THEM WITH DISPLACEMENT.
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN QUALITY
OF LIFE. OR BOTH.
A FEW YEARS DOWN THE ROAD WHEN
WE HOPE EXPANDED HOP HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES TAKE HOLD.
THAT WILL BE TOO LATE.
TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS.
SO THIS IS AN ISSUE FELLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT HAS YET TO
BE THE SUBJECT OF LEGISLATION OR
INDEED OF MUCH CONVERSATION
INTERNALLY HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
AND IT IS INDEED A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT.
SURELY THAT WILL BE BE
DEMONSTRATED BY TODAY'S HEARING.
BUT IT IS IN MY OPINION A
CONVERSATION THAT WE CAN NO
LONGER AVOID. AND PRESENTS AN
ISSUE THAT IS CRYING OUT FOR
RELIEF AND LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
OUR TEACHERS
GROCERY STORE WORKERS CAR
MECHANICS AND NURSES PEOPLE WHO
WE INTERACT WITH. EACH AND EVERY
DAY MANY OF WHOM HAVE LIVED AND
WORKED IN OUR COMMUNITIES THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES AND MAKEUP.
FABRIC OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
ARE BEING PRICED OUT.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
BARELY GETTING BY EACH MONTH
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE
TAKEN POSITIVE STEPS TO
ALLEVIATE THESE FINANCIAL
STRESSES.
WHEN INCREASE MINIMUM WAGE.
INCREASED FUNDED CHILDCARE SLOTS
INVESTED IN THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT FOR WORKING FOR.
BUT ALL OF THESE GAINES INTENDED
TO IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE ARE
COMPROMISED
IF WE CAN'T CONTROL THE COST OF
HOUSING.
AB FIFTY KNOW SIX IS NOT A
SILVER BULLET THAT'S GOING AND
THE HOUSING CRISIS OVERNIGHT. I
RECOGNIZE THAT.
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY REMOVING A
BARRIER FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PRESERVE SOME AFFORDABILITY AND
NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND LET ME BE CLEAR.
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS WILL NOT
LEAD OVERNIGHT TO RENT CONTROL
STATEWIDE. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WILL STILL HAVE TO PASS THEIR
OWN ORDINANCES TAILORED TO LOCAL
CONDITIONS EITHER BY GOING TO
THE VOTERS ARE GOING THROUGH
THEIR COUNCIL OR BOARD.
SOME CITIES AND COUNTIES WILL
CHOOSE TO PURSUE RENT CONTROL
POLICIES
MANY AS HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST
WILL NOT.
NOT ALL JURISDICTIONS ARE READY
FOR RENT CONTROL WE HAVE RECENT
LOCAL ATTEMPTS IN SANTA ROSA
BURLINGAME AND ALAMEDA THAT.
WERE NOT SUCCESSFUL.
SO IN CONCLUSION THIS MEASURE IS
BUT ONE TOOL FOR THE LEGISLATURE
AND FOR OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
BUT IS THE ONLY ONE THAT WE HAVE
THAT CAN RIGHT NOW HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND I WON INTRODUCED THREE
WITNESSES THAT ARE WITH ME HERE
TODAY.
ALLISON REGAN WITH THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD DEAN PRESTON WITH
TENANTS TOGETHER AND SINEAD
FRANKLIN. WHO IS A FORMER
APPOINTEE TO THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING COMMISSION AND THE
BAY AREA RENTER?
THANK YOU.
BLOOM.
WELL TURNED OVER TO EUROPE
WITNESSES AND WHATEVER YOU HAVE.
WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALLISON REGAN I'M A
DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE
CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM STATED THIS
IS A LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE.
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS WILL NOT
RESULT IN RENT CONTROL STATEWIDE
RENT CONTROL IS ALREADY
AVAILABLE AND ONLY SIXTEEN
CITIES CURRENTLY HAVE ORDINANCES
ON THEIR BOOKS.
BUT IN THE AREAS WHERE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IS
MOST ACUTE AND WHERE RENT
STABILIZATION HAS PROVEN
EFFECTIVELY TO PREVENT
DISPLACEMENT OF LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND OTHER VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. POPULATIONS BY THE
WAY WHICH ARE CRITICAL TO A
ROBUST ECONOMY THESE AREAS THE
STATE SHOULD NOT MANDATE HOW
THOSE ORDINANCES ARE
IMPLEMENTED.
ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL.
AND ALSO THESE ORDINANCES ARE
EACH UNIQUE SOME OF THEM ALREADY
MOST OF THEM IN FACT EXEMPT
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES DUPLEXES TRI
PLEX THE SMALLER PROPERTIES. TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE ECONOMIC
REALITIES IN THEIR AREAS. ALSO
WANTED TO POINT OUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. OF
USING THE COST OF USING COSTA
HAWKINS IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
ELLIS ACT.
COSTA HAWKINS ALREADY CREATES A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE. TO FOR
LANDLORDS TO A DRIVE EXISTING
TENANTS OUT OF THEIR UNITS SO
THAT THESE UNITS CAN BE RENTED
AT MARKET RATES.
WHEN USED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE ELLIS ACT IT'S COSTA HAWKINS
ON STEROIDS.
THE OTHER SIDE ALLOWS LANDLORDS
TO EMPTY ENTIRE BUILDINGS OF
TENANTS. OSTENSIBLY TO LEAVE THE
RENTAL MARKET. BUT THE MEAGER
PENALTIES OF THE ALICE ACT ARE
DWARFED IN COMPARISON TO THE
PROFITS TO BE MADE WITH VACANCY
DE CONTROL UNDER COSTA HAWKINS.
THEREFORE WHEN USING CONJUNCTION
WITH THE ELLIS ACT COSTA HAWKINS
HAS LED TO THE PERVERSE
CONSEQUENCE OF INCENTIVIZING
HARASSMENT AND ABUSE IN AREAS.
WHERE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS IS MOST ACUTE?
FINALLY I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
POINT OUT LIKE SAKE THAT CITIES
LIKE WEST HOLLYWOOD SANTA
MONICA.
AND SAN FRANCISCO. TIME ITSELF.
MAY I FINISH MY STATE YOU CAN
FINISH YOUR SENTENCE THINK WE
HAVE ALL STEPPED UP IN RESPONSE
TO THE STATE'S EVER INCREASING
DEMANDS.
TO INCREASE GREATER AND HAVE
GREATER AND DENSER DEVELOPMENT
THE STATE SHOULD NOT THEREFORE
TIE THE CITY'S HANDS IN CRAFTING
EVEN MORE SOLUTIONS TO SOLVE
THIS CRISIS THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS PLACE.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS SHOULD
NAY FRANKLIN MINOR AND.
IVORY A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE
TODAY I SERVED AS AN APPOINTEE
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN FOR THE
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING COUNCIL.
AND I TRAVELED THE STATE HEARD
FROM MANY CALIFORNIANS ABOUT
THEIR FEAR OF DISPLACEMENT
BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING CRISIS.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND PERSPECTIVE OF
A SMALL LANDLORD LIKE MY GRANNY
WHO WAS A SHARECROPPER SHE MOVED
TO SAN FRANCISCO LIVED IN THE
HOUSING PROJECTS. BOUGHT AN
APARTMENT BUILDING BY SAVING HER
MONEY CLEANING OTHER PEOPLE'S
HOUSES AND SHE RENTS IT OUT TO
SECTION EIGHT TENANTS TO GIVE
BACK.
NOW I MOVE BACK TO MY COMMUNITY
IN OAKLAND.
AFTER LAW SCHOOL AND MARRIED MY
HIGH SCHOOL SWEETHEART.
AND WE ENDED UP RENTING A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT I GREW UP IN WE'RE RAISING
OUR TWO DAUGHTERS WHO LIVE THERE
FOR TEN YEARS.
BECOME A BIG PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY AND JUST LAST YEAR OUR
LANDLORD RAISED R. RENT BY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THEY GIVE US A TWO MONTHS NOTICE
FOR THIS INCREASE WAS OVER A
FIFTY PERCENT INCREASE.
AND THEY COULD DO THIS
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF COSTA
HAWKINS.
NOW WE LIVE THERE AS I SAID FOR
TEN YEARS.
WE'VE PAID MORE IN RENT THAN
THEY PAID ME PURCHASE THE HOME
OVER THIRTY YEARS AGO.
NOT KNOWING ARGUES THAT WE'RE
ENTITLED TO EQUITY IN OUR HOUSE.
THAT'S THEIR PROPERTY RIGHT.
BUT AT A MINIMUM WE'RE ENTITLED
TO STABILITY.
THAT'S A HUMAN RIGHT.
SO I URGE YOU TODAY TO STAND
WITH THE FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE USE HOUSING IS BEING
HELD IN THE BALANCE
BECAUSE OF COSTA HAWKINS THANK
YOU?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER PRESTON.
GOOD MORNING.
SHARE CHU AND.
AB MEMBERS WE CAN MAKE SURE MIKE
IS ON THANK YOU LET'S RESTART
THE TIME GREAT THANK YOU COME
MORNING.
DEAN PRESIDENT THAT COULD OF
DIRECTOR OF TENANTS TOGETHER
CALIFORNIA'S STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION FOR RENTERS RIGHTS
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU.
TODAY AYE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX.
AS WE'VE HEARD CALIFORNIA HAS
SOME OF THE HIGHEST RENTS IN THE
NATION AND SOME OF THE WORST
CONDITIONS FOR TENANTS I
CALIFORNIA TENANTS ARE BEING
GOUGED EVERY DAY ACROSS THE
STATE. AND ASK YOUR CHU NOTED.
THIRD OF TENANTS PAY OVER HALF
OF THEIR INCOME TO RENT.
TENANTS TOGETHER OPERATES A
STATEWIDE HOTLINE.
WHERE WE TALK WITH TENANTS
ACROSS? ALL OF THE STATE ABOUT
THEIR HOUSING ISSUES WE JUST HAD
A CALL LAST WEEK FROM THE
RICHMOND.
RESIDENT IN A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME EXEMPT FROM RENT CONTROL.
BECAUSE OF COSTA HAWKINS AYE
SHE RECEIVED A ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN PERCENT RENT INCREASE
HER RENT WENT FROM SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TO THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH THAT'S NOT A
RENT INCREASE NOTICED THAT'S AN
EVICTION NOTICE. AND WE GET
SIMILAR CALLS FROM TENANTS IN
EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE EVERY
DAY AND THE VICTIMS
OF THESE KIND OF ABUSIVE RENT
INCREASES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
SENIORS IMMIGRANTS AND WORKING
FAMILIES WHO ARE STRUGGLING
ALREADY FOR DAILY SURVIVAL AND
THEN FACE THESE KIND OF
INCREASE.
NONE OF THIS IS INEVITABLE IT IS
BECAUSE OF UNCHECKED REAL ESTATE
SPECULATION. AND INDUSTRY
WRITTEN LAWS LIKE COSTA HAWKINS
COSTA HAWKINS ENCOURAGES RUN
AWAY RENTS INCENTIVIZE EVICTIONS
AND REDUCES THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THANKS TO COSTA HAWKINS A
GROWING NUMBER OF UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE TOTALLY EXEMPT
FROM ANY RENT LIMITS WHATSOEVER
AND COSTA HAWKINS INCENTIVIZE
THIS LANDLORDS ENTERING CONTROL
CITIES TO KICK OUT. AFFORDABLY
HOUSE TENANTS SO THEY CAN
REALIZE ON LIMITED RENT
INCREASES FOR THE NEW TENANTS.
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX WILL ALLOW
CITIES TO CRAFT APPROPRIATE
POLICIES.
TECH TENANTS FROM EXCESSIVE RENT
INCREASES AND DISPLACEMENT THE
BILL MANDATES NOTHING BUT FUN
TIES THE HANDS OF A LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO SOLVE AN ACUTE
CRISIS.
THE LANDLORD LOBBY IS FULLY
CAPABLE OF WAY.
MAY I JUST FINISH THE CENTER
COULD FINISH THE SENTENCE THINK
IF THE WOMEN LOBBYIST FULLY
CAPABLE OF WEIGHING IN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AS THEY DO AND WE
KNOW BECAUSE WE HAVE SPARRED
WITH THEM OVER RENT CONTROL
LOCALLY. AYE IN MANY COMMUNITIES
THEY DON'T NEED OR DESERVE THE
STATE THROUGH COSTA HAWKINS
PUTTING A THUMB ON THE SCALE IN
FAVOR OF EXCESSIVE RENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE ASK FOR AND
I'VE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COLLEAGUES UNLESS YOU HAVE ANY
INITIAL QUESTIONS TO THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES I'D LIKE TO INVITE UP
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO MAKE
THEIR STATEMENTS AND THEN.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY ASK
QUESTIONS THAT WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION BEFORE. PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SO THIS TIME I LIKE TO INVITE
THE OPPOSITION.
TO THE DíAS.
I THINK WE'VE THREE SEATS SO
EVERYONE CAN STAY SITTING AT THE
HEARING TABLE.
WE HAVE WITH US DEMóCRATAS OF
FROM CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION CENTER RAY FROM FBI
MANAGEMENT COMPANY AND CREAM
THERESA GREASY FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. OF REALTORS EACH OF
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AS. IN THE
ORDER THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
PROCEED.
SCOTT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DEBORAH
CARLTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION YOU KNOW I
HATE TO DATE MYSELF BUT I WAS
HERE IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
WHEN WE PASSED COSTA HAWKINS.
YOU KNOW WE WERE ABLE TO DO
THAT ARE THE LEGISLATURE AGREED
TO DO THAT BECAUSE AFTER TWENTY
YEARS OF EXTREME RIGHT
CONTROLLING R. LURKED LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WE SAW WE HAD LOST
A LOT OF HOUSING. WE SAW THAT WE
HAD LOST.
PEOPLE WHO HAD MOVED.
TO NEIGHBORING.
JURISDICTIONS GENTRIFICATION
AND NEW CONSTRUCTION HAD COME TO
A NEAR HALT.
TODAY HOUSING PRICES ARE NOT
INCREASING BECAUSE OF COSTA
HAWKINS ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY WE
AGREE.
WITH THE PROPONENTS HERE THAT
HOUSING PRICES ARE INCREASING
BUT I WILL SAY IT'S BECAUSE.
WE HAVE NOT DONE OUR JOBS AT
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION I HAVE TO
COMMEND THIS BODY YOU HAVE DONE
GREAT WORK.
WITH THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN
THE HOUSING PACKAGE AND I THINK
THAT'S GONNA MAKE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROBLEM WE
FACE IS THAT WE BELIEVE COSTA
HAWKINS WILL PUT A HALT ALL THE
GREAT WORK THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
DONE.
I'M IN RECENT REPORTS THE STATE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST CONCLUDED
THAT RENT CONTROL WILL DO
NOTHING. TO INCREASE OUR SUPPLY
AND IN FACT WILL DISCOURAGE NEW
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION AND WHILE
IN THE BAY AREA YOU SEE CRANES
IN THE AIR EVERY DAY. IN FACT WE
HAVE ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND NEW
HOUSING UNITS THAT HAVE BEEN
CONSTRUCTED IN THE PAST YEARS.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A BOOM INTO YOUR
REALIZE THAT WE CREATED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND NEW JOBS AT THE
SAME TIME. THEY'RE COMING IN IN
MASS AND WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
HOUSING ECAUSE OUR BALANCE OF
JOBS AND HOUSING IS NOT THERE.
YOU KNOW THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT AB
FIFTY NO SIX DOES NOT REQUIRE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ADOPT RENT
CONTROL YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THEY DON'T.
BUT CURRENTLY RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS ALREADY TOLD US
THEY WILL ADOPT MORE EXTREME
FORMS OF RENT CONTROL. THE
MAJORITY OF RENTAL UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE LOCATED IN SMALL
MOM AND POP.
HOMES AND YOU ARE ALSO RIGHT
SECONDS IN.
YOU ARE ALSO CORRECT THAT THE
ELLIS ACT HAS BEEN USED BECAUSE
OWNERS HAVE WALKED OUT THEY'VE
LEFT.
THEY HAVE LEFT THE MARKET AND
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THAT AGAIN.
BECAUSE OF THE ELLA SATURDAY
WILL BE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MAKE
A LIVING TURN CONCLUSION.
WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THE
MORE EXTREME RIGHT BECAUSE I
CAN'T TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU IF I COULD ASK MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC DURING THE
TESTIMONY OF MISTER CARLTON SHE
WAS INTERRUPTED A NUMBER OF
TIMES WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS SPARE TIME SO. I
APPRECIATE THE JAZZ HANDS OR IN
SOME INSTANCES KNOW OF IT THAT
GIVES US SOME INDICATION WITHOUT
INTERRUPTING SPEAKERS.
AND I WOULD UP I'D AND ASK FOR
THAT.
SILENCE INDICATION OF WHERE
FOLKS ARE THINKING IS CARLTON
LET'S PROCEED TO THE NEXT
WITNESS.
AB MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
CYNTHIA RAY SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
ACQUISITIONS WITHOUT PI
MANAGEMENT. OUR COMPANY MANAGES
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND RENTAL
HOUSING UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THOUSANDS OF OWNERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AS SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
ACQUISITIONS MY ROLE IS TO HELP
CLIENTS DEVELOP AND GET NEW
RENTAL PROJECTS APPROVED AND
BUILT.
THE REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS
WOULD HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT
ON NEW RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION.
THE UNCERTAINTY REGARDING THE
FUTURE OF COSTA HAWKINS HAS
ALREADY PUT A NUMBER. OF A
NUMBER OF.
NEW SITES ON HOLD.
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
MANY YEARS WITH ADDITIONAL COSTS
RELATING TO LAND AND%
CONSTRUCTION THESE PROJECTS WILL
SIMPLY NOT PENCIL. IF SUBJECTED
TO RENT CONTROL FOR LIFE.
I CAN TELL YOU FIRSTHAND THAT
I'M WORKING WITH DEVELOPERS ON
TWO DIFFERENT HOUSING.
PROJECTS RIGHT HERE IN THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO THAT WOULD BRING
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED UNITS OF NEW
HOUSING MANY OF THEM AFFORDABLE.
BOTH DEVELOPERS HAVE PUT THEIR
PROJECTS ON HOLD AND ARE LOOKING
AT VARIOUS OTHER OPTIONS GIVEN
THE BILL'S CALL FOR RENT CONTROL
IN SACRAMENTO. AND A STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE.
I HAVE CLIENTS HAVE FOUND THAT
BUILDING PROJECTS IN NEIGHBORING
STATES IS PREFERRED BECAUSE OF
THE PREDICTABILITY AND HE'S OF
CONSTRUCTION.
I HONOR CLIENTS ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT FIND THEMSELVES
IN SIMILAR SITUATIONS EITHER
SLOWING DOWN PROJECTS ARE
RECONSIDERING THEM IN THE LIGHT
OF THE UNCERTAINTY AROUND COSTA
HAWKINS.
AS A COMPANY WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THE AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES THAT CALIFORNIANS
FACE WHILE AB FIFTEEN NO SEX MAY
HELP SOME TENANTS IN THE VERY
SHORT TERM. IT WILL HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT IN THE LONG
RUN AND WILL WILL LEAD TO
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER HOUSING
COSTS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER THAT
MOST OF THE NEW HOUSING BUILT
TODAY WAS ACTUALLY APPROVED AND
HAS BEEN IN THE PROCESS FOR FIVE
TO TEN YEARS.
IF A BE FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN COMES
ALONG FIVE SECONDS WE ARE GOING
TO SEE A FAR FEWER NEW HOUSING
PROJECTS IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
ON BEHALF UP.
OF OUR BUILDER AND ALL FOR
CLIENTS.
I WE ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO ON AB
FIFTEEN OF SIX THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND FINAL
WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIFTY NO SIX FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
IT'S MURDER MEMBERS OF THE
COSTA HAWKINS RENTAL HOUSING ACT
WAS A BIPARTISAN COMPROMISE A
REACHED BY A BROAD SPECTRUM OF
HOUSING GROUPS BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE.
AB FIFTEEN NO SIX SEEKS TO UNDO
THIS LONGSTANDING LAW BY
REPEALING IT IN ITS ENTIRETY.
THIS BILL WOULD DISCOURAGE THE
CREATION OF RENTAL HOUSING AND
IMPAIR HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
WHICH IS ANTITHETICAL TO THE
STATED GOAL OF THE BILL.
NEEDLESS TO SAY CA OUR
CONTINUES TO BE A MAJOR
PROPONENT OF AFFORDABLE
WORKFORCE HOUSING AND SUPPORTED
MANY OF THE BILL'S CONTAINED IN
LAST YEAR'S LEGISLATIVE HOUSING
PACKAGE.
THOSE MEASURES ADDRESSED THE
TWO MAIN FACETS OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
WHICH OR THE LACK OF FUNDING
AND THE LACK OF SUPPLY
ADDITIONALLY THE SUCCESSFUL
PASSAGE OF MANY OF THOSE
MEASURES. CAN BE ATTRIBUTED.
AND WAS ACHIEVED THROUGH
COMPROMISE IN BRINGING HOUSING
ADVOCATES TOGETHER FROM ALL
SIDES.
AND SEE OUR FEELS AS THOUGH.
WILD HOUSING PACKAGE WAS
SUCCESSFUL WE FEEL AS THOUGH WE
TOOK TWO STEPS FORWARD WITH
RESPECT THAT HOUSING PACKAGE IN
TERMS OF HELPING TO ALLEVIATE
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
BUT NOW WITH AB FIFTEEN NO SIX
WE FEEL IS THAT WE'RE TAKING A
STEP BACKWARDS.
AND THE REASON WHY I SAY THAT
IS BECAUSE AB FIFTEEN OF SIX
NEITHER ADDRESSES THE LACK OF
FUNDING NOR THE LACK OF SUPPLY
AND TO THE CONTRARY WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY DIMINISH EXISTING
RENTAL HOUSING STOCK. AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW HOUSING
THAT'S A CERTAINLY SIERRA LOOKS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE.
ON OTHER.
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITHOUT
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITTEE LEMME ASK IF THERE
ANY QUESTIONS.
ABSOLUTELY SO ARE WE WILL IF
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS I
ACTUALLY HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
BUT IF THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS.
WE CAN PROCEED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEN CONTINUE TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION.
DOCTOR WHAT.
PALM THINK YOU MISTER BLOOM FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I DO
HAVE A QUESTION I I AM NEW TO
THIS COMMITTEE. SO I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE ELLIS ACT
SO.
IS AT A STATE ACT A FEDERAL ACT.
AND WHY IS THAT NOT UNDER
CONSIDERATION FOR POTENTIAL
REFORM AS WELL.
ALAS. ALAS MS REAGAN TO ADDRESS
THAT QUESTION IF THAT'S ALRIGHT
WITH YOU AND WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU
SO VOTE FROM THE OUTSIDE IS A
STATE LAW IT WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX.
AND THAT WAS IN RESPONSE TO A
SUPREME COURT CASE WHICH
PROHIBITED LANDLORDS FROM
EXITING THE RENTAL MARKET SO IT
WAS DESIGNED TO ALLOW LANDLORDS
WHO NO LONGER WANTED TO BE
LANDLORDS.
TO PEGS AT THE RENTAL MARKET THE
PROBLEM IS IS WHEN COSTA HAWKINS
WAS PASSED LATER IT THEN CREATED
THIS THAT AND AS RENTS HAVE
CONTINUE TO SKYROCKET TO WHERE
THEY ARE TODAY. IT'S WHEN IT'S
USED IN CONJUNCTION WITH ELLIS
AND THAT'S WHY THE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS IS IMPORTANT IS
BECAUSE ELLIS ITSELF IS NOT SO
PROBLEMATIC BUT IT CREATES THIS
INCENTIVE. TO DRIVE TENANTS OUT
OF ENTIRE BUILDINGS SO THAT THEN
THE LANDLORD CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE ABILITY TO REROUTE THOSE
UNITS AT MARKET RATES. AND THE
ELLIS ACT DOES PROVIDE PENALTIES
FOR DOING SO BUT THOSE PENALTIES
ARE SO MEAGER. THAT THE PROFITS
TO BE MADE ENCOURAGE LANDLORDS
TO ABUSE BOTH OF THESE LAWS AND
THEREFORE REDUCES THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUPPLY DRASTICALLY.
THE OPPOSITION HAVE A UNIQUE.
I THINK THE ONLY THING I WOULD
ADD THE ELLIS ACT DOES ALLOW
RENTAL PROPERTIES TO GO OUT OF
BUSINESS BUT YOU CANNOT RE
RANCHER UNITS THERE ARE
PENALTIES FOR DOING SO IN OF
CITIES ARE ENFORCING THOSE. I
WOULD TURN TO THE CITY AND SAY
WHY ARE YOU ENFORCING THOSE LAWS
YOU HAVE TO GO OUT OF THE RENTAL
HOUSING BUSINESS YOU HAVE TO
CONVERT IT TO YOUR OWNER
OCCUPIED OR NOT. I USE IT AT ALL
SO THOSE ARE THE ONLY ALLOWANCES
IF YOU DECIDE TO TAKE YOUR
RENTAL UNIT OFF OF THE MARKET.
I'M.
NO THE QUESTION THAT JUST A
QUESTION I'M.
QUITE FRANKLY I AM NOT USE TO
SEEING A BILL THAT HAS BASICALLY
JUST ONE LINE.
SO THERE.
SO MY QUESTION IS.
WHERE THERE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
IF YOU MISTER BLOOM DID YOU MEET
WITH BOTH SIDES AND BECAUSE
TYPICALLY WE SEE IN OUR PROCESS
WE USUALLY SEE? BILLS COME
FORWARD AND PROPOSED A MET
AMENDMENTS AND SO ON BUT I HAVE.
I'M JUST CURIOUS AS OUR BEEN A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS HERE TO
BRING EVERYONE TOGETHER WE HAVE
BEEN.
OPENING CONTINUE TO BE OPEN TO
DISCUSSIONS WITH.
ANY AND ALL SIDES ON THIS ISSUE
THERE HAVE BEEN CONVERSATIONS
BUT.
THIS IS A VERY POLARIZED ISSUE
AND FRANKLY NOT THAT MANY.
GOT PEOPLE HAVE.
HAVE RESPONDED WITH ANYTHING
OTHER THAN.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
SO SO THEY'RE THEY'RE REALLY
HAVE HAS THE I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS.
YOU SAID THERE BECAUSE IT HAS
OUR BEEN ANY SORT STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS
IS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT
HOW WE GOT WHERE WE HER
SPECIFICALLY WHAT YOU MEAN BY
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
OVER SUPERFINAL BRING NORMAL HE
REBUILDING PROCESS WHERE PEOPLE
ARE INVITED TO TWO WAY AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND COME TO OUR
OFFICE.
MIGHT I HAVE AN OPEN DOOR
POLICY AND AND IN MY OFFICE WE
DON'T TURN ANYONE AWAY FOR A.
FROM CONVERSATION AND.
.
THAT THAT DOOR WILL REMAIN OPEN.
DOCTOR WELL ANSWER THE QUESTION
IN PART SLIGHTLY DIFFERENTLY I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN
VERY WILLING TO CONVENE. A
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATION IF ONE
IS DESIRE BUT AT THIS POINT WITH
THIS ISSUE. AYE I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THERE HASN'T BEEN A
LOT OF INTEREST TO.
TO ENGAGE WITH THAT BY EITHER
SIDE.
TAKE THE MESSENGER ELECT UNUSUAL
LITTLE MORE ARTICULATE AND LESS
AND WILL LIKE TO CONTRADICT
THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MR STONE.
THANK YOU IT'S BLOOM AT THIS
POINT PROP YOU COULD ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS BY. THE THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE.
THE CLAIM FOR THE FOR LACK OF
HOUSING THAT THAT THIS IS GOING
TO DRIVE. IT CONTINUE.
LACK OF HOUSING I THINK FOR
THOSE OF US. WHO'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN CONSTRUCTION OF
HOUSING IN DEVELOPMENT IN.
OUR JURISDICTIONS AS A AS OF
LOCAL ELECTED AS WE HEAR THAT
QUITE A BIT DOESN'T ALWAYS.
PAN OUT TO BE. EXACTLY TRUE AND
ESPECIALLY WITH A AN ISSUE LIKE
THIS THAT THAT IS SO POLARIZED
EVERYONE'S KIND OF JUMPING INTO
THE MOST.
EXTREME.
POSITION ON IT IN IN ORDER TO
MAKE A POINTS BUT I THINK WE DO
NEED TO BE COGNIZANT. OF ANY
BALANCING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
IF WE ARE GOING TO BE PROVIDING
SOME POTENTIAL THREAT TO THE
ABILITY TO DEVELOP NEW HOUSING
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME HOUSING
RENTAL HOUSING WHICH IS VERY.
NEEDED IN A LOT OF OUR AREAS
COASTAL JURISDICTIONS THAT THAT
HAVE A REAL DEARTH OF OF RENTAL
HOUSING SUCH HOPING THAT YOU
COULD ADDRESS THAT
I CERTAINLY.
AGREE WITH YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE THAT IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
IT'S OF GREAT CONCERN TO ME.
AS A.
SUPPORTER OF AND AUTHOR OF.
SOME OF THOSE BILLS THAT ARE
INTENDED TO INCREASE THE HOUSING
SUPPLY THINK IT'S A CRITICAL
ISSUE OF MR PRESS AND I THINK IN
AT SOME OF THE COMMENTS ON THAT
TO. ON SPECIFICS ABOUT IT NAMED
HIM AND AND. AND THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION AND IT'S ONE OF THE
GREAT FRUSTRATIONS OF THOSE OF
US WHO.
SUPPORT RENT CONTROL LAWS THAT
SO OFTEN AND THE ARGUMENT IS
ADVANCED WITH NO DATA TO SUPPORT
IT WHATSOEVER THAT THE
IMPOSITION OF RENT CONTROL AND A
COMMUNITY WILL LEAD. TO.
NO NEW CONSTRUCTION OR
DETERRENCE CUT TO CONSTRUCTION
THESE ARE THE SAME ARGUMENTS
THAT ARE MADE EVERY TIME AGAINST
RENT CONTROL BEFORE CITY ADOPT
SENT. AND IT DOES NOT PAN OUT TO
FACTORS THAT GO INTO WHETHER
HOUSING GETS BUILT OBVIOUSLY
INCLUDING WHAT INTEREST RATES
ARE.
MATERIALS COST ZONING LAWS ON
AND THE INDUSTRY UNDERSTANDABLY
POINTS TO RENT CONTROL.
AS A DETERRENT TO HOUSING I
WANTED TO JUST IN RESPONSE THE
FOCUS THERE HAVE BEEN SPECIFIC
STUDIES.
THAT THAT SUPPORT THE POSITION
THAT NOT ONLY IS RANKED OWN NOT
TO TURN CONSTRUCTION WHO ARE FOR
THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THAT ESTABLISHED THE
RENT CONTROL DID NOT ADVERSELY.
IMPACT THE CONSTRUCTION OF
RENTAL HOUSING.
THERE WAS IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE STUDY BY APPLE BAND THAT WAS
PREPARED FOR THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE.
THAT ESTABLISHED NOT ONLY THAT
RENT CONTROL PRIMARILY BENEFITS
A LITTLE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WHICH
WE ALL KNOW UP BUT ALSO THAT IT
DID NOT DSCOURAGE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF OF NEW HOUSING.
AND IN FACT THAT BERKELEY AND
SANTA MONICA TO CITIES THAT HAD
STRICT.
RENT CONTROL WITH VACANCY
CONTROL PROVISIONS ACTUALLY DID
BETTER THAN OTHERS.
CITIES ON AND STOOD OUT FOR
THEIR PRODUCTION AUTHORED WHAT'S
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX THE
BERKELEY RAMP OR COMMISSIONED A
STUDY LOOKING AT NINETEEN NINETY
SIX TO TWO THOUSAND FIVE
CONSTRUCTION. AYE AND FOUND A
HIGHER PRODUCTION.
OF HOUSING PER CAPITA IN RENT
CONTROL CITIES WHEN THEY STUDIED
ALL THE BAY AREA CITIES AND MOST
RECENTLY JUST LAST YEAR OF THE
HAAS INSTITUTE I ISSUED A STUDY.
AND THEY SAID AYE AYE QUOTE
WHEN WE LOOK AT HOUSING TRYING
TO HALT A PRODUCTION.
I THINK YOU AND THEN I ALSO ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT HAS NOT
REALLY BEEN RAISED BUT I BUT I
KNOW IS THE KEY ISSUE. IS THE
ONE OF THE.
ECONOMICS AND I THINK MOST
ECONOMISTS FEEL THE RENT CONTROL
IS A BIT OF A CHALLENGE OF
COURSE A LOT OF WHAT WE DO IS
NOT.
STRICTLY BY THE BOOK WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT ECONOMISTS WANT
OR DON'T WANT.
OUR ENTIRE TAX SYSTEM.
WHAT DOES NOT MAKE MUCH ECONOMIC
SENSE AND SO FOR US AGAIN THERE
THERE ARE TRADE OFFS WHEN WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING AND I DON'T
DISAGREE? WITH THE ANALYSES OF
THE IMPACT THAT GREAT CONTROL
DOES HAVE ON THE ECONOMY BUT YET
WE'RE WE'RE PLAYING WITH AN
ECONOMY THAT IS SURE
SO.
HAS PROGRESSED SO FAR IN ONE
PARTICULAR DIRECTION THAT
SOMETIMES IT IS UP TO GOVERNMENT
PROVIDE SOME BALANCE IN IN THE
RAIN THAT IT SO PERHAPS YOU
COULD COMMENT ON. THAT THE
ECONOMICS OF IT BUT COURSE.
IT'S IT'S A LITTLE BIT HEAVILY
LOADED BECAUSE ALL WE'RE DOING
IS APPEALING COSTA HAWKINS.
BUT I THINK LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ARE GONNA HAVE TO DO THEIR OWN
ECONOMICANALYSIS ABOUT WHAT
THAT IMPACT IS VERSES THEIR
PARTICULAR RENTAL MARKET. WHAT
THEIR DEMOGRAPHICS ARE WHAT
THEIR SUPPLIES ARE WITH THEIR
DEMANDS ARE SO IT'S
IT'S?
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY EASY THING
TO ANSWER BUT I JUST
LOOKING FOR A COMMENT ON HOW WE
BALANCE THE THE ECONOMIC FOR THE
BALLOT ECONOMIC CRITICISMS.
OF.
WHAT RATE CONTROL DOES VERSUS
OPENING THIS UP TO JURISDICTIONS
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION?
I'LL JUST MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT I
THINK REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS.
ALLOWING
THE INDIVIDUAL CITIES TO ADDRESS
THEIR PARTICULAR ECONOMIC NEEDS
IS THE BALANCE THAT NEEDS TO BE
STRUCK
SO IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED THAT
AREAS THAT ARE HARDEST HIT BY
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
WHERE. FAMILIES ARE BEING
DISPLACED THEY'RE MOVING ON NOT
ONLY OUT OF THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND SOMETIMES OUT OF
THE REGION. THAT HARMS THESE
AREAS ECONOMICALLY IT ALSO HARMS
USERS ECONOMICALLY WHEN PEOPLE
CAN'T LIVE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
LIVE CLOSE TO WHERE THEY WORK
THEY CAN'T BE PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY. THAT'S A WELL
DOCUMENTED ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
SO ALLOWING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO GOVERN TO DECIDE WHAT
SOLUTIONS ARE BASS BY NOT TAKING
AWAY ALL OF THE TOOLS IN THEIR
TOOL BOX.
THAT WILL EASE THAT ECONOMIC
STRESS.
THANK YOU A SHOULD I NAY FROM
WEST HOLLYWOOD BUT. BECAUSE THE
BAY AREA WHERE THE ECONOMY IS
BOOMING BY. HOUSING CRISIS IS
VERY VERY REAL AND IN THE MIDDLE
OF THAT ECONOMIC BOOM THE
UNDERLYING. ECONOMIC LOSS FOR
VARIOUS STRAT OF OUR SOCIETY IS
REALLY CRITICAL
THAT THEY AREAS TO SUCH A
DICHOTOMY OF OF WIN AND LOSE
RIGHT IN THE SAME AREAS THAT.
IT'S REALLY VERY DIFFICULT
PROBLEM AT AT ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE
WE SEE THAT SAME DYNAMIC IN WEST
HOLLYWOOD AND IN SANTA MONICA.
IN WEST LOS ANGELES.
IN MY DISTRICT.
SO I THINK WE ACTUALLY TRY
SIERRA FORTUNATELY WE SHARE.
THE SAME THE SAME ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE LET'S
TURN IT OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR
MISTER STEINORTH.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER
BRING THIS BILL FORD I THINK IS
A DISCUSSION THAT. HAS BEEN.
DISKS REALLY BROUGHT AROUND FOR
A LONG TIME IN AND I TAKE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE OF.
COURSE I'M I'M LOOKING AT IT
FROM THE SIDE OF HOW WE INCREASE
THE. SUPPLY OF HOUSING
WOULD BE ABLE TO REALLY
PROVIDING AND SOLVE ALL OF THESE
CONCERNS I I WANTED TO ASK A
COUPLE QUESTIONS THE OPPOSITION
IF YOU DON'T MIND. DEALING WITH
SUPPLY QUESTIONS.
.
SO I'VE READ THE RECENTLY A
REPORT IT'S RECOMMENDING THAT
HOUSING INCENTIVIZING THE
BUILDING OF MORE HOUSING IS
BEING THE BEST APPROACHES TO
SOLVING THE STATEWIDE HOUSING
CRISIS.
WOULDN'T RENT CONTROL REALLY PUT
A DAMPER ON.
PEOPLE'S INCENTIVES TO BUY ME
BY WHAT IT DEVELOPER BUILD MORE
HOMES ARE WHY WOULD A A
HOMEOWNER DECIDE TO RENT OUT
THEIR HOME. IF THEY DO NOT HAVE
CONTROL OVER THEIR OWN PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
QUESTION YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT
THE STATE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
DID SAY THAT THAT RENT CONTROL
WILL DO NOTHING TO INCREASE
HOUSING SUPPLY AND IN FACT WOULD
INTERFERE WITH HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION. IS PROBABLY THE
DUELING.
THE DUELING STUDIES IF YOU WILL
STANFORD UNIVERSITY FOUND IT
CITIES WITH LANDLORDS WHOSE
PROPERTIES WERE COVERED BY RENT
CONTROL RUSE REDUCE THEIR SUPPLY
BY FIFTEEN PERCENT. AGAIN WE
HAVE THE SMALL OWNERS WANTING TO
GET OUT OF THE BUSINESS FOR FEAR
OF RENT CONTROL ON THE WAY THAT
WOULD APPLY TO SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES. SO IF IN FACT WE END UP
WITH EXTREME FORMS OF RENT
CONTROL LIKE WE DO THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WHEN WE SAW.
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
SLOWING DOWN I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE THAT IN
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
MISS RAY ALSO HAS A A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT BECAUSE THE
DEVELOPERS OF TOLD HER WE'RE
GONNA STOP WE'RE GONNA STOP
RIGHT NOW WE WANT TO SEE WHAT
THE STATE INITIATIVE WILL DO AND
IF IT DOES ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO PASS MORE
EXTREME FORMS OF RENT CONTROL
WERE NOT GOING TO PROCEED.
VERY GOOD MY CONCERN IS THAT
THIS WILL HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT
ON DEVELOPMENT OF NEW HOMES WE
RECENTLY SAW WITH THE TRAGIC
FIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THE ESTIMATES ARE TEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED NINETEEN
HOMES WERE DESTROYED IN THOSE
PLACES. YOU KNOW MY CONCERN IS
WHAT'S THE INCENTIVE FOR
DEVELOPERS AND FOR HOMEOWNERS TO
GO AHEAD AND AND REBUILD OR TO
REPURCHASE THOSE HOMES AB AND
THEN WE COUPLE THAT ALSO WITH.
THE DISCUSSIONS OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS ABOUT APPLYING SPLIT
ROLE.
SPLIT WILL TAXATION WHICH WOULD
LEAD YOU TO MODIFY PROP THIRTEEN
ANY ANY COMMERCIAL CONSTRUCTION
OR ANY HOUSING UNITS SINGLE
FAMILY DWELLING THAT WOULD BE
OPEN FOR RENT WOULD THEN BE. I'M
SUBJECT TO CURRENT REASSESSMENT
OF THE VALUE OF THE PROPERTY
HOW IN THE WORLD COULD YOU. TAKE
THOSE TWO ELEMENTS AND SAY THAT
WE WANT TO.
REVALUED THE PROPERTY TAXES AND
BUT YET WE'RE GOING TO CONTROL
HOW MUCH YOU'RE ABLE TO RENT
YOUR YOUR PERSONAL PRIVATE
PROPERTY FOR.
YOU HAVE AN INCREASE IN COST ON
ONE SIDE YOU HAVE A.
DECREASES SPARSE THE AMOUNT
YOU'RE ABLE TO CHARGE HOW IN THE
WORLD TO WE POSSIBLY SEE THAT WE
WOULD HAVE PEOPLE HOLD ON TO
HOMES AND NOT JUST GO AHEAD AND
SELL THEM.
AND YET YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT I
THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
ALSO FACE IN FACT EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM FACES IS THAT THE%
ENEMIES OF THE NOT MY BACKYARD
INDIVIDUALS COME TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. PUT PRESSURE ON
THE OFFICIALS TO STOP HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION THIS IS A DREAM
COME TRUE FOR THE NEWBIES THEY
CAN STOP HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING TO ADD
TO THE PROBLEM AS WE GO FORWARD.
IF WE DON'T ALL TOGETHER THE
SNAPPERS IN THE ROOM DON'T COME
TOGETHER WE ALL COME TOGETHER
AND PROMOTE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
IF WE ALL CAME TOGETHER IN THE
BUSES AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
AND DEMANDED THE HOUSING
PRODUCTION WE WOULD SEE A HUGE
CHANGE IN OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WELL IF I IF IF I
MIGHT.
I THINK GOT FOR THE MOST PART
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM DO SUPPORT
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION CERTAINLY.
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
SUPPORTS HOUSING CONSTRUCTION I
CAN TELL YOU THAT.
AND.
FOR RENT CONTROL JURISDICTIONS
THAT I MONITOR VERY CLOSELY UMP
SAN FRANCISCO SANTA MONICA WEST
HOLLYWOOD LOS ANGELES.
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING.
HAS CONTINUED APACE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES WE VALUE HOUSING THE
DEBATE IN THESE RENT CONTROL
CITIES IS OVER HOW MUCH HOUSING
NOT WHETHER TO BUILD HOUSING AND
I WOULD DARE SAY THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES OUT PACE. MANY
OTHERS IN THE STATE THAT HAVE NO
RENT CONTROL JURISDICTION
THERE'S YOU KNOW WE CAN.
AUTHORIAL TERMS LIKE GUT NIMBY
ISM ALL DAY LONG THAT'S NOT WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT PROTECTING.
ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS FROM
EXORBITANT RENT INCREASES AND WE
REALLY HAVE TO FOCUS OUR
ATTENTION THERE.
DEBATE OVER HOW MUCH HOUSING TO
BUILD IS A WELCOME DEBATE IN ANY
COMMUNITY I'M HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT ONE AND
YOU KNOW WHAT TO THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
THEM A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND.
WHEN WE SPOKE ABOUT THE HOUSING
PATRICK PACKAGE THAT WAS PASSED
LAST YEAR A LOT OF THAT REALLY
WE SAW REMOVING SOME OF THE
CONTROL FROM LOCAL CONTROL WEEK
WE BROUGHT A LOT OF THAT IT TO
STAY CONTROL TO BE ABLE TO
PREVENT AND. HELP WITH THE NIMBY
ASPECT OF IT BUT YET WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WE WOULD BE TURNING IT
RIGHT BACK TO VERY LOCAL CONTROL
AND PUTTING RIGHT INTO THE HANDS
OF THE ENEMY SO IT'S A WE'RE IN
A BIT OF A CONFLICT HERE. NOW
BUT YOUR POINT ABOUT TRYING TO
BUY AYE A ASSEMBLYMEMBER I DON'T
THINK THERE'S A CONFLICT IT HERE
AT ALL I THINK THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES WHERE IT'S APPROPRIATE
THAT THE STATE STEP BACK AND
SAY.
WE NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A
AYE STATEWIDE.
APPLICATION OF LAW ON
PARTICULAR ISSUES AND WE DID
THAT.
I KNOW THAT.
THAT YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR ARE
A BELIEVER IN LOCAL CONTROL AND
I AGREE TO THAT THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES ON WHICH A LITTLE MORE
LOCAL CONTROL IS THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE TO GO THERE'S NO ONE SIZE
THAT FITS ALL HERE. AND I'D LIKE
TO SAY ALSO THAT.
THAT.
WHEN WHAT WE TALK ABOUT HOUSING
SUPPLY THE ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT HERE IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPLY AND IF
YOU LOOK AT MANY COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING MY OWN. UNLESS WE ARE
BUILDING DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE HOUSING
THAT IS BEING BUILT TODAY IS
UNAFFORDABLE TO EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT ALSO IS
THE ISSUE THAT.
A TO ADDRESS HERE YES AND AND
MISTER BLOOM YOU AND I ARE OF
LIKE MIND ON A LOT OF THESE
AND TOPICS WE ARE YOU KNOW WE
JUST APPROACH FROM A LITTLE
DIFFERENT ANGLES. BECAUSE I ALSO
BELIEVE AND AND REALLY TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN A LOT OF WAYS I BELIEVE WE
CAN DO THAT IS BY MAKING MORE
HOUSING AFFORDABLE. WHICH IS
INCREASE THE OVERALL SUPPLY
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE IS A SUPPLY AND
DEMAND ISSUE.
IT MY OPINION WE HAVE A LOT OF.
WE WE HAVE A LOT OF A DEMAND AS
FAR AS THE AMOUNT OF UNITS ARE
COMING IN FOR FOR.
.
WE YOU KNOW JOBS BUT NOT AS MANY
UNITS FOR HOUSING AND SPECIALLY
IN THESE URBAN AREAS OF THE
COSTA COMMUNITIES THAT WE'VE
BEEN REFERRING TO. SO BUT LET'S
DON'T CHANGE THE TOPIC JUST A
LITTLE BIT LET'S TALK ABOUT IN
ITS IN CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE DO
HAVE A RIGHT CONTROL.
IT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN RENT CONTROL
UNITS DO COMPLAIN ABOUT THE
MAINTENANCE IN THE UPKEEP OF THE
PROPERTIES.
DOESN'T RENT CONTROL DISCOURAGE
THE UPKEEP AND MODERNIZATION
FRIENDLINESS LANDLORDS NOT BEING
ABLE TO SEE A RETURN ON THEIR
INVESTORS MAY AGAIN I'M GONNA AS
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
PLEASE.
DO NOT EXPRESS BUCKLEY YOUR
PROSPECTIVE AGAIN THE JAZZ HANDS
ON THE THUMBS ARE FINE BUT.
WE DON'T WANT.
THAT THE CONVERSATION BE
INTERRUPTED.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR I THINK
GOD IS REAGANISM THE BEST
POSITION ANSWERED THANK YOU I'M
GLAD YOU ASKED THAT QUESTION
BECAUSE THAT'S UP A LARGE
MISCONCEPTION THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HOLD ABOUT RENT CONTROL I
THINK ONE POINT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO MAKE.
A THE CASE LAW REQUIRES THAT ANY
RENT CONTROL ORDINANCE THAT'S IT
THAT'S PASSED
MUST GUARANTEE A PROPERTY OWNER
A FAIR RETURN A FAIR AND
REASONABLE RETURN. ON HIS OR HER
INVESTMENT SO THAT IS WHY THIS
ARGUMENT THAT IT DISINCENTIVE
VISES CONSTRUCTION IS COULD
COMPLETE RED HERRING BECAUSE
CASE LAW PROHIBITS THAT.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS
THE SAME GOES TO FOR THE
MAINTENANCE OF THESE PROPERTIES.
IF A IF A LANDLORD FINDS THAT HE
OR SHE IS HAVING TO EXPEND
CAPITAL. INVESTMENT IN A IN A
MAIN THAT'S PROJECT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE.
COME TO THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
THOSE RENTING THOSE RENTAL RATES
COULD BE INCREASED ON THAT BASIS
SO ALL OF THESE ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE RAISING HAVE BEEN. I'M
ALREADY ADDRESSED IN EITHER BY
CASE LAW OR BY THE ORDINANCES
UNDER WHICH THESE LAWS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED.
I'M AND I JUST I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ADD JOBS THAT I SAT ON THE ON
THE RENT BOARD IN IN OAKLAND.
AND SO FOR CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
LANDLORDS WERE ABLE TO COME AS
AN AND PETITION TO GET RENT
INCREASES FOR THOSE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS THEY ALSO DURING
THE DURING THE BIG DEBT CRISIS
IN THE HOUSING CRISIS. I'M
FACING THEIR LOANS THEY WERE
ABLE TO GET INCREASES I MEAN
INCREASES IN THEIR RENTS AND
SPECIFICALLY APPLY FOR THOSE
INCREASES.
BUT TENANTS BECAUSE OF COSTA
HAWKINS WERE NOT ABLE TO GET
INCREASES SPECIFICALLY IN THE
SITUATION WE HAVE NOW WITH THIS
HOUSING SHORTAGE HOUSING CRISIS
IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
HAPPENED TO LANDLORDS DOING
THOSE FAULTY LOANS. BUT BECAUSE
WE HAVE THIS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT AND A LAW
THAT'S BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS WE CAN'T LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CAN'T. MEET THE
NEED OF THEIR RESIDENTS TO KIND
OF AUGMENT THE RED SPECIFICALLY
IN A LOT OF IN IN THE BAY AREA
COMMUNITIES BUT BASICALLY WHEN I
WAS ON THE COUNCIL IN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
SO BASIS SO IT'S NOT A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL IT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED ON THE
LOCAL LEVELS SO THAT THEY CAN
REALLY SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THIS
IS A. IS A HISTORICAL MOMENT
THAT WE'RE FACING IN CALIFORNIA.
IF I COULD ASK FOR THE
OPPOSITION TO RESPOND AS WELL
PLEASE I THINK THE ONLY THING.
WHAT I WOULD ADD IS WHEN YOU
HAVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
ONLY THAT ROLL BACK RENTS WHEN
THEY WERE FIRST?
ADOPTED SOME OF THE OWNERS
NEVER CAUGHT UP BECAUSE TENNIS
NEVER MOVED WITH THE VACANCY DE
CONTROL THAT'S ALLOWED UNDER
COSTA HAWKINS.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE INCREASES IT
ONLY ALLOWED UP TO SIXTY PERCENT
OF THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THAT IS NOT IN
FACT SOMETHING THAT HELPS THE
LANDLORD. A RECOUP COSTS AND.
EVEN THOUGH IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS THEY WILL ALLOW
YOU TO COME BEFORE OF THE RAM
BORDEN ASK.
FOR AN INCREASE IS NOT ALWAYS
GRANTED TOWARDS GRANTED OVER
THIRTY YEARS DEPENDING UPON WHAT
YOU'VE DONE TO YOUR PROPERTY SO
IT AGAIN IT'S NOT A SURE THING
AND I THINK THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
WITH.
THE RENT CONTROL IN OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
OKAY AND THEN JUST MY FINAL
QUESTIONS WITH THE CHAIRS.
PERMISSION I JUST WANNA ASK.
FOR RENT CONTROL AN OBJECT IS
TO.
IT IS IT MEANS TESTED.
MEANS TESTING.
NO LONGER.
I WAS IS SHORT ANSWER IS NO IT'S
NOT MEANS TESTING SOMETIMES THE
INDUSTRY.
HAVE PROPOSES THAT IT'S BEEN
FLOATED AT DIFFERENT TIMES IT'S
GENERALLY VIEWED WHEN YOU DIG
INTO IT AS A SOLUTION LOOKING
FOR A PROBLEM IN THAT TENANTS
ARE OVERWHELMINGLY LOW IN MY.
INCOME AND THOSE WHO ARE VERY
HIGH INCOME GO OFTEN TEND TO GO
OFF AND BUY PROPERTY.
AND THERE'S ALSO A VERY
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS AROUND
PRIVACY INVASION AND ALSO
POTENTIAL DISCRIMINATION THAT
ARE ONLY HIGHER INCOME TENANTS
WHO WOULD BE EXEMPT FROM RENT
CONTROL IN SOME WAY WOULD BE
RENTED TOO SO THAT'S WHY.
ADVOCATES GENERALLY ARE OPPOSED
AND WHY NONE OF THE
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE RENT
CONTROL ALTHOUGH THEY'VE
DISCUSSED THAT.
OVER THE YEARS WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY DIG INTO IT.
USUALLY THE BETTER POLICY IT IS
TO.
IS TO NOT MEANS TESTED THERE'S
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF THAT THAT JUST
HAPPENS NATURALLY BASED ON THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF WHO RENTS
ASSAULTED SIMPLY SOMEONE MAKING
MINIMUM WAGE WOULD HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS TO THE SAME UNIT AS
SOMEONE MAKING A MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR.
BUT ALSO IN A SITUATION AS
MYSELF WHO SERVED AS YOU KNOW
POLICY MAKER FOR THE STATE AND
MY HUSBAND SERVED AS A VETERAN.
YOU KNOW WHERE MIDDLE INCOME
WE'RE DOING FINE YOU KNOW INCOME
WISE YOU THINK BUT OUR LANDLORD
RAISE OUR RENT BY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS RENT A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME WITH LIVE THERE FOR
TEN YEARS. AND WE WERE FACED
WITH SAYING DO WE HAVE TO MOVE
OUR KIDS FROM THE HOME THAT
THEY'VE LIVED IN THEIR WHOLE
LIVES ARE WE GONNA HAVE TO
CHANGE THEIR SCHOOLS ARE WE
GONNA HAVE TO MOVE. AWAY FROM
GRANDPARENTS I MEAN IT ISN'T AN
ISSUE OF LIKE IT'S NOT AN ISSUE
OF CLASS
IT'S AN ISSUE OF A HUMAN RIGHT
IN TERMS OF A RIGHT TO
STABILITY.
AND SO THAT DOESN'T MATTER
WHETHER OR NOT I'M A MIDDLE
CLASS PERSON WHETHER OR NOT I'M
A POOR PERSON WHETHER NOT A RICH
PERSON WHO HAS MILLION DOLLAR
HOME.
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO HAVE
STABLE HOUSING AND THAT'S THAT
GOES IN LINE WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO WE NEED TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE NEED
TO MAINTAIN STABILITY FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE READY HOUSE.
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T WE'RE GONNA
JUST CABS CIRCULAR CONTINUOUS
PROBLEM.
THANK YOU MISTER STEINORTH
MISTER CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
OBVIOUSLY HIGH COSTS OF OUR
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA IS A
SERIOUS.
.
TO THE LEVEL OF OF PRICES AND.
HOT TOPIC AS A DEMONSTRATED UP.
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
AND ALSO ON THE OR WEIGHS IN ON
OUR SIDE.
UNDERSTAND SEVERAL HUNDRED SO
WHAT PEOPLE ARE ALL DAYER
EITHER.
IN SUPPORT WAR OPPOSITION. A LET
ME EXPRESS MY VIEW.
AND.
ADD JUST SOME GENERAL QUESTIONS.
BASICALLY.
THAT IS SO AB FIFTEEN OR SIX IT
IS OUR.
TO REPEAL.
R. COSTA HAWKINS SO. NOT RENTAL
HOUSING ACT.
YOU ARE NOT QUITE THE DIRECTLY
SAYING THAT UP BUT THE. I DON'T
FEEL.
THAT THE REPEATING HIS TO ASK
THE IS GONNA.
TO SOLVE THE.
SUCH A HIGH COST OF HOUSING.
PROBLEMS.
AND THE WE ARE DEBATING US OUT
HERE WAS IN KHAN SO.
IT WOULD HELP.
ON THE OTHER HAND I SNUCK WILL
NOT ACCEPT. IS NOT GONNA HELP X.
IS GONNA EXACERBATE.
OF THE SITUATION.
FROM.
THROUGHOUT THOSE STATE.
THE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OUT
WOULD INITIATE.
YEAH FOR THE RENT CONTROL.
WHERE? DO YOU THINK A MAYBE.
ASSEMBLYMAN BLOOM TEN ANSWERED
THAT QUESTION.
ON DO YOU BELIEVE.
THIS TO REPEALING.
THIS ACT DOT IS GONNA TRULY.
ELIMINATE.
OUR DOG GO CRISES SET IN THE
PROBLEM WE ARE FACING.
BEFORE YOU ANSWER THEM IN MY
OBSERVATION IS NOT.
UP BECAUSE OF AS YOU MENTIONED
THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL.
NO CITIES I THINK OF.
NEAR SOMEWHERE DOESN'T OFF
FIFTEEN. A LOCALLY A S. ON A
MONICA.
.
LOS ANGELES.
APOLLO ONTO A BEVERLY HILLS.
AND SOME FRANCISCO PALM SPRINGS
ISIS.
SEVERAL OF THOSE CITIES AND
NAMED THE WHO.
I HAVE ADOPTED NO RENT CONTROL.
ARE THE CITY'S.
HAVE YOU CITIES SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
HAVE YOU DONE ANY COMPARISON IS
STUDIES.
THAT THE THE.
OUT MANNED SO. IN THE CITIES ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE AFFORDABLE.
THEN THE OTHER CITIES SO THAT
OUR.
THAT HAVE NOT PUT UP DID.
OF THE OUTRAGE CUANDO CONTROL
MEASURES DUST SO BUMPY SECOND
SECONDARY RUSSIA.
AND ALSO.
.
FURTHER.
EXPANSION.
OF Lú RENT CONTROL POSSIBILITY
FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
AND THE OR SO NOT ANY NEW
CONSTRUCTION HOMES SO WHICH WERE
EXAM.
FROM RENT CONTROL.
BY IDEAS SO A COSTA HAWKINS CBO.
NOW WITH THE MANY NEW BUILDINGS
ARE. R. WOULD BE SUBJECT TO.
RENT CONTROL WORKS.
SO. IT IS THAT IS SO GOOD IN INS
INCENTIVE SO FOR.
.
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES
SO WOULD BE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
BUILD THE MORE AFFORDABLE HOMES.
AT WE HEARD CUSTOM PLY AND
DEMAND THAT TO ME.
OUR BASIC.
.
THEORY OF THE ECONOMY AS A
SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
IF A SUPPLY IS. SUFFICIENT THAT
THE PLANNING.
THE COST OR QUOTA.
AND THE WE ARE LIMITING THE
CONSTRUCTION.
WE ARE DE.
INCENTIVIZING.
DR CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES TO A
FOOT OF BUILDING. AFFORDABLE
HOMES.
AND THAT THAT WOULD BE MAYBE
THIRD.
AND THE NORMAL FORCE THE
QUESTION MIGHT BE.
TAKEN THOSE.
I HAVE ABOUT HALF.
NOT TOO MANY. HAVE YOU THOUGHT
ABOUT. COMING UP.
WHICH VIA OPPOSITE.
PROVIDING INCENTIVES UP FOR
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES TO BUILD
MORE HOMES A SUCH AS SO
REMOVING.
SEEK HiA REQUIREMENTS
CALIFORNIA IS SO NOTORIOUS.
ARE ON THE REGULATION ITSELF FOR
ANY BUSINESS BUT THEN PUT. IN
HOUSING.
OUR LAST TIME WHEN I HEARD GOV
PROBABLY DON'T COSTS ARE.
HAS GONE OUT THE WINDOW SO
MAYOR OR PROCEDURE IRVINE. ONE
YOU NEED JUST OUT TO GET. ARE
PERMITTED ON ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS.
WE'RE COSTS UP THE PERMIT IS
ARAFAT WILL COST A BEEN THERE.
OF WHEN NOT A CONDOMINIUM UNIT
OR DID FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
AND NOW WE WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE.
EASING THOSE WHO REGULARLY R.
EITHER A STATEWIDE.
ONE LOCOG OF REGULATIONS TO.
AYE IS. AND THE BILL THE MORE
OF CONSTRUCTION SO THAT WAY
OTHER BE MORE SUPPLIES AND THEN
WHEN THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPETITION.
THE PEOPLE WOULD LOWER. THE COST
OVER.
HOSTING.
BUT THE WE ARE RESTRICTING AND
THE DISINCENTIVE ON SING AND DO
YOU THINK GOD THIS IS SO RIGHT
APPROACH FOR OVERALL. IS SOUNDS
TONIGHT.
LENDL'S SO INCREASE OUR OUR IS
STILL PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA IN
HOUSING.
BUT THE LAW TO ME COMMONSENSE
TOPS ME ISN'T IT IS SO NOT THE
ANSWER IS SO NOT THE PROBLEM IT
HAS COSTA IS SOME MORE OFF OUR.
SUPPLY AND WITHIN THE DEMAND AND
THE DISINCENTIVE FIVE.
INCENTIVIZING THE CONSTRUCTION
COMPANIES TO APPEAR IN THE WAR
HOUSING.
SO WHY CAN WE WHY DON'T WE IN
OUR ASK.
NAY HOMES TO BE BUILT UP BY.
ENCOURAGING THING ENCOURAGING
THEM AND THEN ALSO REMOVING SO
ALL THE HER DOING SO SUCH AS A
SEQUEL AND THE ROLE LOCAL
REGULATIONS.
THAT'S MY LAST QUESTION.
THANK YOU MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
I MUST SAY I'M GRATEFUL THAT
THERE WASN'T A NUMBER FIVE ON
YOUR ON YOUR LIST.
LET ME SEE IF I CAN WORK MY WAY
UP THROUGH YOUR QUESTION SIR.
ALL TRY TO DO IT IN ROUTE IN
REVERSE ORDER BECAUSE I WOULD
LIKE TO START WITH ASAP QUESTION
YOU RAISE ABOUT SEQUEL AND
FRANKLY I THINK.
IT WOULD BE A GRAVE ERROR FOR
US TO TURN THIS.
HEARING INTO A DEBATE ABOUT
SEAQUEST SUFFICE IT TO SAY THAT
I THINK THERE'S ROOM FOR
DISCUSSION ON THAT ON THAT
ISSUE.
.
TO SOME DEGREE CERTAINLY YOU
AND I AGREE THAT THERE IS A
SUPPLY HOUSING SUPPLY ISSUE AND
IN THE STATE.
IN FACT THAT'S WHAT MUCH OF
LAST YEAR'S HOUSING PACKAGE WAS
ABOUT.
ADDRESSING THAT SUPPLY ISSUE
WHETHER WE AGREE OR DISAGREE ON
THE SPECIFIC SOLUTIONS THAT WERE
ENACTED INTO LAW LAST YEAR EVEN
SOME OF THOSE HAT DIDN'T MAKE
IT THROUGH THE PROCESS.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS SPENT A GOOD
DEAL OF TIME ADDRESSING THAT
VERY ISSUE I WOULD LIKE TO
REEMPHASIZE THAT.
.
IF YOU AND I AND OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR WERE TO COME
TOGETHER WITH EVEN MORE.
WAYS OF PROVIDING FOR MORE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION AS I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD.
BY THE TIME WE PASSED THOSE LAWS
THOSE.
AYE DEVELOPERS WHO WANT TO
BUILD COME UP WITH PLANS TO DO
SO PUT IT THROUGH THE PROCESS IN
LOCAL COMMUNITIES BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION AND ACTUALLY.
HAVE THOSE UNITS COME ONLINE
SEVERAL YEARS AT A MINIMUM ARE
GOING TO PASS THE PIPELINE FOR
CONSTRUCTING THOSE HOMES IS VERY
LENGTHY.
AS I TRIED TO ARTICULATE IN THE
BEGINNING OF MY REMARKS.
OF
QUESTION THAT WE ARE PRESENTED
WITH HERE TODAY IS WHAT CAN WE
DO TO HELP THOSE PEOPLE WHO
TODAY. ARE BEING IMPACTED BY
RENTS THAT ARE TOO DAMN HIGH
THAT THEY CAN'T AFFORD. AND
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO FOCUS
OUR ATTENTION HERE TODAY BUT I
RESPECT AND APPRECIATE THAT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO KEEP OUR EYE
ON ALL THESE OTHER ISSUES AND
CONTINUE TO LEGISLATE. ON AT
THE.
A BILL SIGNING IN IN IN THE
FALL THAT.
R. CHAIR AND MANY OTHER MEMBERS.
ATTENDED IN THE EYE AND I WAS
THERE VIRTUALLY EVERY SPEAKER
SAID WE HAVE BEGUN. THE WORK
BUT THERE'S MUCH MUCH MORE TO DO
SO I THINK WERE IN A COURT ON
THAT.
.
WITH RESPECT TO.
THE WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
ABILITY TO TAILOR SOLUTIONS TO
THEIR OWN NEEDS AND SO YOU ARE
GOING TO FIND IF THIS BILL.
OF PASSES AND IS SIGNED INTO
LAW.
THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE GOING
TO DETERMINE WITH MORE WITH THEM
MORE REFINED PAN.
WHAT THEIR LOCAL ORDINANCES WILL
DO THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT
CREATES STATEWIDE RENT CONTROL
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT?
A THIS IS A BILL THAT ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DETERMINE
FOR THEMSELVES AS THEY ARE THE
CAN. ON WHAT ADDITIONAL OTHER
ELEMENTS THAT WERE PROHIBITED BY
COSTA HAWKINS WOULD NOW BE
INCLUDED OR NOT INCLUDED IN
THEIR LOCAL ORDINANCE.
WITH RESPECT TO YOUR SECOND
QUESTION.
.
I I WANT TO REPEAT THAT A.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
PRESERVING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND OF WAITING DISPLACEMENT AND
COMMUNITIES.
WHAT IS RENT CONTROL DOING RIGHT
NOW WITH COSTA HAWKINS?
WE SEE IN VIRTUALLY EVERY RIGHT
CONTROL JURISDICTION A
DIMINUTION OF THE NUMBER AS
RENTS GO UP AS UNITS TURN. AND.
VACANCY DE CONTROL IS
IMPLEMENTED WE SEE THE DELTA
BETWEEN AFFORDABLE AND
UNAFFORDABLE RANTS INCREASING
RATHER THAN DECREASING. AND
THAT'S A PROBLEM SO WE HAVE IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DIMINISH
NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
A.
AND FINALLY. ON THERE IS AND I
THINK I'VE I'VE ALREADY SAID
THIS BUT.
COMEY TEAR OFF.
YOUR FIRST QUESTION.
ABOUT WHETHER.
THIS BILL WILL ELIMINATE THE
PROBLEM.
A I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY ONE
BILL THAT ELIMINATES THE
PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO LOOK
ACROSS THE BOAR AT SOLUTIONS WE
HAVE ALLOWED AND I WILL TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY AS I
THINK MANY OF US SHOULD WHO COME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WE HAVE
ALLOWED FOR MANY YEARS TOOL AND
AND AT THE STATE LEVEL TO ALLOW
THIS PROBLEM TO GROW AND FASTER.
SUCH THAT WE TOOK DAY HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS THAT IS SO DEEP
AND SO WIDE THAT IT. DEMANDS A
COLLECTIVE EFFORT ON THE PART OF
ALL OF US TO SOLVE IT SO NO
THIS.
IS NOT GOING TO ELIMINATE THE
PROBLEM IT IS GOING TO
DRAMATICALLY HELP.
LET ME ARE OF COURSE SO HERE
FROM OPPOSITION ASIDE THOUGH
WHAT DO YOU ALL FEEL BETTER CAR.
IS SO TO MY COMMENTS AND
CONCERNS SO ONE NIGHT TO THAT TO
AND THE WRONG SO.
MISTER BLOOM TO THINK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE SO YOU ARE.
NOT IN THE CONTROLLING OUR YOU
KNOW ON PARTY.
UP I WON US OVER THE PROBLEM IF
I CAN BE HELP ON A SOME OF THE
PROBLEM AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
IN NOT SINGLE ASSOCIATED ALMOST
SINGLE BR IS.
WHEN I SOLVE THAT PROBLEM I
REALIZED IT.
BUT THAT IS TO SERIOUSNESS.
I'M NOT OF INTEREST BY THE
PUBLIC TO COME IN AND I FEEL
LIKE A.
THE ELIMINATION OF WITH THIS.
YOU KNOW COSTA HAWKINS SAID IS
GONNA SOLVE ENTIRE NO PROBLEM
DUSTER IMPRESSION I GET THE PART
I I WANT THE PUBLIC KNOW ABOUT
IT. BUT THAT THERE ARE SO MANY.
THE PROBLEM SET THAT THE WE
FROM THIS.
LEGISLATURE WE CREATE. NOT OF
THINGS SO SUCH AS SOME MINIMUM
WAGE.
WE WE. ARE INCREASE AYE AND THE
WORKERS SO.
CERTAIN CRITERIA OF
CONSTRUCTION NOT WORKERS TO
WOULD HAVE TO BE PAID TO IN THE
PREVAILING WAGE WHICH IS TO MUCH
MUCH A HIGH YEAR. RATE THAN THE
MARKET RATE. WE MEN DAY.
THE DEVELOPERS SOUGHT TO TREAT
THEIR.
WORK US OUT TO BE SO CALLED THE
FAIRLY PA.
BY PREVAILING WAGE WHATEVER.
DON'T YOU KNOW THAT THOSE THOSE
ARE ADDING TO THE OHIO COST OF
CONSTRUCTION.
AND ARE IN THIS OUR CAPITALISTIC
SOCIETY. NOBODY WOULD INVESTING
MONEY. IF SO.
THEY DON'T SEE THE POSSIBILITY
OF UP GOOD TO RETURN.
AND.
COSTA BUILDING IS SO HIGH BUT
THE RETURN NEWMAN OF CONTROLLING
OR YOU CANNOT HAVE OUR OF FEAR
AMONG OR PROFIT UP LIKE OF THE
MIND. ARCH.
TROLL.
SO ARE. THIS IS A CONTRADICTING
IT US AYE AYE STRUGGLE IN THIS
OP DOC ARE SO SO CLEAN ACTIVELY
HOME. EVEN THIS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL ON THE FLOOR OUT WE
NOW ARE ADDRESS THAT. IS SO.
ONE SIDE TO IS ARE LESS CONTROL
LESS OR MORE AND SO ON AFFORD
ONE THE OTHER HAND.
WE WE ARE.
BUT ENCOURAGE. WE ARE ADDING THE
COST OF CONSTRUCTION SOCIAL
CONTRADICTING
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
INDOSIAR REASSESS WHAT.
I THINK ABOUT THOSE ISSUES EVERY
DAY BUT I. WANT TO REMIND THAT.
THE COMMITTEE AND RESPECTFULLY.
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT.
WE ARE LOOKING AT.
ONE BILL THAT ADDRESSES A
DIFFERENT ISSUE FROM HOUSING
SUPPLY.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF THIS IS A
BILL THAT RESPONSE TO AN ISSUE.
REGARDING WHAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING IN THEIR EVERYDAY
LIVES TODAY THAT FIXING THE
SUPPLY IN THE FUTURE.
OUT REALLY DOESN'T HELP REALLY
DOESN'T SOLVE AND I THINK WE
SHOULD REMAIN FOCUSED THEIR.
BUT I WOULD I THINK I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT I AGREE WITH JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING THE YOU HAVE
SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHORT OF OF
COURSE AGREEING THAT THAT RENT
CONTROL IS THE ANSWER I THINK.
THOUGHTS HE EVER GETTING CLOSER
I YOU KNOW I HAVE TO SAY. I'M MY
BIGGEST FEAR YOU KNOW I HAVE
KIDS IN COLLEGE AND I GET IT.
IF WE IMPOSE RENT CONTROL.
CITIES WILL DO IT FOREVER NO
VACANCY THE CONTROL.
粒
RENTERS IN NEW YORK STILL
PLAYING PAYING NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN RENTS AND WHEN MY KIDS
COME INTO COLLEGE THEY WILL NOT
FIND A PLACE TO LIVE.
THEY JUST WON'T SO WE HAVE TO DO
SO MUCH WHEN IT COMES TO
PROMOTING HOUSING.
THAT WE'VE WE SHRUNK OR OF
COURSE OR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
RENT CONTROL ENCOURAGES PEOPLE
TO STAY IN PLACE THERE WILL BE
NO PLACE FOR OUR NEW. EMPLOYEES
TO LOOK THERE WILL BE NO PLACES
FOR OUR KIDS COMING OUT OF
COLLEGE TO LIVE.
SO.
I THINK RENT CONTROL
UNFORTUNATELY WILL DISCOURAGE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION GOING
FORWARD AND WE WILL REPEAT THAT
I'M SORRY WILL REPEAT THAT AND I
GET IT THAT RENT CONTROL WILL
HELP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES AT
THIS MOMENT BUT IT WON'T STOP
THERE. ANDTHAT'S THE MOST
UNFORTUNATE PART OF THIS DEBATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S NOW GO
TO.
MISTER BONTA.
BUT FIRST I WANT I WANT TO
THANK.
THE AUTHOR I'M.
TO BLOOM FOR IT FOR YOU ADVOCACY
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON ON
BRINGING THE SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR FOR THIS DISCUSSION.
WHEN I THINK ART CHAIR OF OUR A
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
AS WELL FOR ALL THE GREAT
THINGS YOU GOT DONE LAST YEAR.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
COULD YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS AN
ONGOING CRISIS IN STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE NEED ALL HANDS ON
DECK AND ALL THE WORK.
A TO CONTINUE SO IS JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
YOU.
I I'M A CO AUTHOR THIS BILL I'M
GOING AYE TODAY AND I REALLY.
APPRECIATE.
.
A THIS CONVERSATION I UP AND I
WANTED TO SAY THAT.
.
YOU THIS IS THIS IS DEMOCRACY IN
ACTION THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE
WHO TOOK TIME OUT YOUR BUSY DAYS
FOR FOR FOR BEING HERE FOR IT
FOR STEPPING UP AND STANDING UP
IN.
AND EXPRESS YOUR VIEWS AND A
SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO THE ALAMEDA
WINTERS COALITION FOR FOR BEING
HERE AND FOR AND FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW WE WERE IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE JUST ARE WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE TO.
.
RECOGNIZE
THE DEEP PAIN AND HURT AND HARM
THAT OUR CURRENT CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND WHEN WERE IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY OR IN A STATE OF
CRISIS
WE NEED ALL HANDS ON DECK WE
NEED ALL TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX.
AND SO YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN STATED
BUT I THINK IT BEARS RESTATING
THAT.
THIS BILL.
WILL MANDATE.
AND REQUIRE AND IMPLEMENT
NOTHING IN THE FORM OF RENT
CONTROL.
IT WILL ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AND
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC CONVERSATION
TO CONTINUE AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHERE.
THE.
SOLUTIONS CAN BE CRAFTED
ABOUT IT IN A WAY THAT FITS THAT
THAT PROBLEMS AND AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE BEING
FACED.
AND AND THAT'S IMPORTANT I THINK
YOU KNOW THIS IS
COSTA HAWKINS HAS BEEN. A
STATEWIDE ONE SIZE FITS ALL BAR
A PROHIBITION
AND TODAY WE SIMPLY. ASK THAT WE
REMOVE THAT BAR THAT WE LIFT
THAT PROHIBITION THAT WE ALLOW
FOR A CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE.
AND THAT.
LOCALS. WHO ARE CLOSEST TO THE
PROBLEM WHO WHO SEE IT?
IN IN IN THE FACES AND HERE IN
THE WORDS OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
AND THE RESIDENTS CAN CAN HELP
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
FAKE IT PROVIDES A TOOL A
RESOURCE AN OPPORTUNITY SOME
LOCALS WILL NOT NOT USE IT AT
ALL.
SOME WILL.
AND AND.
I TRUST THAT DURING THAT
PROCESS.
ALL SIDES THE TAPE WILL BE
INVITED TO TO. UP PARTICIPATE
NOT CONVERSATION THAT SOME OF
THE POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
CERTAIN SOME AN ATTACK WHAT
CONSEQUENCES THAT HAVE BEEN.
RAISED AROUND SUPPLY SIDE.
PROVIDING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHAT WILL BE ADDRESSED
AND AND AND CAN BE.
.
IN AND A SOLUTION CAN BE CRAFTED
THAT THAT MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO TO HAVE ROBUST
SUPPLYING CALIFORNIA THAT THE
WORK THAT WE STARTED LAST YEAR
CONTINUES. AND.
.
WHILE THAT HAPPENS BECAUSE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED THE
FUTURE IS A TIME HORIZON FOR
THESE NEW UNITS TO BE. BROUGHT
ONLINE THAT TENANTS WHO ARE
HURTING NOW.
WHO NEED HELP NOW?
I WILL BE PROTECTED AND AND
SUPPORTED. SO YOU KNOW I.
I I THINK WE OUGHT NOT.
DEPRIVE OUR LOCAL LEADERS OF OF
A TOOL. THAT THEY CAN USE TO
PROTECT THEIR TENANTS.
AN AND CALIFORNIANS IN IN IN
THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND I THINK.
THAT IT'S.
NOT PRUDENT TO PRE DECIDE THIS
ISSUE.
AND TO REMOVE THIS POTENTIAL
TOOL UP FROM EVEN BEING
CONSIDERED AYE I THINK WE NEED
IT NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERED AND I
AND I THINK.
THAT CALIFORNIA'S DESERVE IT
THAT THAT TENANTS DESERVE IT
THAT IT'S IT'S PART OF OUR
ONGOING EFFORT TO STAND UP FOR.
AND PROTECT AND DEFEND AYE
CALIFORNIANS WHO WHO WERE AYE
FACING CHALLENGES IN WHO ARE WHO
ARE HURTING. AND THAT'S OUR JOB
THAT'S WHAT THE LEGISLATURE DOES
IT IT PROVIDE SOLUTIONS TO
PROBLEMS FACING CALIFORNIANS AND
AND THIS.
IS I'M NOT JUST A PROBLEM
EXISTED EMERGENCY IN A CRISIS
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY ACTIVATE WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WE'VE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO IMPROVE THE LIVES. OF
CALIFORNIANS AND A PROVIDE A
TOOL TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
CAN THAT CAN REALLY HELP MAKE A
DIFFERENCE SO I I AM PROUD. TO
BE CO AUTHOR I AM PROUD TO VOTE
I TODAY I THINK YOU I'M I'M
MISTER BLOOM AFTER YOUR
LEADERSHIP ND ON SO MANY THINGS
RELATED TO HOUSING AND AND OTHER
ISSUES.
MISTER CHU YOU AYE EACH YEAR
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN.
ABSOLUTELY OUTSTANDING AND AND
AND IT CONTINUES AND.
NOTE TODAY THAT WE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE I'M IN A VOTE I
AND I ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO DO
THE SAME THANK YOU.
THING IS A BONTA MISTER CHAPMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I WANT US ON THANK EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. I KNOW MANY OF
YOU HAVE TRAVEL FROM A FAR.
LET ME START OFF BY ECHOING SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED ALREADY.
THAT THE WE'D THERE IS A HOUSING
CRISIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA IN
FACT.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT WE NEED
ABOUT THE HUNDRED THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW UNITS EVERY
YEAR JUST TO MEET THE DEMANDS.
THAT WE FACE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
THE RENTS HERE IN THE STATE.
ARE GETTING OUT OF CONTROL ON IN
FACT THE AVERAGE SHELL AMOUNT
RENT.
ACCORDING TO THE UNITED STATES
A.
OTHER DEPARTMENT OF URBAN
HOUSING.
IS AROUND THIRTEEN HUNDRED.
DOLLARS A MONTH.
AND THAT IS THE SECOND HIGHEST
IN THE NATION.
AND AS WE HEARD FROM THE CHAIR
AND THE AUTHOR IN. A MANY OF YOU
EARLIER.
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE FULLY
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPACTS OF
THESE.
PHENOMENA ARE HAVING.
ON THE RESIDENTS IN THE STATE.
WHICH IS ALSO A REASON WHY IN
THE PAST LEGISLATORS CYCLE WE
PASSED A TOTAL OF FIFTEEN
HOUSING BILLS AS MISSION.
EARLIER.
AND BUT AWARENESS PUT ALL
FIFTEEN OF THEM.
OUR. IT WAS.
NEVERTHELESS JUST ONE STEP
TOWARDS.
THESE VERY PRESSING ISSUES THAT
WE FACE.
WE'LL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO LOOK
FOR SOLUTIONS AS WE GO.
TRUE QUESTION BECOMES WHETHER
EXPANDING RENT CONTROL IN THE
STATE IS YET ANOTHER SOLUTION.
I MUST ADMIT THAT TOPPING THE
RENT IN SOME SITUATIONS MAY
APPEAR.
TO CONTROL THE UPTAKE IN RAN. IN
CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS.
YET IN THE LONG RUN.
I WE SOLVING THE PROBLEM. I
THINK THAT WAS BEEN RACED.
I MEAN FIRST OF ALL POINT TO THE
VERY RECENT STUDY IN THAT'S THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN STUDY THAT WAS.
ARE DISCUSSED EARLIER BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST.
WHICH IS A NONPARTISAN NON
BIASED ANTI THAT WE. IN FACT
OFTEN LOOK TO THAT I OFTEN LOOK
TO.
THEIR CONCLUSION. AS LATE AS
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
WAS THAT RIGHT CONTROL IS NOT
LETME UNDERSCORE IS NOT A
VEHICLE. TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
NOW SOME OF ITS FINDINGS IN FACT
COINCIDE WITH MANY OF THE
STUDIES OUT THERE CONDUCTED BY
ECONOMISTS I THINK WE TALK ABOUT
ECONOMIST EARLIER.
WHICH INDICATES SAID EXPANDING
NOW EXPANDING RANKED ROLE.
HOOKS ACTUALLY EXACERBATE THE
HOUSING SITUATION.
THIS INCENTIVIZE NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
BECAUSE DILAPIDATED HOUSING
CONDITIONS BE DUE TO LACK OF
MAINTENANCE.
AND MAY EVEN DISCOURAGE
HOUSEHOLDS FROM MOVING. TO
MARKET RATE HOUSING WHERE IT MAY
OTHERWISE BENEFIT THEM.
IN FACT THE LA ILL ALSO SAYS
THAT MARKET RATE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION APPEARS TO BE
ASSOCIATED. ASSOCIATED WITH LESS
LESS DISPLACEMENT.
REGARDLESS OF THE COMMUNITIES
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING POLICY.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT ALSO
DISPLACEMENT.
NOW.
AS WE ALL KNOW ON THE CURRENT
LAW IT'S BEEN MENTIONED.
CITIES ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ADOPT RENT CONTROL.
YES.
UNDER THE MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY CITIES HERE IN THE STATE
OF CAIFORNIA. ONLY FIFTEEN OF
THEM FIFTEEN.
HAVE RENT CONTROL AND THAT'S
LIKE THREE PERCENT.
LIFTING COSTA HAWKINS
MAY INDEED HELP SOME CITIES AND
SOME RESIDENTS.
BUT IT MAY ALSO HURT OTHERS
AT THE SAME TIME.
JUST YESTERDAY AYE I RECEIVED AN
EMAIL FROM A SEVENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD.
CONSTITUENTS WHO RAISED TWO
CHILDREN AS A SINGLE MOTHER.
WHO REALIZE ON INCOME FROM A
VERY SMALL INVESTMENT PROPERTY?
AS HER LIVELIHOOD.
SHE SAID THAT SHE NEEDS THE
ABILITY TO CHARGE MARKET RATE.
AGAIN MARKET RATE.
TO PAY FOR.
HER MORTGAGES
HER INSURANCE THE PROPERTY TAX
UTILITIES IMPROVEMENTS AND
REPAIRS
JUST TO KEEP.
THE RENTAL PROPERTY.
ALSO SHE DOES NOT RECEIVE ANY
RETIREMENT BENEFITS BENEFITS
FROM HER DECEASED HUSBAND.
BUT THIS BILL WILL COMPLETELY
CHANGE THAT.
AND SHE'S ONE OF THE MANY
EXAMPLES
IN MY DISTRICT AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE CONSIDER
ALL ASPECTS WHEN WE PASS A LAW.
I THINK THAT A COMPLETE REPEAL A
COMPLETE REPEAL OF A TWENTY
YEAR.
OLD LAW. MAY HAVE IN FACT SOME
ADVERSE IMPACTS ON THE OVERALL
HOUSING SITUATION AND ON THE
VERY RESIDENTS THAT THE LAW IS
INTENDED.
TO BENEFIT.
NO I WAS OPEN AND I HAVE BEEN
OPEN.
TO MEETING INCREMENTAL CHANGES.
TO THE EXISTING LAW.
NAMELY COSTA HAWKINS.
AND AS WE KNOW THE LAW HS THREE
MAJOR COMPONENTS.
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES THEY
CONCEDED CONTROL.
AND NEW BUILDINGS ARE NEW HOMES.
AND WAS OPEN TO BASICALLY
TWEAKING ANY PART OF THAT.
WE CAN ALSO DO A PILOT PROJECT
FOR CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS.
YET.
IT UP IT'S A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTING TO HEAR THAT NEAR
SIGH. HAVE MADE ANY CONCESSIONS
AND PRINTS AND THEREFORE THE
LAST YEAR.
SO PLEASE SAID A COMPLETE REPEAL
WITHOUT A REPLACEMENT A BACK UP
PLAN IS JUST TOO RISKY.
ON MY BOOKS.
SO I'M JUST GOING.
JOHN GOOD ABSTAINED FROM VOTING
TODAY.
I DO WANT ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR
IN. MANY OF YOU TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE.
TRY TO FIND WAYS TO REFORM COSTA
HAWKINS.
THANK WAS CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AYE KNOW WE WANNA GET PUBLIC
COMMENT.
AND LESSER ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OF I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUICK COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS BUT
A DOCTOR WOULD. YEAH I THOUGHT
WE WERE ASKING QUESTIONS AND
MAKING COMMENTS O SO KATE MAKE
COMMENTS THE IT IS ALTHOUGH
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
PUBLICCOMMENT DOESN'T HAVE
DISCUSSION AFTER PUBLICLY SO WE
WILL HAVE TO.
IT'S GOT ABSOLUTELY.
AND THEN I WILL HOLD MY COMMENTS
OKAY GREAT.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC FOR THE
DISCUSSION I WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES AS WELL AS OF THE BILL
AUTHORED THIS HAS BEEN A A
DIFFICULT DISCUSSION. OF IT AND
LET ME SAY I THINK EVERYONE
KNOWS WHERE MY PERSPECTIVE IS AS
I SAID EARLIER I AM A CO AUTHOR
OF OF THIS BILL.
I WANT TO HE APPRECIATE THAT
THE THAT. THE ISSUES AND BEEN
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION AND
OBVIOUSLY.
WE DON'T HAVE AGREEMENT ON ON
ON ON SOME OF THAT AND AND
THERE'S BEEN DISCUSSION AROUND
WHETHER THIS WILL.
A REPEAL EXCLUDE NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND I WOULD JUST
NOTICE WAS SAID BEFORE JUST IN
THE BAY AREA. OUT WE'VE SEEN IN
RECENT YEARS HALF OF NEW
CONSTRUCTION
HAS BEEN TAKING PLACE IN RENT
CONTROL JURISDICTIONS EVEN
THOUGH THOSE RENT CONTROLLED
RESTRICTIONS ONLY. OCCUPY A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF LAND IN THE
BAY AREA WHILE MANY
JURISDICTIONS IN THE BAY AREA
THAT DO NOT HAVE RENT CONTROL.
HAVE SEEN ZERO CONSTRUCT
AND AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO GRAPPLE WITH. I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A DISCUSSION
AROUND.
ACANCY DE CONTROL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT WHEN.
RENT CONTROL.
WAS BEING DEBATED IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND EARLY
EIGHTIES.
SOME OF THE CITIES DECIDED TO
MOVE FOR THE VACANCY TO CONTROL
MANY DID NOT. ARE AND THOSE THAT
DID.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY JUST
FOR EXAMPLE IN SANTA MONICA UP
WHEN VACANCY DE CONTROL WAS
IMPOSED IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
WITH COSTA HAWKINS.
YOU SAW AFFORDABILITY IN CITIES
LIKE SANTA MONICA GO FROM.
EIGHTY THREE PERCENT DOWN TO
FOUR PERCENT ONE VACANCY DE
CONTROL CAME AND SO AGAIN IT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE.
I DO HAVE REALLY TWO QUESTIONS
TO THE OPPOSITION.
I THINK WE ALL AGREE AS MS
CARLTON AND MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
BLOOM UPSET WE ALL AGREE WE NEED
TO BUILD MORE HOUSING.
IF WE HAD MORE HOUSING TODAY. IF
RENTS WERE STABLE WE WOULD NOT
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION BUT AS
MISTER BLOOM POINTED OUT. ON
EVEN IF WE DO ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE WANT TO DO FROM LAST
YEAR THIS YEAR BEYOND. OUR TO
ENSURE MORE HOUSING IT WILL TAKE
YEARS.
TO PUT HOUSING.
ON THE GROUND TO HAVE IT BUILT
TO HAVE FOLKS HOUSE.
AND SO WE HAVE A CRISIS TO DAY.
WE'VE A CRISIS OF NOW.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF TENANTS WHO
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED AND WHO WERE
BEING EVICTED AND THEY ARE OUR
NEIGHBORS.
THEY ARE OUR FRIENDS THEIR
FAMILIES THEY ARE FOLKS WHO ARE
HERE IN THIS ROOM.
AND AND WITH THE URGENCY OF NOW.
MY QUESTION TO THE OPPOSITION IS
IF NOT THIS.
WHAT WOULD YOU PROPOSE TO DAY
THAT WE COULD GET DONE TODAY TO
PREVENT?
THOUSANDS OF TENANTS FROM BEING
EVICTED.
MILLIONS A CALIFORNIANS FOM
BEING.
HOUSING UNSTABLE.
THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
IN YOU KNOW WHAT'S WHAT'S
FASCINATING IS IS WE HAVEN'T SAT
DOWN TO TALK ABOUT A COMPROMISE.
AND I THINK THE MOST MOST
UNFORTUNATE PART IS THAT WE'VE
BEEN THREATENED WITH AN
INITIATIVE RIGHT.
ONE OF THE PROPONENTS THERE HAS
BEEN A PROPONENT OF STOPPING ALL
CONSTRUCTION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AMOUNT OF LOS ANGELES.
IT'S TRUE AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
BUT I THINK.
WE ARE NOT.
OPPOSED TO TALKING ABOUT
DIFFERENT OPTIONS
BUT ON THE TABLE AGAIN
THREATENING US A LOOMING IS AN
INITIATIVE AND THAT JUST
ANYTHING WE DO HERE THE
LEGISLATURE.
WILL BE OVER RIDDEN POTENTIALLY.
BY A STATE INITIATIVE OF COURSE
EVERYBODY'S GONNA THROW MILLIONS
pOF DOLLARS AND SPEND A LOT OF
TIME AND INITIATIVE AND THAT'S
VERYUNFORTUNATE. SO I WOULD SAY
WE ARE NOTADVERSE TO TALKING
ABOUT COMPROMISES AND WE STAND
READY TO SIT AT THE TABLE AND
TALK. BUT AT THIS POINT YOU'RE
NOT WILLING TO SAY ANYTHING
PUBLICLY ABOUT IDEAS I COULD
ADDRESS THE EVICTION COARSER
SENATE DEMOCRATS AS WELL. AYE
I'M TRULY JUST ASKING THE
QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE COLLEAGUES LIKE
MR CHOW YEAH WHO AND PROBABLY
OTHERS THAT WOULD BE WILLING. TO
CONSIDER COSTA HAWKINS REFORM IF
THEIR IDEAS ON THE TABLE BUT AT
THIS MOMENT THERE ARE NO AND
THAT IS ENTERED IT I GET IT AND
THAT'S FAIR IN FACT. LAST YEAR
WE COMPROMISED.
ON INCLUSIONARY ZONING SO WE
HAVE.
CLEARED IT UP THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS COULD ALLOW FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OF ALL NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THE COMPROMISE THAT
WE DID LAST YEAR.
AND I.
I I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THAT IS.
NEW CONSTRUCTION.
RENT CONTROL.
SO MEASURES LIKE THAT ARE
CERTAINLY SOMETHING AGAIN THAT
WE STAND READY TO TALK ABOUT.
AND THEN ONE AND THIS IS A BIT
MORE OF A DETAILED QUESTION BUT
ONE ASPECT OF OF COSTA HAWKINS
THAT I HAVE HAD.
SERIOUS ISSUES WITH OVER THE
YEARS IS THE FACT THAT THERE'S A
A DATE LIMITTION. ARE AFTER
WHICH NEW CONSTRUCTION CANNOT
HAVE RENT CONTROL APPLY TO IT SO
ARE AS OF NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
ALL LAWS THAT HAD BEEN ON THE
BOOKS SO FOR EXAMPLE MY CITY IN
NINETEEN
OF THE NINE OR MANY OTHERS IN.
OF THE LATE SEVENTIES TO THE
EARLY EIGHTIES NO NEW
CONSTRUCTION AFTER SAY NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE IN SAN FRANCISCO
COULD HAVE WRECKAGE APPLY TO IT.
WE ARE NOW MOST FORTY YEARS FROM
THAT AND THAT IS MEANT FORTY
YEARS OF CONSTRUCTION AND SAN
FRANCISCO AND AGAIN YOU CAN.
PICK YOUR CITY AND ONE RANKING
JEWEL MIGHT OF APPLIED.
ARE NO LONGER SUBJECT TO RENT
CONTROL. WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
MY?
TODDLER WHO'S ALMOST TWO YEARS
OLD BY THE TIME HE IS AN ADULT
SEEN AS THIRTIES. WE COULD SEE
RENT CONTROL STARK.
DWINDLE BE DEMOLISHED AND
EFFECTIVELY AND AND AND AND AT
SOME POINT RANK CONTROL IF IF
COSTA HAWKINS DOESN'T CHANGE IN
THE FUTURE.
THE WRECKAGE WAS TALKING
CALIFORNIA WILL DISAPPEAR.
I AND IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT
THAT IS WHERE WHAT YOU SUPPORT
THAT RENT CONTROL IN ALL THE
CITIES IT EVEN CURRENTLY HAVE A
CONTROL. THAT THAT RENT CONTROL
STOCK SHOULD SHOULD NO LONGER
EXIST.
WE A RIGHT I DON'T THINK WE WANT
OUR KIDS MOVING BACK HOME WITH
US DO WE AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
HUNDRED CHALLENGES E WANT THEM
TO HAVE A LIFE.
AND I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO DO
THOSE PROVIDE ASSURANCES.
FOR THOSE A NEW CONSTRUCTION
WHAT DOES IT MEAN WHEN YOU
CONSTANTLY CHANGE THE DATE.
WE'VE GOTTA FIND A WAY TO
PROVIDE SOME ASSURANCES.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE BUILDING NEW
HOUSING IF WE JUST LEAVE IT WIDE
OPEN. A FOR EVERY JOB LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO MAKE THEIR OWN
CALL ON WHETHER IT'S BELOW. CP I
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX THAT
DOESN'T HELP.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW. WHERE
IS THE POINT AT WHICH WE WILL
STOP AND WILL WE CONTINUALLY
MOVE THAT MARKER? IF WE COULD
FIND A WAY TO SAY WHAT THAT
MEANS I THINK THAT WOULD HELP
AND IT WOULD HELP WITH NEW
CONSTRUCTION SO WHILE THAT'S NOT
A FIRM ANSWER. I THINK WHAT IT
IS IS A WAY FOR US TO COME TO
THE TABLE TO TALK.
THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT.
IT MISTER BLOOM D. OF ANY FINAL
COMMENTS YOU WANNA MAKE AN
OTHERWISE OR THE PUBLIC AREA
I'LL JUST A RESPOND BRIEFLY TO
OF THE LAST FEW COMMENTS THAT
WE'VE HEARD AND AND EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION AND.
TO THE OPENING CA.
THAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
OPPOSITION TO HAVE A DIALOGUE
AND DISCUSS COMPROMISE SOME
CERTAINLY.
CERTAINLY OPEN TO THAT AND IT.
FURTHER TO THE POINT.
AYE AYE CERTAINLY WOULD NEVER
TRY TO SPEAK UP FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO.
BUT.
AYE I HEAR HIS COMMENTS AND I
SEE THEM MORE AS AN ADMONITION
THAN A SUGGESTION A REQUEST.
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT A
AT ALTERNATIVES I WOULD.
.
POINT OUT ONE OTHER THE OTHER
THING AND THAT IS SO.
THAT WE ARE.
FACED WITH CERTAIN FACTS WITH
RESPECT TO THE.
ASSEMBLY.
OF LEGISLATIVE SCHEDULE THAT
PUTS.
ANY DISCUSSION OF A COMPROMISE
WHETHER THIS AND AND AND OTHER
FACTS EXTERNAL TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THAT REALLY
DEMAND THAT WE HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. HERE AND NOW AND
SO I WANT TO JUST SAY FOR THE
RECORD HERE.
REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOME HERE
TODAY I THINK THERE'S GOOD
REASON FOR US TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION.
I'D CERTAINLY.
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE THISBILL MOVE FORWARD SO
THAT THE.
BILL COULD COME TO THE FLOOR
AND HAVE A BROADER DEBATE THERE
WOULD BE DISCUSSION BETWEEN NOW
AND THEN IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN.
BUT.
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
ISSUE AND I THINK IT ACTUALLY
IT'S PROBABLY GOOD THAT WE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT. HE'D ON US AND LOW
PRESSURE ON TO FIND THE RIGHT
SOLUTION.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WHETHER
REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOME I JUST
WANNA SAY I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU MR BLOOMIN AND WITHOUT
AND LESSER ANY FINAL COMMENTS
FOR THIS STAGE OF THE HEARING.
ARM AS I STATED AT THE OUTSET
NAM I WANT TO WE WERE GOING TO
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
IGHT AT THIS MOMENT I WANNA
FIRST GIVE PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
WISH TO.
STAND OF THE VERY LONG LINE OF
THE OPTION TO RAISE YOUR HANDS
TO INDICATE IF YOU ARE AND
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THE TELEVISION CAMERA THAT IS
HERE COVER THIS YEAR IS GOING TO
PAN OUT TO THE AUDIENCE.
SO WITH THAT LET ME ASK UP FOR
ALL WHO SUPPORT.
AB FIFTY NO SIX THE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS IF YOU COULD
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HANDS.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU
COULD PLEASE SIT DOWN AND THEN
FOR ALL WHO OPPOSE. AB FIFTEEN
SIX OPPOSE.
REPAIR REVERSING.
THIS REPEAL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
STAND UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I JUST WANT TO CLEAR FIVE
FOR THE PUBLIC THAT MAY BE
WATCHING WE APPARENTLY HAVE
PLEASE ASK EVER TO KEEP YOUR
VOICES DOWN.
WE HAVE MY GUESS IS THREE OR
FOUR TIMES AS MANY INDIVIDUALS
ON THE OUTSIDE. THAT WE CAN HEAR
THROUGH THE WALLS.
WHO HAVE A PERSPECTIVE OF ONE
SIDE OF THE OTHER?
AND AT.
THIS TIME.
OUR POLICIES AT THIS HEARING
ROOM IS NOT LARGE ENOUGH TO
ACCOMMODATE EVERYONE. ARE AT
THIS TIME WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
THE HEARING. UP AGAIN AS I SAID
EARLIER. DUE TO THE NUMBER
PEOPLE WHO WISH TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OUR DESIRE TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE WHO WANTS TO
CAN INDICATE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WE ARE GONNA LIMIT
PUBLIC COMMENT.
TO REALLY JUST THREE QUICK
THINGS YOUR NAME.
WHY DO YOU REPRESENTED
ORGANIZATION OR WHAT CITY YOU'RE
FROM? AND THEN SIMPLY THE WORD
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE WE'RE GONNA
TRACK THAT.
BUT THAT IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA
ASK FOR IT THIS TIME SO THAT WE
CAN UP MOVES THROUGH ALL OF THE
FOLKS WHO COME THROUGH.
TODAY AGAIN I WANT WHAT I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR AND.
IT WITH THAT OF INDIVIDUALS
WILL LINE UP ON THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE OF THE HEARING. ROOM.
AND TO WE WILL GET STARTED.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
I'M ACTUALLY TRUST YOU WITH A
MICROPHONE IS.
MISTER SARGENT MICROPHONE IS
BACK THERE OKAY GREAT.
SO WE WILL START AND I WILL ASK
EVERYONE TO PLEASE KEEP YOUR
VOTE PLEASE DO NOT. HAVE
CONVERSATIONS IN THIS HEARING
ROOM.
BECAUSE WE WILL BE UNABLE TO
HEAR THE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WHO
HAVE COME A TESTIFIED. WITH
THAT.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE BEGAN STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION OR
CITY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
TESTING TESTING.
YOU HEAR ME. HELLO HELLO BY
COULD PLEASE ASK PEOPLE TO NOT
HAVE CONVERSATIONS THIS FROM
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR. HELLO THERE I
AM JERRY BAXTER I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
TENANTS UNION AND I URGE OF THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB
ONE FIVE OR SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEXT SPEAKER.
HELLO I'M LAURA DESCEND FROM ANA
HANDCOCK PARK CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WERE IN.
FULL REPEAL OF THE COSTA
HAWKINS A BILL THINK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I NEED TO ASK PEOPLE TO TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OUT OF THIS
CHAMBER NEXT SPEAKER.
HELLO MY NAME IS RUSSELL
RAWLINGS I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCACY SERVICES AT RESOURCES
FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING.
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA.
AND IN SOLIDARITY WITH.
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES STATEWIDE WHOSE
STRUGGLE WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF.
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
NEXT SPEAKER.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHERRY EDDINGS
AYE LOW MEMBER OF ACE AND I AM
HERE TO SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS.
UNIX BECAUSE.
MY NAME IS GREG HAASSUMMER
RESIDENT OF MILPITAS AND I AM
AGAINST AB FIFTEEN ALL SIX THANK
YOU.
NEXT WEEK. HI MY NAME'S CAN
YOUNG.
FARMS SUNNYVALE.
AND I'M. OPPOSING THOUGH FIFTEEN
OH SIX.
THANK YOU.
NEXT WEEK.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIAN OUT THERE
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF ALL SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. ASK YOU TO OPPOSE AB
FIFTEEN NO SIX THANK YOU.
BUT SPEAKER.
I MEAN THIS AMY I LIVING LOS
ANGELES AND TEN YEARS OLD AND I
WORK ON MY MOM AND THE CAN.
I MEAN IT'S JUST SOUND LIKE THAT
AND I'M FROM.
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA BUT THE
COMMUNITY GROUP ACES AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A TWELVE PERCENT
VACANCY RATE IN DOWNTOWN LA THIS
IS A PROBLEM.
I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO SUPPORTER POST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT SPEAKER
AYE MONEY OF BILLY MARTIN FROM
OAKLYN I'M A MEMBER OF ACE AND I
SUPPORT.
IF YOU KNOW SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A BAD AT ALL I'M
STATE REPS IN THE FACE AND I AM
DEFINITELY FOR A BI IF YOU KNOW
SIX THANK YOU.
A LOT MAY EMBODY THOUGHT AM I
THINK HAVE BEEN COUPLE OF THE
VENT THEN GLENDALE BLACK EVEN
LOVE BUT YOU KNOW THAT WELL WHAT
GIVEN THE FLOOD. ADVANCE.
AND MAKE YOU SENSE THAT A SAY UP
WILL YOU WOULD WELL WHAT MARKET
ONEMORELEVEL GET US BACK ON THE
SEQUEL. GRATIS.
NEXT SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS ALAN MURRAY I'M A
RETIRED BUS DRIVER LIVING IN
OAKLAND I THINK OUT BOTH COME
ABOUT HER
LOVER AND NOT PUT THEM MUCHO.
FOR FOOTBALL.
I DON'T CARE IF WE ADDRESS HE
LET YOU LOWER THE RIGHT RIGHT
NOW IT'S WAY TOO HIGH WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO LIVE IN OUR CITIES
ANYMORE.
THE NUMBERS AYE HELENA JIMENEZ
MEAN LITTLE* SEVEN WILL
SUNKEN THIS BUT THEN WILL BECAME
KNOWN UP AGAIN THAT CASA. IT
THN ONE DUPLEX ECONOMIST HERBAL
PRODUCTS AYE YOU LOW WHAT I'VE
ASKS
SPEAKERS TO DO TO SIMPLY STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE AYE YES
AND HE'S INTERPRETING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT SPEAKER.
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
HELLO I'M DEEP OF ARMORED
ATTENDED IN SAN FRANCISCO
REPRESENT A SANDERS GOOD TENANTS
UNION AND WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF IT YOU KNOW SIX WITH NO
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
I'M TOTALLY NOT AGAINST SOME
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I.
SUPPORT.
AB FIFTEENTH ALL SIX. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HOW MY NAME AND OUT OF OUR IS
UNSUPPORTED A V. PEEPING SERIOUS
SIX?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M AN EVICTED SEVENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD TENANT FROM LOS ANGELES A
MEMBER OF THE LOS ANGELES
TENANTS UNION AND I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN OF SIX. THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS MARGARET HENNESSY I'M
A SENIOR CENTER SAID MEMBER OF
LONG BEACH RESIDENTS EMPOWERED
AND I SUPPORT.
AB FIFTEEN NO SIX.
YOU.
MY NAME IS HARRY HAVE GIDEON
LIFELONG RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
AND OTHER ENGINEER. AND THE
URBAN PLANNER THAT SUPPORT FIFTY
NO SIX.
AND I SUPPORT THE STATE A
CALIFORNIAN THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
NEXT WEEK.
I'M DAVE ALLIANCE.
I'M RETARDATION TRAVéS DRIVER
FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA PROUD
MEMBER OF BASS.
AND I RESOUNDINGLY SUPPORT THE
REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS THANK
YOU.
NEXT WEEK.
THREE SO WAGNER PAYS MIDTOWN
SACRAMENTO LANDLORDS.
WITH CA RHA AND PRIVATE
LANDLORDS AND I'M OPPOSED TO.
THANK YOU.
HELLO JANE MANTI WITH THE
SACRAMENTO TENANTS UNION WHERE
FULL SUPPORT A FIFTEEN NO SIX.
Q.
SPEAKER.
I AM JOHN PAUL THE SECOND OWN
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA
AND WE FULLY SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
A SIX BECAUSE HOUSING IS A HUMAN
RIGHT.
SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS NIKON HERE
REPRESENTING DEMOCRATS OCEANS
AMERICA SACRAMENTO'S WELLNESS
FOUR FIFTEEN ZERO SIX.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
LET'S LIGHT SACRAMENTO TENANTS
UNION PLEASE REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
SPEAKER SARAH SHERBURNE ZIMMER A
SAN FRANCISCO TENANT WHO HAD ARE
RAISED RENT RAISE THIRTY THREE
PERCENT AND FROM HOUSING RIGHTS
COMMITTEE OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
WE SUPPORT FULL REPEAL.
THANK YOU.
TOM DECKER LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
THE BAY AREA AND AS A LANDLORD
BUSINESS OWNER AND. CORPORATE
OFFICER INTACT I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT FIFTEEN A SIX.
NEXT WEEK.
YEAH MY NEIGHBORS CAME OUT SO I
CAME FROM OAKLAND AYE FROM MA
ACO GOING TO SAY SOME AND I
SUPPORT AB FIFTY ALL SIX.
BAKER.
MANY MISTY SEQUENCING AND WITH
ORGANIZED ACKERMAN ON A STUDENT
AND I SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN OF SEX.
MY NAME'S JESSIE DREW I'M A
HOMEOWNER HOMEOWNER NOT ATTENDED
I'M A PROFESSOR AT UC DAVIS I'M
CO CHAIR OF THE DAVIS FACT THIS
ASSOCIATION. AND ON BEHALF OF
ALL STUDENTS ASK YOU TO PLEASE
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS DAY NECK
SPEAKER THANK YOU. WHERE IS THE
KILL A CHOPPER I HAVE NO
PARTICULAR AFFILIATION JUST A
CONCERN COLLEGE STUDENT AND I
URGE THEIR APPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS THING HERE?
YOU.
MYNAME IS PALATABLE THAT OF. OF
SACRAMENTO.
AND I ASKED.
THAT YOU OPPOSE COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M POWER NOT LOVE
IT OF A I'M A REPORT
COMMISSIONER FOR THE CITY OF
BERKELEY AND MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRAT ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND I. ASK YOU
TO PLEASE SUPPORT AB FIFTY NO
SIX.
I KNOW THAT'S A NUMBER PRESENTED
AT THE NO HOLDS AXIS IS UNDONE
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND WE SUPPORT
TENER RIGHTS WE SUPPORT AB FIFTY
NO SIX.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS GEORGE AND
SHARP I'M A CANCER SURVIVOR ON A
FIXED INCOME PLEASE REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
THANK YOU.
I AM MARINO OPEN NOW THAT I
BELONG TO FEEL THE BURN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. ACE AND SAGE.
AND I WANT YOU TO SUPPORT.
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
I MY NAME IS JOE STRINGER
EMANATES MEMBER FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE TO SUPPORT.
AB FIFTEEN ó SIX AND NOT
PAYING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOSE THE
AS I COME FROM THERE HOME POMONA
CA. ANDI DON'T WANT IT TO GAVE
MY INCREASED THEIR MINIMAL WAGE.
IN THE LAW EIGHT OF THE ATLANTA
OR I NEEDTO USE THIS MONEY FOR
MY FAMILY TAKE YOU.
I THINK YOUR THE AB PICKING ALL
SEEK.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
SNM RANDOMIZE AYE I'M A RESIDENT
OF THE CITY OF POMONA
CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF ACES AND
I'M HERE TO URGE CITY URGE YOU.
TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS IT'S AN
URGENT MATTER IT'S A CRISIS.
.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICIA CARMEN
I'M A RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I'M ALSO A VICTIM OF THE
ALICE ACT.
I WANT TO TO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS FOR ALL SENIORS LIVING
ON THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY WE NEED
THIS.
THANK YOU. HELLO EVERYBODY MY
NAME IS AL BY BARBARIC CALL ME
BUTTON BUT IF YOU WANT TO DO I'M
WITH THE COMMUNITY GROUP EIGHT
PUMPED OUT EIGHT AT WOULD YOU
PLAY.
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU HAVE A BLESSED DAY.
YOU.
MY NAME IS CALORIES PER OUNCE.
FROM SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
I'M WITH A.
AND THERE IS A DESPERATE NEED
FOR ME.
TO SUPPORT A BE.
FIFTEEN KNOWS.
THANK YOU JUSTIN TIMBERLAKE HE'S
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF OAKLAND FROM
MACE.
AYE SUPPORT AB FIFTY NO SIX
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
OKAY.
EIGHT BUT YEAH HOW WAS IT TO
RESOLVE WONG TIMMY MEN EQUAL
RIGHTS STOP AT THIS LITTLE
SLUMMING BADMINTON MEANS IS HE
FOUND THE MYTH THAT GEORGIA THE
MYTH THAT THE HOUSE AMONG. YOUNG
HOLD USES SUPPORT PART OF OPPOSE
EIGHTY YOU WINNING NEAR YES OR
NO AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK I COULD DO
THAT AWFUL YEAH LIKE. I GET
THANK YOU FOR EXPLAINING THAT TO
THE CHINESE PUBLIC CAREER.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDA WEIGHING.
FROM A BAY AREA HOMEOWNERS THAT
THE WORK. I OPPOSED AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX BILL WERDE FROM FREMONT.
RETIRED SENIOR CITIZEN.
NO ONE ON ONE.
HI AM VIVIAN LA I REPRESENTS
SMALL LANDLORDS CAN SUMMER
SISKEL BAY AREA I'M OPPOSED TO
AB FIFTY NOW SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ROGER BOSWELL I'M
A LOCAL SENIOR CITIZEN RETIRED
AND I OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO SIX AND
HOUSING IS NOT A HUMAN.
MY NAME IS WESLEY WALKER I NEED
TO ASK AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ARE WORKING LA. AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT BE.
A B. THIRTEEN ALL SIX RIGHTHERE
ACROSS THE HOT THANK HER MUCH.
HELLO HELLO MY NAME VIDEO TRAIL
ON THE A TO SUPPORT.
AL.
EPB I THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S AUSSIE
WILL I'M FOR MILPITAS A PRIVATE
RESIDENT I WORKED UP WITH A LOT
OF SMALL A HOME BUILDERS AND
DEVELOPERS. AND I'M HERE TO ASK
YOU TO VOTE AGAINST UP ABOUT
FIFTEEN OF SIX AND I ASK THE TWO
SIDES TO SEEK A COMPROMISE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS DOROTHY MAYNARD
AND I REPRESENT ABOUT FIFTEEN
HUNDRED SINGLE FAMILY OWNERS
THAT ALL OPPOSE THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
HI I AM JULY MEDINA FROM SUTTER
COUNTY AND I REPRESENT. THE SAME
AMOUNT OF OWNERS AND WE OPPOSE
FIFTY KNOWS AB FIFTY NO SIX.
MY MY NAME IS AMIL BLACKWELL
MAREZ THEY INTENDED OAK LYNN.
I'M WITH CASA WHO SUGGEST
BECAUSE AND WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL PITINO SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS LET THE STAFF
SAMICK TEN A ALSO HERE WITH
COSTS UP WITH THEN SECRETARY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
WE'RE IN FAVOR FOR REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS NO ONE MELMASON
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT THANK
YOU.
AGAIN I NEED TO ASK MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC TO PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS YOURSELF OR TAKE IT
OUTSIDE NEXT SPEAKER THANK YOU
OKAY MY NAME IS BEVERLY ROBERTS
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA.
I'M A LANDLORD AND I SAID I AM
SAYING REPEAL COP COSTA HAWKINS
BECAUSE THE RENTS ARE TOO HIGH.
NEXT SPEAKER THE GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LOS WORK ON THE US A
MEMBER OF THE SECOND UNTIL TENS
UNIT NUMBER A SACRAMENTO AND ON
MOST OF THE SON OF LANDLORDS.
AND I AM HERE SUPPORT AB FIFTY
NO SIX FULL REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI LESLIE DRYER WITHOUT SAN
FRANCISCO HOUSING COMMITTEE AND
ALSO ATTENDED UP OAKLAND WHO'S
BEEN COSTA HAWKINS EVICTED TWICE
IN TWO YEARS I ASK FOR A FULL
REPEAL THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STABLE ONE SIDE IS
LIKE EMPLOYER LOS ANGELES MEMBER
OR A. A PLEASE REPEAT ACOSTA
HAWKING.
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KELLY PEELER
AND I'M A RESIDENT OF UNION CITY
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S ANDY SPIVAK COME
FROM EMERYVILLE.
AND HERE ON BEHALF OF.
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
OUR SEARCH BAY AREA AND ASKING
FOR A FULL REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME'S JOHN AND FEINGOLD
I'M AND RESIDENT OF OAKLAND A
MEMBER OF SHOWING UP FRAZIER
JUSTICE BAY AREA CHAPTER I
SUPPORT EP FIFTEEN NO SIX
WITHOUT AMENDMENT.
HI LISA SHOT OF ALL THE MEN
OAKLAND RESIDENT WITH SERGE
TYING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE BAY
AREA AND. SUPPORT YEAH I AB
FIFTEEN A SIX.
HI MY NAME'S ELIZABETH FRASER
I'M A RESIDENT OF OAKLAND ALSO A
SURGE BAY AREA WE HAVE A
MEMBERSHIP OF EACH OVER A
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE BAY AREA
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIFTY
NO SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AMY SURE RENTER IN LOS ANGELES
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DUES PAYING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION ACE
UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
WE SUPPORT THE REPEAL AND WE
URGE YOU TO BE WHERE FALSE
CHOICES WE NEED TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
JUST AS A SENTENCE WE NEED TO
ALL THINK YOU VERY MUCH BAKER
HALL NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I I APPRECIATE AGAIN WE NEED TO
HAVE THE SAME RULES WE ASK THAT
EVERYONE BE TREATED. WITH THE
SAME RESPECT NEXT SPEAKER.
HI MYNAME'S MONIQUE DORLAND I'M
IN OAKLAND LANDLORD AND MEMBER
OF SURGE AYE SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
NO SEX. THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S MEADOW DDA I'M A
RESIDENT OF OAKLAND AND MEMBER
OF SURGEON I SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
NO SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ANA GARCIA AND I'M
FROM OAKLAND I'M WITH THE GROUP
ACE AND I DEFINITELY AM FOR THE
FULL TOTAL REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BRIAN PAUL.
AYE REPRESENT CURRENT LANDLORDS
IN SACRAMENTO AREA AND WERE
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO JENNY THOMPSON AND THE
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNER IN CITRUS
HEIGHTS STRONGLY OPPOSE.
HI I'M MARIE ALBERT ST RESIDENT
OF SACRAMENTO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
ME NUMBER LOS YET MODELING GLASS
BUT ACCUSED GOING UP WE HAVE
THOUGH I HAVE A FEW SAYS THAT'LL
SAVE TO BUY OUT OF THE SOVIET
AYE IMPASSE ADAMANT IT'S US
YOUNG AT A COP.
HI MY NAME IS JOHN A LAYER NUMB
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO FIND.
SOME KIND OF COMPROMISE OR
RETAIN COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU MIX BIGGER.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA I WAS EVICTED
FROM THE CITY OF RICHMOND I'M
NOW AT TEN IN THE CITY'S ARM
CISCO AND I SUPPORT THE FULL
REPEAL OF KAZAKH AND THINK YOU
THANK YOU.
WE NUMBER IS SAID ABOUT FLORIDA
BEEN LED BY IS SOME FERNANDO. HE
SLOWLY THAT BY WIN EVEN THE PLEA
LA AVE USES THAT'LL SAVE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO
MORNING DAVID WILL FOR THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA'S LEADING
PROPERTY RIGHTS ACTIVIST GROUP
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU AGAIN I ASK FOR
RESPECT FOR EVERYONE WHO'S
SPEAKING IN PUBLIC COMMENT NEXT
SPEAKER.
I AM HEATHER A PAL I AM A PART
OF SURGE BAY AREA I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FIFTY NO SIX.
THANKS.
KALEY CORNELL'S SACRAMENTO
NATIVE ON BEHALF OF ALL REALTORS
PEOPLE IN THE HALLWAY WE OPPOSE
FIFTEEN OF SIX AND WE FIND YOU'D
WE URGE YOU TO FIND A MIDDLE
GROUND.
DANIELLE JAMES.
NEW HOMEOWNER IN SACRAMENTO AND
WE OPPOSE.
YEAH THERE A MEASURE FARES FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I POSE AB FIFTY
NO SIX.
THANKS.
VICTORIA FIERCE REPRESENTING
NINE HUNDRED PLUS MEMBERS OF
EAST BAY FOR ONE OF THE SPARE
LARGEST YOU'LL BE ORGANIZATION
IN SUPPORT OF REPEAL. THANK YOU.
THEN SCHWAB NATIVE OF SAN
FRANCISCO I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
LAYLA STANLEY COUNSELOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO TENANTS UNION CALLING
FOR FULL REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
SHANE CLARK WITH TEAR AYE
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT OPPOSED AB
FIFTY NO SIX.
JERRY HAZEL PROPERTY MANAGER DEL
PASO HEIGHTS I URGE A
COMPROMISE.
THANK YOU.
CITY WEBER.
REPRESENT TWO ORGANIZATIONS I'M
THE.
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR OF
PEACE AND FREEDOM PART OF
CALIFORNIA. MOST THOUGH ON THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE OF CARA
CALIFORNIA LINES REGARD
AMERICANS.
WE ARE BOTH FOR. AB OF FIFTEEN
OH SIX.
THANK YOU.
I LEAVE WITH.
HELLO I'M MYRON TAYLOR FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA FORCE ARE.
I.
WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT THE
MORAL THING SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER SHAM FROM
ELBOW HERE I WOULD HAVE ONE
THOUGHT MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS OUTSIDE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE FIFTEEN OH SIX.
THING IS YOU A CUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THE TEN CD ALSO SACRAMENTO
OPPOSE.
YOU.
I'M WHEN DISSOLVES AND EVER OF
THE CITY THAT.
I MEAN I AM STRONGLY SO OPPOSE
AB. FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SO SO WHILE FAMA MONTEREY COUNTY
STOP ABFIFTY ZERO SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEAN WHERE I'M FULL
MUG AND HE'LL A AND I SEE NO A
BE FIFTEEN ALL SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I MIGHT AND TEN I COME FROM ON
THE SAN FRANCISCO IS LOW A BEEFY
T. N. O. SE.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN MY NAME YOU SEE AN
EMPLOYEE A OF FROM SAN FRANCISCO
LOW. FIFTEEN OLD CC.
THANK YOU.
NOW A FEE PACIFIC WITHIN HOME
SAFE.
BOB.
SEVEN FIFTY GOES BACK THEN. SAY
WHY WE'RE.
THEY WOUND.
THANK YOU.
BRIAN WAGNER REAL ESTATE BROKER
OWNER ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
PATRICK WAGNER THAT SACRAMENTO
LANDLORD OPPOSE.
I MINDY KIRSHNER SAN FRANCISCO
I'M AN ETHICAL LANDLORD WHO
OPPOSES THANK YOU.
LINDA IRK ONCE SAN FRANCISCO
LANDLORD AYE OPPOSED.
BILL FROM SOME I TELL IMPOSING
FIFTEEN ALL SIX.
TIME FROM SOME OF HOW LOW AB ONE
FIVE OR SIX.
LENDS MAYBE EN.
LANDLORD THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA.
HAPPY CA A MEMBER. ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSED.
YOUR YOU FARM MILPITAS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M DR MIKE MAN OF MY FROM
OAKLAND ON LOCAL HUMAN BEHAVIOR
MARKETS AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I'M SHARE LOWER FROM RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA PROUD HOMEOWNER.
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
THROUGH IT NOW TO SAY.
THERE REACH ONE.
A I A PULSE.
GOOD MORNING JOE LAWTON
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION FOR THIS YEAR.
I OPPOSE FIFTEEN NO SIX.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MAINLY
YOUNG I'M A CARETAKER SINGLE
FAMILY HOUSE OWNER AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. FIFTEEN OF SIX.
WELL MY NAME IS A QUAN HIT CAN
FROM SAN JOSE I STRONGLY OPPOSE
SCHOOL PP ONE FIVE OR SIX.
THANK YOU.
I AM VANESSA LEAVE FROM SAN JOSE
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME'S
FRANCIS QUOC I REPRESENT ALAMEDA
PROPERTY OWNERS ASSOCIATION I'M
SORRY PIPE OF POVERTY POLITIS
ASSOCIATION I ALSO REPRESENT A
GROUP OF REAL ESTATE DEVELOPERS
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND EAST BAY WE
OPPOSE THE BEEF IF NO SIX.
Q..
MY NAME IS HEATHER DAN I'M FREE
FOR ALL FROM FREMONT A NO NO NO.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS THERESA DO
GET I'M THEY SEKADAR ECTOPLASM
FRANCISCO'S.
IN SOME POSSESS GO AREA SOME
FOR THE S. FCC WE HAVE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE OPPOSE THE.
I AB ONE FIVE OR SIX.
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JOAN WHO AM FROM
BRENTWOOD I'M OPPOSED.
AB WIFI OWES IT I WAS SICK.
THANK YOU.
BOB.
BUT I.
MADONNA.
BUT I KNOW.
THE GOAL THEY SEEM CHICKENED OUT
OF THE JAPAN. SOME ASSUME SEVEN
CISCO.
I DON'T YET THINK. DOC LOOK NO.
YES ON THE ASSEMBLY LOW THOUGH.
OKAY NO AB ONE FIVE OR SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M OPPOSED TO FUND SOME A CISCO
NO EIGHT BE FIFTEEN NO SAY NO
STUNT YOU KNOW.
Q..
MY NAME'S SURELY CLOCK HOW LAST
FUND COSTA COUNTY ACOSTA NEW.
OSCAR CONTRA COSTA I'M SORRY.
AND UP NO FIFTEEN OH SIX.
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE U. E. IKE
APLOMB.
SEMI CISCO PEACE TEAM LAW ON
FIFTEEN OH SIX.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I MIGHT END ESTáN I
FORUMS INDIANS SO.
.
NO I KNOW A BE ONE FIVE ZERO
SIX.
THANK YOU.
I'M MY NAME IS A LAND LINE I'M
COME FROM OF OAKLAND. AYE VOTE
AGAINST THE AB ONE FIVE ZERO
SIX.
MY NAME IS HE TO WHO FONG SUNG
JOSE HOMEOWNER. AGAINST AB ONE
FIVE ALL SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS NORA NISSAN I'M
FROM FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA AND
SOLANO COUNTY. I AM HERE NOT
JUST FOR MYSELF BUT FOR OTHER
PROPERTY OWNERS AND PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES. WE ALL
WANT YOU TO PLEASE VOTE AGAINST
FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
BUT I.
NOT MY NAME IS TINA FUNDS
IMPRESSES SCHOOL NO EIGHT BE ONE
FIVE THERE WERE SIX.
MINUS PETE SHOULDN'T VERMONTER
COUNTY A ROAST THEIR BROKER
NARAL ON AP ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
MY NAME IS SIVA. HOMEOWNER FUN
SAN FRANCISCO FEE I'M AGAINST.
AB FIFTY NO THANKS.
THANK YOU MISS GALLON FROM SOME
MYSTICAL ON THE HOME WILL NOT.
LOW ON FOOD BABY A FIFTY IN ALL
SIX.
THANKS.
MY NAME IS THE S. THIRTY I'M THE
HOME OWNER OF THE EAST PALO ALTO
CALIFORNIA.
I VOLVO KNOLL A BE ONE FIVE OH
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS TONY CAME FROM SOME JOSE ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE BAY AREA HOME
OWNERS ASSOCIATION. PLEASE VOTES
NO I'M AB FIFTEEN ZERO SIX.
MY NAME IS ABDUL MOHAMMED I'M
WHICH ORGANIZATION A FROM LOS
ANGELES VOTE YES AB YOU. FIFTEEN
DON'T SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I'M JENNY FROM SAN JOSE I SAY NO
ON A B. FIFTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NEMESIS SYNCHRONY IN FROM
SOME FASTER CHICAGO I WON'T KNOW
ALL KNOW ON A AND FIFTY A
PREVIEW OF THE DEAL SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S CUTS BELOW I'M PHAM
SEMI FISCAL AYE OPPOSED AB ONE
FIVE OR SIX.
THERE MEDICAL ANYONE FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY.
AND NO AB ONE FILE YOUR SETS
DON'T CARE.
MY NAME SO SO WE Mú I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO NO. A BE ONE FIVE
OR SIX THANK YOU.
MILEY LIE YOUNG.
FROM SOME OF HIS EAGLE. EYE A
RULE. AB ONE FIVE. ZERO SIX.
HI I'M SORRY. I AM ON LOW AB ONE
FIVE OR SIX.
THANK YOU.
TORTURE I'M.
I AM GLORIA I'M FROM PUTS THEM
BACK TO SCHOOL I STRONGLY ONE TO
SAY NO NO ON EIGHT. ONE FIVE OLD
STATE.
MY NAME IS PAM.
THAT FUNDING AND CUT MY FACE
AGO. GOAL ALL IP EFFECTING NO NO
SAID. THANK THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BARBARA PINTO
REPRESENT AIDS FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED AB
ONE FIVE OF SIX.
MY NAME IS SUE LISA CAME FROM
SAN FRANCISCO I'VE ROLE ON NO.
A BRIEF FIFTEEN ZERO SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY LAND THE SPY AND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NO ON AB ONE FIVE ZERO
SIX.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME OF LAMIACOME FROM ON
THE SUMMER A HE SCHOOL NO ONE
EIGHT BE AFFECTING AEROSPACE.
YOU
HI MY NAME IS CINDY AND I'M FROM
SOMEONE SURE SCHOOL I WILL PHONE
NO. FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN.
Q..
MARIAM PART TIME FOR SOMEONE FIX
YOU CALL LOW EARLY P. ONE.
BY.
SIXTY.
DON'T.
MY NAME IS SABRINA LEE AND.
PART TIME LANDLORDS IN BAY AREA
SAN FRANCISCO NO HBO SIX IS
SIMILAR. FUND THE LANDLORDS.
HYMAN EMMITT THOMAS WHEN I'M
REPRESENT A CHINESE REALLY STATE
OF SOCIAL AMERICA I STRONGLY R.
TO COMMITTEES VOTE NO ON AB
FIFTEEN OR THINK THANK YOU.
IN MY NAME IS HARLON TEN I'M
REALLY I'M COME FROM OAKLAND. ID
PERCENT NOLAN SMALL OWNER.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AT
AT EIGHT P..
TEAM EFFORT YOU KNOW SIX.
HI MY NAME IS ONE SIGN ON A
PRIVATE RESIDENCE FROM AND BROWN
CALIFORNIA AND.
AGAINST
AB ONE FIVE OH SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH YEAH AND I
WAS SURPRISED UNITY TO THE.
OWNER SO I STRONGLY WHOA R. AND.
AB YOU WAS FIFTEEN OWES LIKE.
NO.
MY MEMBERS OF QUEEN THEM TO
COME FROM SAN FRANCISCO I WILL
FUN THOUGH.
MY NAME'S DING NEED I COME FROM
SOME BICYCLE AND IRON LEGAL
PHONE NO ON AB ONE FIRE I ONLY
SAY.
HI MY NAME IS SANDY FROM UP BAY
AREA I WANT TO SAY NO ARMED A BE
FIFTEEN OH STAKES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME REYES EYEING AND I COME
FROM MILPITAS BLOUSE APIECE
SMELL PRECISE.
WOW ARM I'M AGAINST.
ARE A BEEFED UP FIFTEEN NO SIX
ARE I READ THIS BILL BEFORE BY
THOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
SPEAKER.
I I MEANT THE FROM GILROY. I ST
NULL ON THE AB ONE FIVE ZERO
SIX.
THANK YOU.
YEAH MY DISAPPEAR CALL I COME
FROM GILROY.
I IS A SAID NO ON.
ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S SIMON THE FROM
SACRAMENTO NO ONE EIGHT BE FETED
OVER SIXTY.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M GOING FROM SACRAMENTO NO
NO NO ON A BE FIFTEEN OH SIX.
THANKS.
JEAN FIRST US OAKLAND SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDER OPPOSE.
IRENE LOW SAN FRANCISCO I
REPRESENT ALL HARDWORKING HONEST
PEOPLE KNOW ON. FIFTEEN OH SIX
THANK YOU.
I'M ROBERT BAILEY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO HOMEOWNER TAXPAYERS
LANDLORD AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS SIMONE VALRULE. LOW
ON EIGHTY.
FIFTEEN OH SIX
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S CATHOLIC HIGH FROM
UNICITY CALIFORNIA MON LONG NO
ON AB FIFTY ALSO EXPECT.
MY NAME THE CHAIN WARRANT CAME
FROM SO THAT UNICITY.
MY VOICE IS A NO AB.
ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KEN LA FORMA OPEN.
NO ON AB FIFTEEN OVER SEX.
LAWRENCE TbM FROM SAN RAMON.
NO. FIFTEEN OH SIX.
RICHARD JONES REDWOOD CITY
CALIFORNIA NO ON AB FIFTY NO
SIX.
PETER CASE ZACK.
CARMICHAEL NO ON FIFTY NO SIX.
MY NAME IS MAY COME FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NO EIGHT BE FEE FOR
THEIR OWN SAKE.
MY NAME IS MASON AND FROM MORGAN
HILL. ANNUL AB FIFTEEN OLD SIX.
HOW WAITING FROM SUMMONSES CO I
SAY NO ONE PP FIFTEEN OH SIX?
I'M ONE JUDGE C#M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO BONE ALL ON FIFTEEN
HM SIX.
I'M KURT CONROY FROM MENLO PARK.
I'M THE FOUNDER AND SPOKESPERSON
FOR THE. BETTER HOUSING
COALITION OF MOUNTAIN DEW.
UNDER SEVENTY FIVE MEMBERS VOTE.
NO ON AB FIVE ONE FIVE OR SIX.
NANCY LIVE.
OPEN. UP.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON A BEEF FIFTEEN
ZERO SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHN JOHN I COME FROM
SOMETIMES GO PLEASE NEW. WELL NO
ON A P. FIFTEEN OH SIX.
MY NAME IS JULIA KWONG I'M FROM
SOME TO CISCO AYE OPPOSED AB
PIPINO SIX.
PROS ROCCA. I WORK FOR A
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT COMPANY. BUT
I'M ALSO A RENTER IN NORTH
OAKLAND.
AND I VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN NO SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHN CHAIR AND I'M
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
I'M HERE FOR MYSELF AND A FEW
OTHER PROPERTY OWNERS. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO SIX
THANK YOU.
AND WE THEN RESIDENT OF
SUNNYVALE AYE OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
THOUGH SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THAT LINDA CHEN FROM
MOON. OAKLAND I'M OF MOM AND POP
SMALL PUPPY OWNER. BUT I.
I THINK THOUGH A.
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX HARMFUL TO
THE.%
HOUSING MARKET I WILL KNOW ON
FIFTEEN. HOLDS ALL SIX AB.
I'M UNITS IT WAS AMEND REALTOR
AND COMMERCIAL AS WELL FROM
ALAMEDA. AGAINST OF AB FIFTEEN
OF SIX.
MICHAEL CHAO FROM SAN FRANCISCO
I'M A REALTOR WHO REPRESENTS ALL
UMPS.
RETIRED APARTMENT OWNERS AND WHO
DEPEND ON THE INCOME FROM THEIR
APARTMENTS NO ON FIFTY NO SIX
THANK YOU.
MORNING MY NAME'S ALAN LOUIS I'M
A REALTOR PROPERTY OWNER. AND A
PROP.
A REALTOR.
IN SAM TELL COUNTY IN SAN
FRANCISCO NO IN FIFTEEN OH SIX
THANK YOU.
ONLY TWELVE BUILT OF LOUD YES
HOLD FIFTEEN ALL SIX.
MY NAME IS THAT AND OWN. I SEE
NO NO NO I'M EIGHT BPP HOME SIX.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA I HAVE A
FULL TIME JOB AND THE SMALL ON
OUR PROPERTY I SAY NO NO NO. TO
AB FIFTY OR SIX THANKS.
MY NAME IS THEIR SO I'M HOME ON
THEIR OWN SIMPLICITY I SIGNAL A.
FIFTEEN ALL SIX.
HI TERRY PER WEEK SUMMER HELP
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT. I REPRESENT
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY OWNERS KNOW
ON FIFTEEN NO SIX.
HI ROSEMARY GIBSON WITH GIPSON
PORTFOLIO MANAGEMENT I MANAGE
PROPERTY FOR FORTY PROPERTY
OWNERS AND I VOTE NO.
HI MY NAME IS KYLE FONG AND I'M
A MEMBER STUDENTS UNITED WITH
RENTERS SYSTEM ORGANIZATION FROM
UC SANTA CRUZ.
WE I'M COALITION WITH RENTERS OF
SANTA CRUZ AND THOSE ARE
HOMELESS AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY NO SIX AND A
FULL REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU.
HI SPEAKS EARLY BOTH REPRESENTS
MAMA POP HOUSING PROVIDERS IN
SAN JOSE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB
FIFTY NO SIXTH
ACUTE NEXT WEEK.
HI MY NAME IS KEVIN ALBERT COME
FROM SACRAMENTO ON THE LANDLORD
AND I SEE NO ON FIFTEEN NO SIX.
GARRICK AND ASIAN AMERICAN REAL
STATE ASSOCIATION GREATER YOU
SPAY NO ON A BE FIFTEEN NO SIX.
LARA CAME.
AGED BELIEVES THE ASSOCIATION
AMERICA. THE.
LOTS CHANGE DOES NOT BENEFIT
THE TENANT SO I SAY NO TO AB
FIFTY NO SIX.
HI MY NAME IS JESSICA FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
I WAS TONI SAY NO ONE AB ONE
FIGHT OVER SIX.
STANLEY CHAN FROM SAN FRANCISCO
I STRONGLY OPPOSE FIFTEEN WOULD
OWE SIX THANK YOU.
COMMENTS JAM FROM CITY ABA
ALAMEDA I CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
FOR FREEDOM AND FOR FREE MARKET
NO.
AND NEEDLE FOR.
SOMEONE CISCO AYE WELL NO HAN
PATE BE FIFTEEN ALL SENSE THEN
HERE.
THEY BIG JOHN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
NO ON A BE. ONE FIVE OH SIX.
I AM NOT TO AND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NO ON AB ONE FIVE OR
SIX.
MY MAN YOU SEE TEN.
AND NO ONE EIGHT FIVE FOUR I'M
SOME CONSISTENT. THOUGH WHEN
THEY BE.
ONE BY YELLOW SAYS.
NO. MY KNEES AND I FOUND SAID.
I FUND SENTENCES TO CALL HOLE ON
EIGHT BE FEE FOR TEENS CELSIUS
THANK YOU.
THIS IS ROSY LEAVE FROM
MILLBRAE.
OPPOSING ONE FIVE OR SIX.
I ROGER ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATIONS
QUARTER OF A MILLION STUDENTS IN
EVERY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME ANYTHING REMOTELY I'M
FROM SAN JOSE I HAD TO BE AN
ATTENDANT FOR A YEARS ON THOSE
AND A HOME OWNER FOR TEN YEARS.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB FIFTEEN
ZERO SIX SACKS THANK YOU.
MATTHEW LEWIS ON BEHALF OF THE
BERKELEY TENANTS UNION STRONG
SUPPORT AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIAN DEMOCRATS
PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS IN STRONG
SUPPORT WHICH WILL REMEMBER. HOW
PEOPLE VOTE IN THE PRIMARY MUCH
YOU VERY MUCH?
HI I'M EVELYN POSTMAN TEAR I'M
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO TENANTS
UNION I'M A SENIOR.
ABOUT LIVING WITH A DISABILITY
AND PLEASE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M EAGLE ATTRACT
UP OF BARCLAY AND ON BEHALF OF
BOTH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. AND THE LEVEL
OF ONE HUNDRED CHAPTERS AND WHAT
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF THE CALIFORNIA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS WE ARGUE TO VOTE YES
ON FIFTEEN ALL SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DENNIS SO SHE
DONE ON THE EXTERNAL VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS OF UC MERCED AS WELL AS
THE CAMPAIGN CHAIR FOR YOU SEE A
SAFE. AND I URGE YOU ALL TO VOTE
YES.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT MAGEE
AREA I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
AND WITH THE BERKELEY EAST BAY
GRAY PATH OF. VOTE YES ON AB
FIFTY NO SIX AND.
AND COST UP IS NOW.
THANK YOU HI I'M RITA COULD STOP
THIS SUMMER SMALL PROPERTY OWNER
AND I VOTE.
NO ON FIFTEEN NO SIX.
HI AYE AYE AND WHO SAYS YEAH I'M
FLOW.
SOME A CISCO AND THEIR LANDMARK
KNOW ON AB ONE FIVE HOLES SAKE.
HI MY NEWS ADA I AM I'M FORUMS
OFFICE OF.
SUCH I'M THOMAS ITS GOAL AND
THEN THE WHOLE. AB ONE FIVE
JOSE.
ROXANNE ALBERT TOLLEY AMIR
INDIVIDUAL NO ON FIFTEEN OH SIX.
THIS IS A BILL PINE FROM SOME
CISCO I WILL KNOW TO.
TUESDAY'S UPON.
NOT THAT I'M A PLATE YOU. MY
NAME IT'S A TO YOUR WING.
BECAUSE THING SEE WAS IT IS I'M
I FEEL I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO
SUNSET.
OWNER.
AND YOU YES THING AND ALL OF
LIKE LIKE RIGHT OW AB ONE FIVE
OR SIX. TORTURE THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS CECILIA AGING AND COME
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND
PLEASE-WON'T KNOW ON AB ONE FIVE
OR SIX.
HI MY NAME IS LISA FORUMS
SUMMONSES CALL. I VOLATILE NO
ONE. AB ONE FIVE ALMOST SIX IT.
AND GET.
I WOULD JAN HOPE I'M FUNDS THEM
A TALE LITTLE ON A P. ONE VITAL
STAKES.
HI MY NAME IS LISA BOWERMAN AYE
MCCARRON FARE.
SMALL PROPERTY OWNER PLEASE
VOTE NO.
THIS IS A JOHN HIZO FROM SENATE
FISCAL VOTE NO ON AB ONE FIVE
ZERO SIX PLACE.
Q..
GOOD MORNING MY NAME JOHNNY
WILL.
AYE FOR SERVICE AS COOL. NO
FITTING ALSO EXPECT YOU THANK
YOU.
HELLO I'M CAROL COLLINS A SMALL
TIME HOUSING PROVIDER.
IF FROM ATHERTON AND I OPPOSE
AB FIFTY NO SEX THINKING.
HI MY LANFANG CLEAN THOU FORM
SAN FRANCISCO. NARAL ALL ONE
EIGHTY BE. THE VICTIM OH SIX.
MY THEM YOU SEE KNOWING ALONG.
LOW ON AB. FIFTY.
OLD SIXTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT JONATHAN GROW OAKLAND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN
NO SIX.
I THINK PASSAGES ECONOMIC
ILLITERACY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER.
LYNN MAYOR OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE VOTE NO.
REALTOR BROKER SMALL HOUSING
PROVIDER THANK YOU.
I AM STEVE EDRINGTON ON THE
LANDLORD IN A REAL THREAT TO
LIVE INRABAT THIS DISTRICT AND
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS THANKS.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M THING PLUMS AND FUND
CISCO PIECE.
WELL THRILL ON.
MAY ONE FIFTEEN OH SIX.
HELLO.
I AM MINUTES I'M.
I'M.
LEADING SOMEONE SAYS IT ALL. NO
ON A BE IN ONE FIVE YEAR OLD
SAFE.
ARE AMONG THEM IT'S WE DbN.
CHEN ARE COME FROM SOME
FRANCISCO NO. A BE FIFTEEN OH
SIX.
MY NAME IS PATTY CHEN FROM SANTA
CLARA NO tNG EIGHT B. ONE FIVE
ZERO SIX.
MY LAND YES WEIGHT WHEN YOU HAVE
COME FROM SAN FRANCISCO I WON'T
GO ON AB ONE FIVE OH SIX THANK
YOU.
MY MAN MAKES IT C#M A TEAM. I
COME FROM SOMEONE SUCH CALL I
SAY NO I'M NOT.
AB FIFTY KID OH SET.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME BECKY LEAVE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. VOTE NO ON AB ONE
FIVE OR SIX NO NO NO.
HI MICHELLE SAY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
TEENY SIERRA COME FROM SERVICES
SCHOOL AND NO ON. OF FIFTEEN OH
SIX.
YEAH I MADE ALLOW I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. THOUGH ON ONE BY AP
YOU ONE FIVE ZERO SIX NULL NULL.
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
CLOUDING. I COME FROM SOME CISCO
STATE AND ALL ON AB ONE FIVE OH
SIX NODE NO.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME YOU SEE ME AROUND LOW.
AND FORUMS SOMEONE CISCO FLOW ON
A P. MODIFY SO.
SO SIX.
HI MY NAME IS HUGO ING FROM
SAM'S DISCO I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
HI MY NAME IS KENNEDY REALLY AT
FORUMS ON LET'S JUST CALL NO AB
LADEN. FIVE YELLOW SIX PLAYERS.
BAG YOU.
WHY THEN IS IT THE KILLER? AYE
FROM ARE LIVING THERE THOMAS IF
YOU CALL.
I KNOW.
AP FIFTY.
ALSO IF
NO NO NO.
MY AGE IN WHILE I'M PHONE
SERVICES AGO.
I.
NO ONE AB ONE FIVE OH SIX.
WHENEVER SCAN A ZEN FORUMS OF
ASSIST GOAL.
NO AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
FRIDAY'S ASSIGNMENT CHAIR AND I
A COUPLE OAKLAND FLORIDA YOU
SPAY RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION
IV POSTS AND ALL THE MEMBER ALL
WILL YOU STAY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION SAY NO PEACE VOTE
LOW. BALL AB FIFTY OH SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS PATRICIA MCGOLDRICK
FROM PUT ALL PLEASE VOTE NO ON
AB ONE FIVE OF SIX TAKING.
MY NAME IS TIM KERNS AND I
POSTED FIFTEEN NO SIX.
MY NAME IS ANGELA CHAN AND I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I REPRESENT.
BETTER HOUSING POLICY THOUGHT OR
AND SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS THAT
OR TO SAY NO ON AB ONE FIVE OH
SIX.
YOU VERY MUCH.
DENISE OFTEN A REAL ESTATE
BROKER DANVILLE CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE AB ONE FIVE OH SIX
THANK YOU.
AND THEN THE CHILD MAY UP
CANADA'S FROM SAN FRANCISCO I AM
A SOCIAL WORKER I AM YET TO
OPPOSE IT STRONGLY. NO AB ONE
FIVE OH SIX THANK YOU.
Q..
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID STERN'S
AMONG SMALL HOMEOWNER AND FATHER
OF TWO I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FOUR
ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
ACCU.
MY NAME IS FERNANDO KNOWS ALL
RETIRED NURSE.
ACE MEMBER FROM SACRAMENTO STOP
PRODUCT CORPORATE PROFITS OVER
PEOPLE.
AND PROBABLY VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR.
SPEAKER.
THAT'S ONE OF THE EFFORT THE LOW
NUMBER OF NINETY AUTHORITY OFTEN
WITH LITTLE ST HENNESSEY SO
YEAH.
NUMBER THAT SOON.
YEAH WELL YOU ALL CAN.
KING SAYS.
AYE WITH HIM SOON.
SEVERAL CITIES. PEOPLE FALL
WATER.
IF THE.
JUST LOOK GROWS HE IN ALL MY THE
FELLOW WHO WAS NO MUSCLE MENTAL
THEM INTO. GRASSROOTS.
TRANSLATE.
SHE WAS IN SUPPORT OF OUR THE
REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS HELLO MY
NAME'S EDUARDO TOURISM AN
ORGANIZER WITH TENNIS TOGETHER
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION I'M HERE
REPRESENTING SEVENTEEN MILLION
RENTERS IN CALIFORNIA WHO WANT
FULL REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS.
STOP WITH THE LANDLORD LIES.
I AM MY NAME IS NICHOLAS ABOUT
DYNAMIN ORGANIZER WITH THE EAST
BAY ALLIANCE RACIST ANIMAL KANA.
WE WORK IN ALLIANCE WITH
COMMUNITY GROUPS PEOPLE OF FAITH
AND LABOR TO BRING ABOUT CHANGE
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND THAT
WE SUPPORT THE REPEAL AND I WANT
TO SAY THAT BUT OPPOSITION LIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINDA OSAMA BERKELEY TENANTS
UNION REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
BECAUSE THE RENTS TO HIGHER
PAPER MUCH.
NICK SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS SON THAT I'D SEE YEAH
HE MENDOZA ADVICE AND DOWN.
MY NAME IS CENTER GARCIA AND I
COME FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
I ALMOST NEVER DOES NOT HOW MOST
AND FEEDING HIS THIS AMEND
FENLON. NOT IN THAT W. WILL NOT
SEE FY YEMEN LACKING SAYS I
DON'T THINK. ANIMAL FARM WORKER
AND I CAN'T AFFORD ANYMORE RENT
AND KEEP VERY HIGH SUPPORT
FIFTEEN ZERO SIX.
WELL I'M A NUMBER OF AN
AUTOMATED SEE UP WE ALLOW BANDS
HAVE SENT TOPPLE OVER HERE.
.
SEE UP MY EMBASSY.
MY NAME IS BERNIE DORMERS THEM
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I
ALSO SUPPORT AB. FIFTY NO SIX.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA BERGER I'M
FROM SANTA CRUZ TENANTS
ASSOCIATION I REPRESENT ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND VERY SMALL TENANTS
AND WE ARE ALL FOR HER. A BI
FIFTH DONO SIX THANK YOU.
YES MY NAME IS ART RODRIGUEZ I
REPRESENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EMPOWERMENT ALLIANCE AND IT.
WE OUR A PIPE COUNTY WIDE
COALITION.
AND WE SUPPORT AB FIFTY NO SIX.
I'M FINE IF HIS FATHER.
FROM SACRAMENTO I'M WE'VE SEIU
THEM I'M STRONGLY SUPPORTS BUT
AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB ONE FIVE
OR SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TONY GRAHAM I
REPRESENT THE SENIORS AND
DISABLED COMMITTEE PROUD TO BE A
PART OF THE ALAMEDA RANCHERS
COALITION THOSE OF US ON FIXED
INCOMES DESPERATELY MAKE A VERY
MUCH NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS GABRIELLE GABBY
DOLPHIN AND I AM A DELEGATE IN
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
FOR THE FIGHTING A DEEP THE
EIGHTEENTH. AND I FULLY SUPPORT
THIS BIL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S LISA HALL I'M A
FORMER HOMEOWNER I AM A CITY OF
ALAMEDA DISABILITY COMMISSIONER
AND I PLEAD YOU TO DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIANS
AND STOP THIS RATE BEING TO HELP
YOU FIND A LOT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEXT SPEAKER. LAURA WHAT IT WITH
ALAMEDA RENTERS COALITION I AM
HARD WORKING PERSON AT RISK OF
DISPLACEMENT I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT. AB FIFTY OF SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MAHDI BETTIS FREEZE
HOW EMIRATIS COALITION PRESIDENT
I'M ASKING YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
THE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
YESTERDAY BUT OUR TALK SHOW AND
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I ASK EVERYONE PLEASE
TO RESPECT THE RULES THAT WE
NEED TO LAY DOWN HERE SO THAT WE
CAN GET THROUGH EVERYONE. IN
LINE THANK UNIX SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS ROXANA THOUGHT APPIAH
AND I REPRESENT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY EMPOWERMENT ALLIANCE AND
UNITED KERN COUNTY I'M FROM
BAKERSFIELD AND I SUPPORT
FIFTEEN OH SICK YA UP ALL YOUR
KEEN SAYS THAT ALL SAFE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIUS ELITES
AND I'M FOR BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE DEMOCRATIC DELEGATE I'M
ALSO ON THAT CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
YOU RETIRED AMERICANS AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY EMPOWER MENT
ALLIANCE AND ALSO WITHOUT A
FEVER. AWARENESS IN RESOURCES
AND I DON'T THINK ANYBODY KNOWS
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE A HOUSE
UNTIL YOU GET THINKING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I'M GONNA ASK FOLKS.
I'M GONNA ASK FOLKS THE LAST
THREE SPEAKERS HAVE NOT.
RESPECTED THE RULES OR TRY TO
LAY DOWN HERE AND I'M GONNA ASK
EVERYONE. IF YOU COULD PLEASE DO
THAT BECAUSE OTHERWISE.
THIS WILL NOT BE FAIR FOR
EVERYONE HAS BEEN WAITING IN
LINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
SPEAKER.
HI MY NAME IS SHARON WAY OUT
THERE I'M A DELEGATE FOR BAKER
SOME CALIFORNIA KERN COUNTY.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON A BE FIFTEEN
OR SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AUSTIN TbM A
DISABILITY ADVOCATES WHAT IT
DOES IS ACTIVISTS AND THE ONE
WHOSE LIVES ARE THE DISABILITY
AND I SUPPORT A BE.
IF YOU KNOW THINK THE PILL COSTA
HAWKINS I MEAN ROB BONTA
DISTRICT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DAN HARPER TENANTS TOGETHER LIVE
IN RICHMOND CALIFORNIA JIM WOOD
MARK STONE YOU CAN DO THIS VOTE
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SUSAN MARCH WITH THE SO HOUSING
RIGHTS COMMITTEE OF SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS NOW TENANTS NEEDED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
LAURIE CANCEL FROM SANTA CLARA
AND VOTE NO ON AB ONE FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU.
IN A SOLID HOOK FROM SANTA CLARA
LOAD NO PLACE.
PLATINUM MILINKOVICH FROM SAN
JOSE AND I SAY NO A BEEF FIFTY
NO SIX.
THANK YOU.
ALLEN APPEL NEVADA CITY
CALIFORNIA WE NEED MORE HOUSING
NOT LESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
VOTE NO.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL SPENT OVER
SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA SAY VOTE
NO IN FIFTEEN OH SIX PLEASE
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL FITZGERALD FROM SAN JOSE
POLICE VOTE NO AGAINST AB FIFTY
NO SIX THANK YOU.
VIVIAN FAN FOR MOUNTAIN VIEW
PLEASE DON'T KNOW FROM FIFTEEN
OH SIX.
DEBUT TEARS FROM SAN JOSE FOR
PLEASE VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN OH
SIX.
SHARON PITT FROM SAN FRANCISCO
IN A MEMBER OF FACED PLEASE VOTE
YES ON FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
GRAZIANO DE LA CRUZ SENIOR
SEVENTY YEAR OLD YES ON FIFTEEN
OH SIX.
RIVER HAVE FLOWS BAYLOR THUMPING
OF FISCAL.
UP OR YOU'RE NOT A.
THINGS HIS IS THANK OUR. EVERY
TO WE JUST SAW ME WALK DOWN THIS
A POLICIES.
RUSSELL YES THANK YOU.
HE SAYS HIS NAME WAS RELEASED
THEIR HERE SO IF YOU SEEN A LOT
OF PEOPLE PUSHED OUT OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD YES ON FIFTEEN NO
SIX.
RAYMOND CUSTODIAL WOULD PSALM
CANS ON A MARKET COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK IN SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE VOTE YES TO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS I WORK A LOT OF PEOPLE
GET THE SPACE OF A.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO WITH SOME CAN
PLEASE VOTE YES THANK YOU.
JEAN ALEJO WOULD SONG CAN'T
PLEASE VOTE YES ON A BE FIFTEEN
OR SIXTEEN Q..
HELLO DAVID WHO WAS SOME CAN
LIVES IN SAN FRANCISCO WE SEE
FAMILIES GET EVICTED EVERYDAY
YES ON FIFTEEN NO SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ALAN USED TO GO I'M A
TEACHER AND A SMALL LANDLORD
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND EMERGING
YOU TOREPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
IF YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DEBBIE
FELONY SO ARM FROM LOS ANGELES I
WOULD THINK YOU KNOW SALINAS
PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB FIFTY OR
SIX IT IS URGENT THANK YOU.
COLLECT CRUTCHER AND WITH A SO I
HOPE YOU REALIZE THAT REAL
ESTATE SPECULATORS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NICK
SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING I'M KNOWN A RICH IN
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M A SMALL
PROPERTY OWNER AND PRESIDENT OF
THE SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
YEAH AND CRAIG FORMER MAYOR THE
CITY OF MILLBRAE PROPERTY OWNER
IN SAN FRANCISCO ON A VOTER
PLEASE VOTE NO.
THANK YOU.
SUSAN LEWIS A VOTER FROM KEVIN
MULLINS DISTRICT TWENTY TWO OUT
OF SAN MATEO.
OPPOSED TO AB FIFTEEN OF SIX THE
MECHANICS ARE WRONG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
HE WON'T FROM SOME ASSIST GO
WITH THAT BUT HOUSING POLICY DOT
ORG.
NO ON FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
SAYING DIESEL REALLY TIENE FIVE
SEVEN A CISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
HE'S THREE PRE SOMEONE NO ON AB
ONE FLY OH SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
JANICE LEASE REAL ESTATE AGENT
PROPERTY OWNER OF IT.
NO ON FIFTEEN ALL SIX.
Q..
TRIM THE WHOLE.
SMALL PARTLY THE OWNER. PEACE
OPPOSE
OFTEN SIX THANKS THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING KATHRYN QUIGG CITY
OF MILLBRAE. WE OPPOSE FIFTEEN
OH SIX
I THINK YOU KNOW.
WHEN HOPE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CHINESE WILL STAY ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA AND I OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
THOUGH SIX BECAUSE YOU AT TO NAY
ON EVER GROWING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SEVEN CHANCE SAN FRANCISCO REAL
ESTATE ATTORNEY PLEASE VOTE NOW
THANK YOU.
JOHN WONG THE RESIDENTS SAN
FRANCISCO A VERY VEHEMENT NO ON
AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK YOU.
CALEB SMITH WITH THE UNITY
COUNCIL IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
YES ON FIFTEEN OF SIX THANK YOU.
DANNY LU WITH THE CHINESE REAL
ESTATE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
AND IN DALY CITY VOTE NO FOR A
BI FIFTEEN SIX THANK YOU.
JOHNNY RODRIGUES OF LANDLORD AND
TENANT. AYE VOTE NO ON A BE
FIFTEEN OF SIX.
A GUY YEAH ANYA'S FROM SANTA
CLARA NO ON.
BE AB ONE FIVE LC.
DEBBIE BASSAM FROM MOUNTAIN
VIEW.
NO ON FIFTEEN NO SIX.
CREATE ARE ALL CITY OF MOUNTAIN
VIEW OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO SEX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME SEE COLLEEN TALL AYE.
I FROM SERVICES COAL.
NO ON EIGHT BEEF FIFTEEN HOLLOW
SIX.
MARLENE TRjN A RETIRED PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER LIKE HUNDREDS OF
A SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO FIFTY.
IF YOU KNOW SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S CLOUDS ME AND I'M
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROVIDER
OF MEMBER OF THE BERKELEY
PROPERTY OWNERS ASSOCIATION
SINCE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES
AND OPPOSED TO THE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS BETTY T. I'M FROM
SUNDANCE HE'S COOL FIFTEEN A
REPEALING OF COSTA HAWKINS IS
UNFAIR TO TO OWNER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MIGHT PAY AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M GONNA JUST REPEAT AGAIN THE
LIGHTNESS OF THE HOUSE WE'RE
ASKING PEOPLE TO GIVE THEIR
NAME.
AND ORGANIZATION OR A OR A CITY
AFFILIATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE JUST THE WORK
SUPPORTER PUTTING GOOD COP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I AM MINA MUSICAL MIRAMAX I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M NOT ON AB
FIFTY NINE SIX.
MY NAME IS MARK CLIMB FROM
SUMMER CISCO I RECOMMEND THAT
THE GOVERNMENT POLICY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
NEXT BIGGER THOUGH.
A DOOR ON IP FIFTY IN ALL SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS VINCE TOMORROW FROM
YOU IN CITY CALIFORNIA. I'M A
PROPERTY OWNER SUFFERING HERE
AND I POST.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT LENDS MATH
I'M FROM PALO ALTO NO ON AID BE.
FIFTEEN NO SIX THANK YOU.
AYE DOUG SMITH FROM POWER
ALTHOUGH IN SAN FRANCISCO PLEASE
DON'T KNOW ON FIFTY O SIX THANK
YOU.
ACCU.
SOON YOU US ON THE AB. DOWN FROM
DANVILLE NO ON FIFTEEN OR SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOHN THE SWORDS A. CONCORD NOW
ON FIFTY NO SIX THINK.
REED ROBERTSON ORINDA NO AND
FIFTEEN NO SICK I WOULD RETURN
OF THE GAVEL OVER TO MY VICE
CHAIR FOR JUST.
A FEW MINUTES I'LL BE BACK.
IT. KUMAR FROM CONCORD NO ONE
FIFTY NO SIX PLEASE.
MY NAME IS TAL HO LOAN.
FROM SERVICE FILLED WITH YOUR
WHOLE AYE OPPOSED AB ONE FIVE OR
SAFE.
JOAN CAME FROM SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN OH
SIX.
HELLO YA FROM SOME DISCO WILL
KNOW ON VIEW.
THANK YOU.
JEFF WE LOVE.
MY LIFE UNITED THUMBS BOTH SOME
SUBSTANCE GO THE VOTE NO ON
FIFTY NO SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS LILY MORENO AND
I'M FROM PLEASANTON CALIFORNIA
VOTE NOW ON FIFTEEN NO SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I'M JACQUELINE MARTINEZ
REPRESENTING MY LIVING NO ON AB
FIFTEEN OF.
I'M MICHELLE WHY MOULIN NOR DO I
RENT TO LOW INCOME TENANTS.
I VOTE NO ON AB FIFTY NO SIX.
FROM LOCAL.
HI MY NAME IS STEVE WILLIAMS I'M
ALL LOW INCOME PROPERTY OWNER ON
MEDI CAL. IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
VOTE NO THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S JB ALLEN JOHNNY AND
FROM SAN FRANCISCO VOTE NO NO NO
ON FIFTEEN NO SIX THAT'S THREE
VOTES PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THURMOND THE MINUTE THE CO
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
COUNCIL COMMUNITY HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS YES ON FIFTY NO
SIX.
AARON READS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION ADVOCATE WITH YA SAN
FRANCISCO YES ON FIFTEEN NO SEX.
BRENDAN ARMY DELEGATE TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE
PARTY SUPPORTS THE REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
LANCE VENDOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER SAN FRANCISCO.
PLEASE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
ANNE FARROW ICE FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE SAINT FRANCIS
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGE IN SAN
FRANCISCO LET'S SUPPORT SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS BUT YES.
ON STABLE RENT.
TREVOR MARTIN A SAN FRANCISCO
PROGRESSIVE ALLIANCE TREASURE OF
SAN FRANCISCO BERNIE KRATZ
TREASURE OF SAN FRANCISCO FOR
DEMOCRACY DEMOCRACY FOR AMERICA
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
PETER HOLDEN SEARS CISCO DON'T
REPEAL THE PROTECTIONS FOR FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS THANK YOU.
LARA SMALL.
MEMBER FOR SMALL PROPERTY
OWNERS ASSOCIATION SAN
FRANCISCO.
NO I'M AB FIFTY NO SIX.
GARLAND CHAN FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND I VOTE NO ON AB FIFTY NO
SEX.
HIGH MY NIECE FAY I'M OF RECIPES
FROM SOMEONE FISCAL. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
AB FIFTEEN ZERO SIX PLEASE WON'T
LOW LOW LOW.
MY NAME IS A MAYBE I CAN FUNDS
AND LOCAL I. MAGNIN VERIFY SAY
NO TO EIGHT THE LEFT FILE SAKES.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STEVEN HERE.
I SOMETIME ASSISTED RIGHT NOW
I'D WHEN FIVE POSTS YEAH.
HE TWO THINK YOU MIGHT HEAR MY
NAME IS EVA SHALL I HAVE BEEN
THE RENTER AND ALMOST A MEMBER
OF THE SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION. I DEFINITELY SAY NO
VOTE NO ON PROP.
AB FIX FIFTEEN OH SIX BECAUSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
I MY NAME IS SHERMAN CAM FROM MY
SUMMER CISCO.
I'VE BEEN BROKE A BIT A HOUSING
POLICY PRIEST VOTE NO ON AP ONE
OF OUR SIX THANK YOU.
TERRENCE JONES SAN FRANCISCO
VOTER NO ONE AB FIFTY NO SEX.
I AM GRACELAND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE SAY NO TO
FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU.
CHRISTOPHER DAVIES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MEMBER OF SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS OF STEPS GO
PLEASE VOTE AGAINST AB FIFTY NOW
SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BADLY QUAN.
NO ON.
AB FIFTY IN ALL SIX.
MY THEN TWO THIEVES WELL I'M
SEVEN CISCO.
WELL AB ON A BE VICTIM OH SIX.
THANK YOU MY LAND USE OF ONE
LYNGBY HOMES SYNTHESIS CALLED.
NO ON A P. ONE FIVE OR SIX.
MY NAME YOU'D STAND IT FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. ROLE A YEAR ONE FIVE
ZERO SIX.
MY NAME IS MAGGIE FUNDS EVAN
CISCO LOW ON ONE FIVE ZERO SIX
SQUEEZES.
HI MY NAME IS FIVE YEARS SO I AM
CONFIDENT THAT A CISCO WHAT NO
ON AP FIFTEEN OH STAKES.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S NGUYEN INFORM FROM
SOME FISCAL PRESEVO.
NO ON. A BEAT ONE FIVE ZERO SIX
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A SOUL TURN SAN
FRANCISCO NO ONE EIGHT BE FUN
FIVE ALMOST SIXTY.
HEY MY NAME SINCE EVENMILD. AYE
FLORA I'M SENSE WHEREAS IS GOAL.
THEM OWNER. AND NOW AND.
SAVE KIAN SAILOR SIX NULL NULL
NULL.
MY NAME REFER CARE WHO LAW I'M
FROM GO SEE TOO OFTEN FROM FIFTH
CALL. I'M OUR GUNS TAYLOR VP
FIFTY ALL SIX.
SECOND.
MY MAN IS YOU CALL IT THEN TOLL.
I LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND NO NO NO AB BE.
AND FIFTEEN.
SAYS
YOU.
DAVID WONG SAN FRANCISCO
PEACEFUL VOTE NO ON AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX THANK YOU.
I NEVER SPENDING I'M FROM
SUBJECT CLINICAL NO ON A PEACE
SAYS THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS JOSE
FONSECA FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
PLEASE VOTE NOT.
FIFTY NO SIX.
MY NAME IS CARRYING APTLY I AM
OAKLAND A RENTER WHO CANNOT EVEN
DREAM OF OWNERSHIP PLEASE VOTE
YES.
PICK YOUR MUCH.
EUGENE TURRETS FROM FRIENDS OF
ADELINE IN SOUTH BERKELEY.
VOTE TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME IS RISE NEITHER
RESIDENT ELAINE LOAD OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
AND OPPOSED HIS BILL THINGS.
I'M HELEN FONG SAN FRANCISCO.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN I WAS
SIX.
MY NAME IS SWEENEY LAMB FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PEACE MON DOLE ON AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX.
AND HE WENT FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WILL KNOW ON A P. PITINO
SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NEXT YOU AND.
I WON'T KNOW.
AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX THINK IT
YEAH.
LOW ON. FIFTEEN OH SIX COME FROM
SACRAMENTO.
MY NAME IS JEAN FARMS AMEND
CISCO PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB.
FIFTEENTH OH SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS WILL BE FONG
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO NO AB
FIFTY OR SIX.
HI MY NAME'S MICHAEL DOWN PEACE
WILL KNOW WAS ON A BE FIFTEEN OH
SIX THAT YOU.
HEY MAN I'M USING REALLY AND I'M
FEINSTEIN HAS HE'S CO. I KNOW.
FIFTEEN HOLD SIX NULL NULL NULL.
THANK INNER SPEAKER MY LEGS
LAYING NO.
NOW ON A B. ONE FIVE OH SIX
PLEASE.
MY NAME IS SO TbM FROM FREMONT.
PEACE BOLTS NO ON A P. FIFTEEN
OH SIX
NO FREE LUNCH.
WHAT FOR IT?
NEXT
SPEAKER.
MY NIECE JENNY TOWN FROM
SACRAMENTO I WILL NOT ALL ON
EIGHTY ONE FIVE CYCLE SIX.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GRACE PIECE THONG
NO.
HBO AFFECTING OH SIX.
HONG CHAMP FROM SAN FRANCISCO
NULL ON AB FIFTEEN OR SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CINDY MAY I AM FROM
SAN FRANCISCO PLACE WHILE NO ONE
EIGHT BE FIFTEEN ALL SIX THANK
YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME'S DAVID
LOANS I COME FROM CENSUS GO
PEACEABLE NO ON A P. FIFTEEN OH
SIX THANK A ONE.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOWN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE PLEASE WON'T
KNOW FULL AB ONE FIVE OR SIX
THANK YOU.
CURRENT PRIME THEY MUSIC CONTENT
AND NO NO NO THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS.
SEQUEL YOU I'M LIFT IN ELKO.
PIECE.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON.
A BE FIFTEEN OH SIX.
MY LIMBS SOUL YEAH I.
STEM VINCE'S A CALL NOW AB
FIFTY IN ALL WHICH.
GAEL LAWS MORE FROM SAN JOSE
PACKED AYE REPRESENTING SENIORS
APPEAL APPEAL APPEAL.
HI I'M JOY STAND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
ESPECIALLY FROM CA CA WE OPPOSE
FIFTEEN NO SIX.
MY NAME IS A MEAL HALL FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I WILL NOTE TOOL. HBO
PICKED TEENS.
SEX THANK YOU.
MY MAYES BEINGS HAD A SUPERIOR
TO MRS CALL WE HAD NO ON. A BB
KING OH SIX.
I.
FREELY A LOSS OF FRANCISCO
PLEASE NO.
MAY MARC FROM SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE HOLD NO ON AB ONE FIVE OR
SIX THANK YOU.
MY NEPHEW OUT YEAH.
AND I.
I THINK OF MYSELF.
NOW IF YOU YOU ENCHANT AND. SOME
LOGISTICAL.
LOW IN.
LOW I AND EIGHT FEET LONG FLY
AREN'T SEXY.
OFFER NOT A.
SICK OF. THIS
MY NAME IS CA.
SO IT'S ALL Mú.
A NEW LOW.
I THEN.
NOT A.
THE.
FIFTEEN OH SISSY NOT.
SYMBOL CITICORP.
YOU.
WELL MY NAME IS AARON NEED. I'M
FROM CEMEX IT'S CALLED PRETTY
SMALL NO ON A P. FIFTEEN OH SIX
THEN TO LEARN MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS ROSE KHtNG I LIVE
IN SEVEN CISCO ON BEHALF OF THE
LAND LAW. AND NOT PLEASE BOTH NO
HAN EIGHT BE FIFTEEN NO SIX.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME SLOWLY OH I'M FROM
DAILY CD PRE UP PRETTY SMALL NO
ON PICKING OH SIX PINK YOU.
MY NAY SAID LILLY WONG AND PHONE
SAN MATEO PLEASE WILL KNOW.
PHONE FIFTEEN.
I NEED A CHANCE R. B. HABLABA MY
AGING HUSBAND AND MYSELF POLICE
VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JESSE AND I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. PLEASED MOAN NO
ON AB ONE FIVE OH SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CINDY Mú FROM
SERVICE GO PLEASE WELL NO ON AP
FIFTY NO SEX THING.
HI MY NAME'S EVA WONG I'VE FLOWN
ALL ON AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
MY NAME IS SELENA MADISON FROM
DAVIS AND I ASK YOU USE YOUR
VOICE.
AND VOTE NO FOR AP FIFTEEN OH
SIX THANK YOU.
CAROL DUMB SAN FRANCISCO I THANK
YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR NO VOTE
ON AB FIFTEEN ALL SIX.
I MY NAME IS PAT WATER SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA PLEASE VOTE
NO ON AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX
THANKS.
MY NAME IS NOBODY PLEASE JUST OF
ALL NO.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAT MEALS PET
NIELSEN I LIVE IN OWN PROPERTY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I ALSO OWN
PROP UP PRO I AM ALSO IN A
MAAGEMENT COMPANY I MANAGE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED UNITS DOWNTOWN
MOSTLY.
PLEASE PLEASE SAVE OUR BEAUTIFUL
CITY.
WELL I MY NAME IS LESLIE I'M
AWARE MORE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
ARIANNA HOUSE YOU PLEASE VOTE NO
ON E. BE A FIFTEEN OF SEX.
MY NAME IS BRENDA HODGES FROM
SACRAMENTO ONE HOME CARE
PROVIDER. I'M VOTING YES TO TO
SUPPORT THE BE ABLE ON FIFTEEN
NO SEEKS.
THANK YOU FULL APPEAL BANKS.
MY NAME IS BRENDA GONNA AND I'M
OPPOSED TO FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK
YOU EVERYBODY.
MY NAME IS HELEN MARIE HARRIS
I'M A HOMEOWNER IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA PLEASE VOTE YES ON A
BE FIFTEEN OH SIX.
OUR COUNTY WORKER HOME CARE
WORKER NEVADO CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAROL TAYLOR CINNAMIC
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE REPEAL HAD.
ROBERT GEARY FROM SAN JOSE. AYE
AYE REPRESENT THE HOUSE LISTS
PACKED.
OF THE SACRED HEART COMMUNITY.
HOUSING ACTION COMMITTEE. AND
UP PLEASE VOTE.
YES REPEAL.
I'M BARBARA NICHOLAS. AND PLEASE
VOTE YES.
ON.
ACOSTA HAWKINS.
WE NEED IT. THANK YOU.
I'M AMANDA CARLOS FROM QATADA
CALIFORNIA MY HOME CARE WORKER.
PLEASE VOTE TO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN LUMA SOME
FROM OAKLAND AND SOLANO I'M A
RETIRED LIBRARIAN PLEASE VOTE
YES ON FIFTEEN NO SEX.
COME ON I'M SURE A WILLIAMS I
WOULD LIKE TO. VOTE AND ON
FIFTEEN NO SIX YES.
I AM I LIVING CARE PROVIDER
THINK YOU.
MARIA MOLINA YES ON AB FIFTEEN
ALL SIX AND HOME CARE PROVIDER.
ANTHONY FEDERICO FROM OAKLAND
WITH S. E. AYE YOU TWENTY
FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM
CARE WORKERS UNION PLEASE VOTE
YES PLEASE REPEAL.
WELL WELL WELL.
HI MY NAME IS NINETY OF US GOT
SECOND MAN IS HE A LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN POLICE VOTE YES ON THAT
EBP CHANNEL SIX. FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INTO.
MY NAME IS LAURIE TO VOICE I'M
FROM CALPERS COUNTY WITH SEIU
LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN PLEASE VOTE
YES ON AB FIFTY NO SIX.
MY NAME IS A JUROR CREEL FROM
CINEMA QUALITY I'M A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE ACLU TO ANY PROOF
THEN I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ONLY GOOD WHERE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN
OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND LONG TERM CARE WORKERS
HAVE STRONG SUPPORT FOR THEM AB
FIFTY NOTHING.
ME NUMBER ADDRESS I DON'T I MEAN
AS OUR PRESENT THOUGH I KEY LA
ALONE IN THE LOWEST OF THE LOW
THE BUT I WILL. IS THE MOST THAT
YOU PUT IN A SO MEMBERS OF A
SEVEN OR NOTHING THAT HE IN
THAT.
YES YES.
THE NUMBER A MONEY.
YANO YOU WELL Y. ESTá YEAH BUT
UP UP WILL YEAH I'VE IS THE
SYSTEM WILL SAVE.
MY NAME IS FATIMA GARCIA I AM
HERE AS A SECRETARY OF
SACRAMENTO LABOR COUNCIL FOR
LATIN AMERICAN ADVANCEMENT
AFL-CIO AND ALSO WITH SEIU U. S.
W. W. THAT REPRESENTS. OVER
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
URGE YOU TO PASS IT. A BE.
ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
LOW MY NAME IS CHRISTINE ALVAREZ
MOST ORGANIZER FOR SEIU U. S. W.
W.. AS STATED WE REPRESENT OVER
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
THE STATE.
I URGE YOU ASK YOU TO PLEASE.
VOTE AND REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS OF THAT BILL MEDINA
LOPEZ SO I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
FIFTY NO SIX.
VERY IMPORTANT
FOR WE THE PEOPLE
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS FOR US AND TO
MAKE ALL ON A PROUD MEMBER OF AS
CA YOU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN. AND
I'M ASKING FOR A YES VOTE THANK
YOU.
I MEAN IT WAS THE VINYL ON THEM
FROM TRACY CALIFORNIA AND I VOTE
YES ON AB FIFTY NO SIX.
ALEXANDER OH JINGLE OF SEIU
LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTY NO SIX.
EVERY BACK CURRENCY I WAS
SILICON VALLEY RISING FROM SAN
JOSE YEAH SUPPORT FIFTEEN NO
SEX.
NICK MARINO FROM SCO YOU TEND TO
ONE PLEASE SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN NO
SEX THANK YOU.
CHOPPER WAS THE MONTH THERE WITH
LATINOS UNITED TROUT FOR NEW
AMERICAN SAN JOSE.
WE'RE HERE TO.
FULLY SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
AND DILATORY HIS HERE YOU TEND
THE ONE SACRAMENTO.
VOTE YES ON.
AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK YOU.
BRUCE MOYER SEIU TEN TO ONE.
FULLY SUPPORT TO AYE AB FIFTY
NOW SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M MY DONALDSON I'M AT
HOME KNOWN HOMEOWNER IN
BERKELEY.
AND I URGE YOU TO USE
SUPPORT S. B. FIFTEEN ZERO SIX
AND PROTECT OUR TRENDS THANK
YOU.
HI AM CAITLYN PRINTABLE I'M WITH
SEIU TEND TO ONE AND I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN OAKLAND PLEASE
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN NY SIX AND
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME'S ELIZABETH YOU RE BAM
SCHOOL BUS DRIVER HOMEOWNER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND I'M WITH A C.
R. U. TEN TO ONE.
AND I WANT TO VOTE YES FOR A BI
FIFTEEN A SIX.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ROBIN
MUCH SLUR ON MY WORK IN SPECIAL
ED WITH SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND I'M HERE
WITH SEIU LOCAL TEN TWENTY ONE.
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON AB
FIFTEEN ZERO SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JOHN JAPAN SEIU
LOCAL TEND TO ONE STRONG SUPPORT
MAYBE FIFTEEN A SIX.
TONY ROSENBERGER WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
REPRESENTING SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS THROUGHOUT ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE I'M FROM
CASTRO BODY. PRIESTS BOTH YES TO
KNOW. MAYBE. A BOW YOU YES TO.
NO TO.
AB ONE FIVE OR SIX. THANK YOU.
THIS IS DIANA FUN SAN ANGELO
PLEASE VOTE NO NO TOOL AB ONE
FIVE OH SIX KEEP COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU.
THIS IS KELLY I'M OF SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB
WILL FIFTEEN NO SAKES IT'S
KILLING ALL THE HOUSING.
AND.
NIGHT IS GORDON THEM FROM
SACRAMENTO HOMEOWNER. OFFICE
VOTE NO ON A P. FIFTEEN OH SIX
THANK YOU.
I'M STEPHEN HOME WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA OF PLEASE SAY NO TO
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX.
ADDITIONAL OUR PROCESS AND
BUREAUCRATIC THING CAN ONLY POSH
ON YOU DON'T RENDON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DARREN
KELLER I LIVE IN WALNUT CREEK
CALIFORNIA I ASK YOU TO VOTE NO
ON AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RYAN HENRIK'S FROM
SAN FRANCISCO PLEASE VOTE NO ON
AB.
ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SO LEASE SHAH. AND HERE TO
TESTIFY IN STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'D VOLLENHOVEN SEMI TALE
CALIFORNIA NO ON FIFTEEN OH SIX.
FRED BOCANEGRA SAN MATEO.
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE.
NO.
FRED KIANI FROM MOUNTAIN VIEW
PLEASE VOTE NO ON FIFTY YOU KNOW
SIX.
A PATRICK WORK FROM THE THOMAS
VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN OAK SIX THANK
YOU.
PLANETS UNIQUELY SOME OF KNOWN
FOR AB ONE.
FINE HOLDS SIX.
DABBING GOD THAN US WITH THE
NORTH BAY ORGANIZING PROJECT IN
SANTA ROSA FIRE COUNTRY WE SAY.
YES TO FIFTEEN OH SIX REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS.
MARLENE OR TORONTO YES FOR
FIFTEEN OH SIX NORTH BY
ORGANIZING PROJECT ONE PERCENT
VACANCY RATE PRIOR TO FIRES
NEGATIVE TWO PERCENT VACANCY
NOW.
KATHLEEN CHIPOLA FIRE RAVAGED
DISTRICT TO SANTA ROSA NORTH BAY
ORGANIZING PROJECT. ND.
GET RID OF IT.
AND SUPPORT.
AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW THE POLITICAL BUT THEN
I'M CONSULATE WAS SAN FRANCISCO
HOUSING RIGHTS COMMITTEE WORK
WAS RUSSIAN COMMUNITY REFUGEES
SENIORS IN FULL SUPPORT OF
REPEAL.
MY NAME IS JOY ATTEND THEM FROM
SOME A CISCO AND PART OF HOUSING
RIGHTS COMMITTEE OF SAN
FRANCISCO I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DENISE BASSLINE I
LIVE IN MARIN COUNTY. PROUD
COKE.
ATTENDANT TO ANTI SMALL OF MARIN
SHIP A NINETY EIGHT YEAR OLD NOW
FACING EVICTION.
PLEASE PLEASE REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
ROUGH BOOKS OCCUR YOUNG YOUNG
AREN'T SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
RICHMOND VICE MAYOR JIM BACA
BACK GOALS.
WE MUST REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
PLEASE VOTE YES ON. ON THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL*
I AM WITH THE HOUSING RIGHTS
COMMITTEE OF SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE OF FOR A BI FIFTEEN US.
THANK YOU.
TONY ROADLESS SENIOR IN
DISABILITY ACTION IN SAN
FRANCISCO I MYSELF WAS HIT WITH
A THREE HUNDRED PERCENT RATE
INCREASE.
URGE YOU TO PASS OF AB ONE FIVE
OR SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN YOU SHOW HONOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO HOUSING RIGHTS
COMMITTEE.
PLEASE PASS AB FIFTY KNOW SIX
WITH NO AMENDMENTS REPEAL.
YES HELLO OF MY NAME IS HIS SU
GAME FROM SOME FRANCISCO I AM
THE FOUNDED OF THE HIV LONG TERM
SURVIVORS GROUP WITH CLOSE TO
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE. POLICE.
AND YES.
GET RID OF COSTA HAWKINS PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS A METER RUBIO
FROM SAM'S CISCO WITH THE
HOUSING RIGHTS COMMITTEE ON
MATTHEW TO REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
BECAUSE IT DISPLACES. TENANTS
AND SMALL ARE SMALL BUSINESSES.
HI I AM ONE OF Y BOND NATUS
EVERITT SISKIN ALSO A VOLUNTEER
HOUSING RIGHT COMMITTEE PLEASE
BAG OF YOU.
NO COSTA HAWKINS.
I AM GREG LAWLER SAN FRANCISCO
RENTS HERE PLEASE REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
I AM A JOHN DE ICING SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE REPEAL CUT
COSTA HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT FINNEGAN
HOMEOWNER PROPERTY YOU.
OWNER WHO RENTS.
I'VE HEARD NO LINE THAT THEY
QUITE FIFTEEN OR SIX WITH
COMMUNISM IT'S NOT AYE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SHOWS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SPEAKER.
I RISKE FREE MAH.
I'M HERE TO OPPOSE EIGHT. ABA
FIFTEEN OH SIX.
MY NAME IS JOHNNY.
FOURTH THE CITY WHERE OPPOSE AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX.
THIS COUNTRY Mú DRIVING PHONE
FREE MOM AND REPRESENTING BAY
AREA HOME OWNERS NETWORK. WE
STRONGLY URGE TO VOTE AGAINST
FIFTEEN OF SIX.
JIMMY FANG FROM SUMMIT TALE.
ALONG THROUGH THE PHONE.
BAY AREA HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION.
AND DAHLE VOTE NO ON AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX I'M COME FROM CHINA FLUFF
MARKET CONTROL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY NAME IS LYNN FROWNED DALY
CITY.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THE BE FIFTY
OR SIX
AND KEEP COSTA HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME IS DANIEL LEVY WITH A
BOMB BAY AREA HOMEOWNER NETWORKS
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THE AB FIFTY
NO SAFE AND KEEP.
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
HI.
LES HALL.
WELL I FAMILY LEAVE.
I'M A LITTLE WORRIED TO KEEP IT
ON MY OWN. I SCRIPT A KEEN
THAT'S LIKE SAYING THE FOR ALL
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GEORGIA.
HI A REMOTE AYE CHIANG I AM A
CURRENT CITY OF OAKLAND RENT FOR
COMMISSIONER. I REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF SENIOR CITIZEN
HOMEOWNERS THAT OPPOSE FIFTEEN
OH SIX THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RACHEL GUNN THIRD
I'M WITH MAY CALIFORNIA GREAT
PACKED AND BETTER HOUSING LONG
BEACH.
PLEASE LET COMMON SENSE PREVAIL
AND VOTE NO.
TO AB FIFTY NO SIX.
CHUCK BURKS LIFETIME MEMBER OF
THE APARTMENT OWNERS ASSOCIATION
AND TREASURER OF THE SHERMAN
OAKS HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION. AND
I URGE OF THE NO VOTE ON FIFTEEN
NO SIX.
FRANK Mú FROM OAKLAND.
PRIESTS FOR. NO AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI I AM TERM BECAUSE MY MM.
COMES LOVE THOSE SAME INTERESTS
GO BECAUSE YOU ARE TRYING TO
SAY.
THANK YOU.
NO.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS A HIGHS I'M
DOWN BY KNEELING.
IT ARE SIMPLICITY COUGH
CALIFORNIA I SAY NO ON THAT.
AB FIFTY FIVE SIX.
FIFTY YET ALSO.
MY LAMB KIM JONG. I FROM SOME
PHYSICAL.
I KNOW.
A BLUE DRIFTING FLORAL SCENT.
BRING YOUR.
HOW MY MOM AND POP HOME NOW FUND
BAY AREA HOME OWNERS NETWORK LOW
KNOWN TO AP FIFTEEN NO SIX
READING CONTROL CHILLS HOUSING?
HI MY NAME'S NORI LEO I'M A
BERKELEY LAW STUDENT AND A LOT
INTERNET THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY
LAW CENTER I SUPPORT FULL
REPEAL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELISSA COLOGNE
I AM WITH THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY
LAW CENTER SUPPORT A FULL REPEAL
NO AMENDMENTS THAT OU.
HI MY NAME IS AND I SAY LOOK UP
THAT I'M I WOULDN'T GO SO COSTA
PLACE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
YOU KNOW BUT AT LEAST OF THAT IS
SO BENGAL WHO GOES OFF WITHOUT A
SOME FRANCISCO EXECUTE
CONSIDERABLE TECHNICAL STUFF
ATKINS AND SO THE VALUE OF MY
NAME IF WE SET THAT ASIDE I'M
HERE BECAUSE I WAS THERE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AND I DEMAND THAT.
COSTA HAWKINS REPEALED AND IT'S
A HOLIDAY THANK YOU.
NUMBER S. AND HAVING OAKLAND
BECAUSE THAT WAS THAT GIVING UP
WE AND THE US ELEVEN I WAS YEAH.
BECAUSE THEN I CAN.
I MANY MY SOMETIME YOUR SUFFERS
IS GO FROM BECAUSEI WILL SEND
I'M HERE TO.
SUPPORT THE REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS RAMONA COVER SAN
FRANCISCO I'M IN THE FOR JUST A
CALLOUS AND WHEN HE'S TO FIGHT
TO REPEAL BECAUSE THE HUNKY AND
BOUGHT FIFTEEN LOS THINK.
HELLO MY NAME IS KURT DENY
HARRIS AND I'M WITH C. JJC COSTA
WHO SUGGEST BECAUSE AND I'M
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE.
PILL COSTA
HARKINS.
SUSAN THE SAME WITH KAZUSA JUST
BECAUSE OAKLAND AND URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON FIFTEEN OR SIX
REPEAL COMPLETELY KUSTOK.
MOMMY PLOT THIS COUSIN WHO
STOLE.
DISS BY GREED AND RACISM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HE'LL COVER UP
MUCH.
WE NUMBER IT MEDI AMONG THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE HOUSEHOLD
THAT IF THEY ARE PUBLIC THAT I A
BAKING THINKS THAT'LL SAY WHAT
GOOD. AND THAT IT WILL NOT BE BE
AND I THINK THAT ACTUAL MONEY MY
NAME IS MONEY UNLESS YOU HAVE
SOME ACOSTA WHO STEP FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THE REPEAL OF. THAT BABY FIFTEEN
ALL SIX A BECAUSE HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE NUMBER OF BILL LET US ON
FRANCISCO PARTICULAR BB AND THAT
WAS SIMPLY LAKE ASSUME THAT IT
TOOK WHAT PUBLIC ABOUT CAN COSTA
HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS VIOLET FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE REPEAL BECAUSE
HOUSING.
SHOULD BE A RACIAL.
AGAIN FOR FOLKS IN THE ROOM WE
ARE ASKING EVERYONE TO JUST
STATE YOUR NAME.
YOUR ORGANIZATION OR CITY AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
AND BASIC ENABLE US OUT AND SEE
IF GO PLEASE FULLY REPAIR COST
BACKING.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS DAVID
I'M WITH CUSTOMERS THAT JUST
BECAUSE I WAS A VICTIM OF ACOSTA
HARKIN AYE THROUGH SUPPORT AB
VIDEO SIX ON THE RICHTER
CROSSTALK THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CARMEN I'M A TENER
JUST BECAUSE AND I AM SUPPORT A
FULL REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME IS THEME BE FROM SOME
FRANCISCO AM WITHOUT SOME HOST
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT TO
FULLY.
.
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS CAMILLE FROM THE CITY
WITH TWENTY FIVE PERCENT BLACK
DISPLACEMENT IN OAKLAND PLEASE
FULLY REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
I'M CHRIS DRAWS SO FROM THE
CITIES OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
OAKLAND FROM CAUSING US TO JUST
BECAUSE.
AB.
EYES UP SUPPORT THE. APPEAL
SORRY.
I'M GETTING CONFUSED HERE.
BASICALLY.
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LIKE SPEAKER.
EMMANUEL JACOBO MASTER STUDENT
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT I SUPPORT.
FULL REPEAL OF COMSTOCK.
THANK YOU.
LIVE GONZALEZ I CAN'T AFFORD
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN
APARTMENT I'M FROM SAN JOSE WITH
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG AND THE
SILICON VALLEY RENTERS RIGHTS
COALITION WHERE IS A PART OF THE
FULL REPEAL. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SANDY PERRY I'M FROM
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING NETWORK
OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY I'M ALSO A
CHRISTIAN MINISTER WITH CHAMP
DELIVERANCE MINISTRY STOP THE
SUFFERING STOP THE EVICTION STOP
A HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES MY NAME IS RUBY DOMINGUEZ
AND I'M FROM SICK AT HEART AND
I'VE BEEN EVICTED AFTER TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS THE RENT WENT UP.
PLESE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GABRIEL REGARDING UP
FROM SAN JOSE I'M WITH PACKED.
PLEASE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS IT
IS TOXIC.
MY NAME IS SHIRLEY STAIGER I'M
WITH PACKED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SEIU ONE THOUSAND WE'RE LOSING
OUR STATE EMPLOYEES IN SAN JOSE
REPEAT IF YOU'RE A MUCH.
SPEAKER.
CHRISTIAN ALANO WITH PACKS IN
SAN JOSE REPORT OF THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA NETWORK.
SOME OF THE SICK CAPITAL OF
SILICON VALLEY CAPITAL OF
EQUALITY REPEAL.
SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS RON JOHNSON SAN JOSE
ON BEHALF OF MY CHILDREN AND
GRANDDAUGHTERS YOU TO PEEL COSTA
HAWKINS.
SUSAN HUNTER LOS ANGELES TENANTS
UNION HOLLYWOOD LOCAL PLEASE
PROTECT OUR LANDLORDS FROM
PREDATORY INSURANCE COMPANIES
VOTE YES ON FIFTEEN OH SIX.
ROBERT GEARY CHANNELS A PLEASER
REPEAL FIFTEEN OF. US.
CUT CUT OUT.
NAME UNKNOWN LIKE THE SEVEN
THOUSAND ON HOUSE PEOPLE OAKLAND
WHO ARE BEING INVESTIGATED BY
THE UNITED NATIONS FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. VIOLATIONS OF RACIST
BECAUSE YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER.
I MANY MISS CHRIS STARK AND I'M
A RESIDENT BELMONT CALIFORNIA
ALSO A COUNTY MEMBER OF ONE SAME
TALE FROM CITY OF SAN MATEO BODY
FOR HOUSING JUSTICE WE SUPPORT
THE REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
EMILY A KEY SAYING I'M A SAN
FRANCISCO TEN AND I'M A FIFTH
GENERATION CALIFORNIAN WITH THE
SIXTH GENERATION CALIFORNIAN
HERE AND I SUPPORT THE FULL
REPEAL OF.
COSTA HAWKINS AND WITH IT SFTS
A.
SERLING RIENDS TENANT IN
BERKELEY ADDS CHAO PLEASE
REMEMBER THAT AN ABSTENTION IS A
NO VOTE REPEAL BECAUSE THEY ARE
VERY MUCH.
MY NAME'S MIKE BOSSY LAW SOME
FROM RICHMOND AND I OPPOSE AB
FIFTY NO SEX.
MY NAME IS SHANTI SAYING I'M THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE CO CHAIR FOR
THE SAN FRANCISCO DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA PLEASE FOR
MY NEIGHBORS ARE SENIOR TENANTS
OF COLOR UNDER RENT CONTROL
PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE REPEAL
VOSTOK.
MY NAME IS BRYCE BELL THAT I'M A
VETERAN MEMBER THE DSA SAN
FRANCISCO AND.
ONE EMPLOYER AT SHALL NOT BE A
COWARD.
I NEED TO ASK EVERYONE AGAIN TO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOUR NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION OR
YOUR CITY AND SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
I'M GONNA ASK THE SHERIFF SAYS
THEY'VE BEEN DOING TO CUT
PEOPLE'S MICROPHONES OFF IF THEY
DO NOT. ABIDE BY THAT WE WANT TO
HAVE EQUAL COVERAGE FOR EVERYONE
THAT IS WHAT WE REQUIRED TO DO
IN THESE HEARINGS THANK YOU.
IF AND SILVERSTEIN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA TIME AND YOU SEE
HASTINGSLAW STUDENT I SUPPORT A
FULL REPEAL THANK YOU.
I LEASES ON THE WHILE I WORK
WITH HOUSING RIGHTS COMEDIANS
HARRIS'S AGO BORN AND RAISED I
LIVE IN MARTINEZ. ARE I SUPPORT
A BE FIFTEEN ALL SIX
SUPPORT FULL REPEAL THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S BRAD HERNAN WITH
HOUSING RIGHTS MAY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
TEN AND I SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE OF
COSTA HAWKINS.
MY NAME IS JACK GRAYSON
REPRESENTS THE COALITION ON
HOMELESSNESS SAN FRANCISCO
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS IN FULL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KYLE JONES A CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE STAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF FIFTEEN A SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KIRK
MACKENZIE FROM SARATOGA AND I
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN Nó SIX AND
ASK THAT YOU RETAIN COSTA
HAWKINS
I MEAN IF MAKAYLA I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NO I DID THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE FOR OPPOSING FIFTEEN
KNOWS.
THANK YOU.
TEMAS GRAMMAR FROM CONCORD AYE
OPPOSED AB FIFTEEN NO SIX.
TYRONE BUCKLEY HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI PER IN SHAW WITH ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK A
PEN. IS ASKING YOU PLEASE VOTE
YES.
ELAINE PATTERSON BERKELEY BPO
AYE. AND I OPPOSE AID. FIFTY
LONESOME THANK YOU.
I'M RICHARD PATTINSON.
I'M OF. A PROPERTY ONLY IN
BERKELEY.
AND I'M BACK AGAIN.
I'M ONE OF THE ORIGINAL.
A.
PEOPLE WHO CAME DOWN.
AND BECAUSE OF OUR SITUATION IN
WEST BERKELEY.
WE WERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR.
OPPOSE OR SUPPORT.
.
I.
HOPE YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
NEXT BIGGER.
WE STILL HUNDREDS OF FOLKS TO GO
I WANT TO ASK AGAIN EVERYONE
ALREADY TAKE JIM O'CONNOR. IN
REDWOOD CITY CALIFORNIA. AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON A BE.
FIFTEEN ZERO SIX.
THANK YOU CROSSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON LUIS BROWN JUNIOR
WITH POLICY LINK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON AND CHRIS SHELVE THE
LANDLORD WITH LANDLORDS FOR RENT
CONTROL SUPPORT FIFTEEN NO SIX.
THANK YOU MARK MCKINNEY WE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT IF IT'S YOU KNOW SIX
THANK YOU.
LOW ENGINE DEAN OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTY OF SEX THANK YOU.
BILL MITCHELL I LIVE IN AND.
FOUR PLEX IN OAKLAND AND I SAY
NO.
THANK YOU.
GREG ALAMEDA COUNTY NO.
WELL DO SO MUCH SERIOUS EFFORT
CISCO AND ONE PROPERLY WHEN
ARTICLE NO LAW CAN NO LONGER
PROVIDE SIR HOUSING SERVICES IF
YOU SAY YES PLEASE VOTE NO FOR
EVERYONE'S SAKE THANK YOU.
JONATHAN WELDON SMALL PROPERTY
OWNER IN BERKELEY I URGE A NO
VOTE AND ALSO ENCOURAGE IT WOULD
HAVE A LITTLE FUN.
THANK YOU.
JACKSON WELDON FROM BERKELEY.
I ALSO REPRESENT MY BROTHERS
HERE WHO HAVE HAD VERY BAD
EXPERIENCES WITH THIS PLEASE
VOTE NOW.
NO SHAME LIFETIME SEVERANCE
CISCO RESIDENT I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE OPPOSE THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE HOLES IN WITH FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA PLEASE VOTE NO ON
AB FIFTY NO SIX.
APRIL SIMMONS ON WITH THE LOCAL
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT COMPANY AND
WE OPPOSE.
RACHEL A BILL I'M WITH A LOCAL
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT COMPANY AND
I OPPOSE.
GEN NOW LOW ON MOST OF WHAT THE
LOCAL PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
COMPANY AND WE OPPOSE.
CAFEPRESS ALLY WITH THE LOCAL
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT COMPANY AND
WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. NICKY HARRIS SOME OF
THE LOCAL PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
COMPANY AND WE OPPOSE.
AND ASK OF IT TO THE LOCAL
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT COMPANY AND
AYE OPPOSED.
ANDREW PARTS US
BERKELEY PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED.
AND THAT EVEN AS A ONE SILENCE
I'M PACKED.
I.
DOES IT FIT.
THAT'S THE HACKING SO.
I THINK I MEAN SOMETHING.
THE LITTLE SUPPLY LOPER THEN THE
FIRE THIS OPEN UNDER THE UP ALL
YOUR LOVE IS. KEEN SINCE SEVERAL
FACE ENOUGH.
THANK YOU SOLELY ALBERT
POLITICAL DIRECTOR OF THE CAL
BERKELEY DEMOCRATS AND BOARD
MEMBER THE UC BERKELEY
PROGRESSIVE SCAN ASSOCIATION
PLEASE REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
BEAMISH ART IN BERKELEY OPPOSED.
KAREN FRANCISCO OAKLAND MEMBER
OF EMPEROR AYE OPPOSE REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE
PARRIS SAID ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATES ORGANIZE SACRAMENTO
HOUSING FOR SACRAMENTO. AYE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
SACRAMENTO CENTRAL LABOR COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT.
SUSIE SHATTUCK WIFE OF HER
PERCENT SERVICE CONNECTED
DISABLED VETERAN WE LOST OUR
PLACE TO LIVE AND. THE OPPOSE
WE SUPPORT.
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOYCE LIVE FROM BAY AREA
PALO ALTO. I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY SIXTEEN OH.
FIFTEEN OR SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOAN I'M FORMER LOS
GATOS CALIFORNIA I'M STRONGLY A
FULL OF OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
THANK YOU.
HELLO OF DON'T OMITTING DAHLE
WILL COME ON COME FROM SAID THE
CAR OF. A POLICE THE WHAT THE
NORMAL NO I'M A P. FIFTEEN THERE
WERE SIX.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S AUDRY HA I'M A MEMBER
ALL FOR BAY AREA HOME THAT WELL.
IDEALLY IN THE SOUTH POLE AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE MEASURE.
WELL LAWRENCE R. ANA AND EMMA.
I'M ALSO A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
OF THE TEN OVER HOW TO CLEAN A
FOR THE ORGANISM DEPARTMENT. AIM
WE SUPPORT IN THIS THIS. CRYPT
FULL REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS.
MY KELBERG.
HOUSING PROVIDER FULSOME FAIR
OAKS ORANGEVILLE CITRUS HEIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB FIFTY NO
SIX.
BOBBI REMY CLARK GRANDMOTHER
WITH AIDS.
I FOR SUPPORT FIFTEEN I'LL FIX
FOR MY LIVING YEAR OLD AND MY
TWELVE YEAR OLD GRANDCHILDREN
I'M RAISING THANK YOU.
JOHN ABOUT OUT OF THOSE
SACRAMENTO EAST ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNION
FARMING HERE. IN SACRAMENTO
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF REPEALING
COSTA HAWKINS.
VERONICA BT WITH THE SECOND IN A
HOUSING ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LUCY WALKER CARMICHAEL I'M WITH
THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF
AMERICA. I SUPPORT FULL REPEAL
OF COSTA HAWKINS.
AND THE SUNDERLAND WITH.
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF
AMERICA SACRAMENTO AND ORGANIZE
SACRAMENTO AND I'M HERE BECAUSE
WORKING PEOPLE DESPERATELY NEED
A REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS CO
YES.
ASSEMBLYMAN BLUE.
CHAIRMAN CHU.
I AM AN APPLICANT THE NAME IS
JEFF TARGET HERE NATIVE
SACRAMENTUM.
pSTARTING WITH CAR STARTING WITH
DISABILITIES THERE'S SO MANY
THAT I COULD NAME BUT I SUPPORT
THIS REPEAL WITH THE
UNINTENTIONAL CONSEQUENTLY VERY
MUCH REPAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH AND I'M AS THE US FROM
DAVIS CALIFORNIA AND THE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
DEMOCRATS.
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRAT I
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN OF SIX THE.
GREG CqC LONGTIME RESIDENTS
SACRAMENTO A MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA
SACRAMENTO PLEASE VOTE YES.
NOVEL WELL US ORGANIZE WITH ACE
IN THE RICHMOND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND I SUPPORT THE REPEAL
OF COSTA HAWKINS.
GUSTAVO GONZALEZ WITH THE
SENATOR COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS REPRESENTING OVER SIX
THOUSAND REALTORSAND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS NELSON WILCOX I'M A
VERY VERY SPOTS BILL LANDOWNER
AND LANDLORD HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NO SIX.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M JULIA KATO I'M WITH A
BERKELEY TENANTS UNION. THE
BERKELEY GRAY PANTHERS AND THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS WHICH IS A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION OF CLOSE TO A
MILLION PEOPLE.
AND WE ALL SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
PLEASE VOTE YES.
JEAN SCHAFER FROM SACRAMENTO I'M
A RETIREE AND FAIR SMALL
LANDLORD. AND I.
HE CURRY TO DEVOTE NOW I'M
FIFTEEN NOW SIX.
HELLO I'M CONNIE SPECKLE MEYER
RETIRED TEACHER AND SMALL
PROPERTY OWNER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. BY VOTE.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN
NO SIX.
HELLO THIS IS CHRISTINE AND.
DANCE.
FRANCINE SCHWARTZ WILL SHORTZ
TWINS FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
DAY.
AND UM WE. WERE PART OF THE
BERKELEY TENANTS UNION. AND WERE
PART OF TENANTS TOGETHER THANK
YOU AND WERE I'M IN HOME CARE
WORKER FROM SCO YOU LOCAL TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN THANK YOU.
AND WE BOTH VOTE YES ON A BE
FIFTEEN NO SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HELLO R. MY NAME IS JAMES CHIANG
AYE SIR ON THE BERKELEY RENT
STABILIZATION BOARD I AM THE
CHAIR OF THE OUTREACH COMMITTEE
URGING YOU TO VOTE. YES ON
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS.
CHRISTINA TRIED AWAY WITH FBI
MANAGEMENT WE OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO
SEX.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS I AM I I
THOUGHT AS I AM A MEMBER OF THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY ACTION
NETWORK ALSO A RESIDENT. AND
RENTER IN LOS ANGELES.
AND I'M HERE TO SAY.
AND TO URGE YOU TO VOTE.
YES ON AB FIFTY NO SIX
HOMELESSNESS IN LA COUNTY WENT
UP TWENTY PERCENT LAST YEAR AND
I'M HERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AGAIN I WANT ALL OF US
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S.
PASSION AND YOUR PROSPECTIVE BUT
WE NEED TO KEEP EQUAL TIME FOR
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR RESPECTING
THAT NEXT SPEAKER.
HELLO.
I'M LEE MOFFITT I'M REPRESENTED.
AW.
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES THE BIGGEST
RECOVERY TSUNAMI LAW COMMUNITY
IN THE WORLD. AND NO BILL AITKEN
AND ALMOST TO URGE ALL TO VOTE
YES OR NO.
A. BE FIFTY IN ALL SIX LIKE.
HI MY NAME IS SHARON WAY I AM
WITH YES A SAN FRANCISCO I'M A
STUDENT AT CITY COLLEGE OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND A RENTER.
WHO HAS FACED EVICTION IN THE
PAST AND I SUPPORT PEOPLE OVER
PROFITS?
THANK YOU.
PAGE AND SNYDER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS
OF AMERICA AND NEIGHBORS UNITED
PLEASE SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
CHAO WOULD IT'S ON YOU TO DO IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT RAZA SAN FRANCISCO
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA
AND CHAO DON'T BE A CALLING CARD
YEAH WHICH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY.
MY NAME IS BLAKE GRIFFIN I'M
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS
OF AMERICA SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
WORKING CLASS I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU ALL TO VOTE YES ON FIFTY NO
SIX THANK YOU.
LOW MONIES THE SLOT MáS
ARTICLES FROM LOS ANGELES BASE
WARMER TENET.
JUST YES ON A BEFITTING ALL SIX
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HI I'M MARK LEARNED TODAY FROM
THE ESSAY SAN FRANCISCO MY
FAMILY HAS LIVED IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR ABOUT THREE
GENERATIONS NOW AND I STRONGLY
SAY VOTE YESTO REPEAL COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHN MONTFORD WITH
SAN FRANCISCO DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA AND LIVE
IN THE MISSION DISTRICT OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHICH IS EXPERIENCING
AN EVICTION AND DISPLACEMENT
CRISIS. LET US DO WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HI MY NAME'S NORA BELROSE I'M
HERE WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHAPTER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALISTS OF AMERICA.
ALSO ATTENDANT AND I URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES ON AB FIFTEEN OR
SIX.
HI SIMON RUSSELL SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
CHAPTER OF DO YOU SAY. ED CHILD
VOTE YES DONOT ABSTAINED WE
WILL REMEMBER.
HI JOHN BUCHAN THOUGHT CARE
GIVER.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON A BE.
IF YOU KNOW SIX THANK YOU.
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
HI MARIA SHOWMAN INDIVISIBLE SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE FOUR THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS PLEASE VOTE
YES ON AB ONE FIVE OF SIX THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO OVER A LOT RECEIVE NO LIKE
A MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND FORMER SECRETARY
OF SAME BODY. I URGE YOUR.
SUPPORT OF REPEALING RENT
CONTROL AND THIS BILL THANK YOU
MUCH.
JEAN DONE PRIVATE CITIZEN
OAKLAND.
I BELIEVE IN NO ON FIFTEEN OF
SIX.
I'M ELAINE STEMMONS OF BERKELEY
PROPERTY OWNER AYE. VOTE NO. OR
A BE ONE FIVE ZERO SIX.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN CHU CAROLING
GAUGE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS AND
PROPERTY OWNER AYE MS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SYLVIA VINEGARS SOME FERNANDO
ACE MEMBER AND I SUPPORT AB ONE
FIVE ZERO SIX THANK YOU.
MICHELLE BAKER FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA YES ON AB FIFTEEN ARE
SIX.
HELLO MY NAME IS STACY WHITE OF
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA AND SEE A
MEMBER AND I VOTE NO IMMEDIATE
FIFTY NO SIX THANK YOU.
I AM IN HER TENNIS AND I AM FROM
ROSA CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS MAJOR.
HI JEANNE OUR LEAST ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA MEMBER OF CA A AYE
OPPOSE FIFTEEN OF SIX.
HI RHONDA FARLEY FIRST POINT
MANAGEMENT GROUP ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA CA A MEMBER AND I
OPPOSE THIS MAJOR.
HI MY MANTRA CENTIMETERS AYE
FROM LOS ANGELES. ANGI ESSAY. AB
PREPARE.
REMEMBER IT'S NOT THE BEST
SCIENTISTS BINGO. BANGO THERE SO
SOMETIMES I HAD THIS IDEA YOU
KNOW ME NEVER COME AND GO. EGO
BANG BOTH HIM OKAY THEORY FEE.
UP A BIT FEDERAL. GIVES A SUBTLE
SAFE.
ADDRESSES.
MY NAME IS SYLVIA MONARCHY IN
HOW MINE ORGANIZER WITH SAY
EACH.
I'M ALSO A A.
MEMBER OWES TO DEMOCRATIC CLUB.
IN MY TOWN IN FONTANA IN SOME
BUT I THE NO COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TO SAY YES REPEAL
COSTA HAWKING'S.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DAVID BAYLISS SUMMER
RANCHER IN LOS ANGELES AND AN
ORGANIZER WITH SAGE AND I'M HERE
TO SAY YES REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS
PASS AB FIFTY NO SIX.
MY NAME IS I WILL ASK AS WITH
SAGE FROM LOS ANGELES AND WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WITH NO AMENDMENTS THINK.
MY NAME IS JEFFERSON MEDIUM WITH
A SACRAMENTO AND.
I SAY YES ON FIFTEEN NO SIX WITH
NO AMENDMENTS.
MY NAME IS THERESA CAR I'M OF
SMALL LANDLORD IN SOLANO COUNTY
AND I'M A MEMBER OF CA A AND I'M
ASKING YOU TO VOTE NO. ON
FIFTEEN OH SIX.
BERNIE STILL ROBERTSON SMALL
LANDLORDS SOLANO COUNTY AND I
VOTE NO ON AB FIFTEEN NO SIX.
JANINE BY ALL THE WAY ó
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE AB FIFTY
NO SIX.
BETH WILSON RESIDENT OF VALLEJO
AND AYE VOTE NO ONE FIFTEEN NO
SIX.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS JESSICA
I'M A COLLEGE STUDENT AND WITH
FAITH IN ACTION AND I SUPPORT AB
FIFTY NO SEX AND TIME IS RUNNING
UP.
LISA MARIE WONG WITH FAITH
INACTION BAY AREA AND I SUPPORT
AB FIFTY NO SIX REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS AMBER I'M IN OAKLAND
TEN IT REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS IN
STOP RACIALIZED DISPLACEMENT NOW
TODAY.
LARA LAST SAT TEN AND COUNSELOR
WE COUSIN WHO SAT I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE HUNDREDS OF
TENANTS AND A WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES WHO'VE BEEN DISPLAYS.
I'M PRICED OUT OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES AYE AND YES ON AB
FIFTY NO SIX.
THANK YOU.
JERRY BOWEN WOULD SEE JJ. FOR
SUPPORT AND GETTING RID OF IT
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KIND OF MODEL
KING.
I'M WITH THE BERNIE SANDERS
GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA AND YOUTH
THANKS FOR US TO WIN TO GREET.
HELLO MY NAME IS CONNOR RYAN AND
I'M A RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I URGE YOU STRONGLY TO VOTE
YES ON FIFTEEN ZERO SIX REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOE MURRAY I'M A
RESIDENT IN MARIN AND A LANDLORD
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON FIFTEEN NO SIX THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SUSAN PRICE
CHEWING AND I AM A SMALL
LANDLORD FROM SAN JOSE I CAME
HERE WITH PEOPLE ACTING AND
COMMUNITY TOGETHER. OUR URGE YOU
TO VOTE YES AND FIFTEEN NO SIX
REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS.
WELL I'M. COMPLAIN YOU KNOW THE
DIVIDEND OFTHE MAMMOTH CLOSE IN
ON HIM. IS SO THIS UNCLE TAKE ON
THE FUNDING OF THE SECOND HEART
COMMUNITY SERVICE THE THING LOOK
AT US ON. DE JUST PLOY UP OF
ORDER THAT KEEN SAYS TOTAL FAITH
YEAH PUESTO HUH. R. COSTA
HAWKINS.
GOT AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS PAULA BACK WELL I'M
A RESIDENT OF OAKLAND.
AYE WITH JESS BECAUSE WOULD YOU
PLEASE VOTE YES.
AN APPEAL FIFTEEN ALL SIX THANK
YOU HAVE A BLESSED.
MEMORANDUM BUT TRAVIS ON THE
PHONE WITH A GOOD FOR NOW MEN OR
NOT. YOU UP OIL BUT THE METHOD
OF INSANE DO YOU THINK THAT A
PHONE.
SEE ALAMI NUMBER OF US HAVE GOT
ABOUT THE MINIMUM BANGLA CYCLE
SAMPLE YOUNG DON'T HAVE.
INSENSITIVE THINKS.
UNITS HERNANDEZ FROM A CIGARETTE
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND THE
SILICON VALLEY WINTERS RIGHTS
COALITION IN SAN JOSE WE SUPPORT
AB FIFTY NO SIX A FULL REPEAL OF
COSTA HAWKINS.
HI MY NAME'S GOD LOTTERY A LOT
OF FROM SOME FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORTED THE FORTY
PEEL OFF DIG UP.
HELLO I'M NANCY COMBS I'M ON THE
A RICHMOND RENTS BOARD AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES.
FOR MORE LOCAL CONTROL THE KID.
HELLO MY NAME IS LISA KANG I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN RICHMOND AND ALSO A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER FOR DID
NINETY THOUSAND MEMBER
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION.
NURSES SAY YES TO A BEFITTING A
SIX REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THEY
LET ALL POP I AM WITH THE
EVICTION DEFENSE NETWORK OF LOS
ANGELES ALSO WITH THE ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT. THE LA TENANTS
UNION I THINK ENOUGH WILL NEED
LAWS A BEHALF OF THE FIVE
THOUSAND FAMILIES WE COUNSEL TO
THIS LAST YEAR WE URGE YOU TO.
SUPPORT AB FIFTY NO SIX
ESPECIALLY IF YOU WANT TO KEEP
YOUR JOBS THEY.
NEXT WEEK A POLICE.
HI MY NAME IS PHIL RAPIER I AM A
MEMBER OF THE.
THE VIXEN DEFENSE CENTER IN
OAKLAND AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
EAST BAY TENETS BAR ASSOCIATION
WITH COUNSEL THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
OF THE LAST FEW YEARS.
AND WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF.
FIFTY NO SIX.
THE OJ.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DANYA CASSIDY AND I
AM A RESIDENT A RENTER IN
ALAMEDA AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTY NO SIX A FULL REPEAL
OF COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BRIAN NELSON I'VE
BEEN A MULTI FAMILY SPECIALIST
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE LONG TERM BEST
INTEREST OF ALL TENANTS
I AM HERE TO OPPOSE AB FIFTY NO
SIX.
MY NAME IS SALAH CLARK FROM
RICHMOND I AM A NURSE.
A SMALL HOUSING PROVIDER AND A
MEMBER OF SEIU LOCAL SIX ONE SIX
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS VOTE NO
COMPROMISE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH BRANDON ON FROM
OAKLAND PLEASE AMEND THIS BILL
BY REPLACING THE DATE OF
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WITH THE
PHRASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DAVE TAYLOR FRAILE MASSARO
CALIFORNIA'S STRONGLY OPPOSED.
LET ME STATE IF FOLKS WANT TO
SEND US IDEAS SUGGESTIONS OTHER
COMMENTS YOU ARE VERY WELCOME TO
DO THAT TO SEND TO OUR
COMMITTEE.
TODD FBI MANAGEMENT STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
THAT IS A MAIN CO CHAIR OF SANTA
MONICA SYRINGES WRITES THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. WE'RE
URGING VOTE YES.
ON AB FIFTY NO SIX REPEAL COSTS
HAWKINS STOP A HEMORRHAGE.
MY NAME'S NATALIE I AM A BAY
AREA RENTER AND AYE OPPOSED TO
AB FIFTY US.
MY NAME IS CHERYL COLLINS OR A
GUY OWN MY HOME AND ALAMEDA AND
I ALSO WORK FOR A PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT COMPANY IN OAKLAND.
WE WERE OPPOSE.
NO ON FIFTEEN NO SIX
THANK YOU.
WELL EAST YEAH I'M ATTENDED AM
ALAMEDA AYE OPPOSED AB PATINA
FIX.
THANK YOU.
I'M ADRIANA FANNING AYE OPPOSED
FIFTEEN OF SIX.
I'M STEVE FINLEY ON BEHALF OF
THE BREAD AND BUTTER HOME SO WE
OWN IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA. I
WILL BE MOVING OUT OF THIS AREA
FEW DON'T THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CARLA MORGAN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA PROPERTY MANAGEMENT.
OWNER WE OPPOSE.
MY NAME'S ANGELA CHAN AND I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO ALREADY
SPOKEN AND BONO ON THIS BILL BUT
JUST WHAT THE SIZE MILLION
YOU'VE ALREADY SPOKEN. YOU'VE
ALREADY SPOKEN MA'AM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
.
I DON'T HAVE TO TAKE A RECESS.
I'M GONNA ASK EVERYONE TO PLEASE
TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
RESPECT EACH OTHER.
THIS IS THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
NEXT SPEAKER THANK YOU.
HI I'M ROW FOR NEWS FROM SAN
JOSE I'M WITH THE LUNAR
ORGANIZATION AND SILICON VALLEY
RENTERS RIGHTS COALITION PLEASE
VOTE YES ON FIFTY NO SIX.
HI THERE MY MAN THIS LATINOS
APPEALS COURT NOMINEE CA AND AND
PART OF SILICON VALLEY WINTERS
RIGHT COALITION HERE APPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS THINK YOU.
HONESTLY SUPPORT AROUND HERE.
SOLIS UNPLEASANT SO YEAH THEY
WILL NOT BE ENOUGH FOR ME LOS.
YEA SEE PARA.
AB A V..
CONSIDER SLICE.
THANK YOU.
SO THE SO CALLED OUT I HIT WITH
OUTDOOR NINE SOME WILL SAY HE
SHE'S HERE TO SAY YES TO AB
FIFTY NO SIX.
ALL NOW NEED MY NASCO CAUGHT I
LINDA JOIN MEMBER A LITTLE KNIFE
AND WE'LL TAKE DIPLOMAT. AND BUT
THEN HE BOUGHT AYE ABC PP CENTER
THING.
SOCORRO I MEAN THOUGH WITH NO
ONE OUTSIDE WAS SAYING AND VOTE
YES WITH IT FOR S. B. FIFTEEN OH
SIX.
ALLOW ME NUMBER IN MY TO HIM AND
THEN. BINGO AS SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA IS TAKEN LUNA UP A
YOUNG THE COSTA HAWKINS.
THANK YOU.
AND THIS IS MY IDEA HE MENACE
AND SHE'S WITH.
SOME WILL SAY WITH NO NINE
SHE'S HERE TO REVEAL COSTA
HAWKINS.
WELL LET ME KNOW BEDLOE DAILY
NOTICE EVEN GOING TO SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA.
MEMBER OF THE LUMIA ECCC ALOT
OBVIOUSLY.
HE INSISTS IT'LL SAY SAY SAY
SEATS EXCEPT WHEN.
SO THIS IS WHAT I MEAN THAT IS
AND SHE'S ALSO WITH SOME WILL
SAY.
LUNA AND ALSO YES ON AS.
AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK YOU.
I AM SAM SOROKIN ORINDA RESIDENT
FORMER BERKELEY RENT PORT
COMMISSIONER FROM NINETEEN
NINETY TO NINETY SIX.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL I WAS
LANDED PRIOR TO AB FIFTIES IS
AWFUL.
SPEAKER.
ANA SMITH I AM A TENANT IN
BERKELEY AS WELL AS A PROPERTY
MANAGER FOR OVER FOURTEEN YEARS
IN THE BUSINESS AND I VOTE NO ON
AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEFF I'M A LONG TIME
BAY AREA NATIVE AND WE OPPOSE.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL TO WAY I'M
FROM BERKELEY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A BI FIFTY NO SIX THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT KABAM ACE
MEMBER HERE SEC WELL.
SUPPORT AB FIFTY NO SIX TOUGH
TALK IS A BAD BILL. ALONG.
NEXT BAKER THANK YOU.
SINGLE BRANSON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE BERKELEY PROPERTY
OWNERS ASSOCIATION MORE STRICT
RENT CONTROL STARTED ALL THIS
OPPOSE.
TINA MOSHE EAST BAY RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL EAST BAY RENTAL
HOUSING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. I WORK IN ROB BONTA
AS DISTRICT IN OAKLAND WHERE I'D
BEEN VICTIMIZED BY THE RENT IT
JUST PROGRAM PLEASE OPPOSED A
BIGGER THANK.
VOTE NO.
THANK YOU.
ANDREAS OF RESIDENT OF ROSE WILL
KNOW ON AB.
PATTON
SMALL TIME HARDWORKING LANDLORD
IN LA PLEASE VOTE NO.
HELLO WE NEED TO TURN THE MIKE
BACK ON.
SHOULD WORK NOW.
HI I'M CYNTHIA MORALIS I'M A BAY
AREA NATIVE I LIVE IN PLEASANT
HILL CALIFORNIA AT A RENTAL HOME
AND I SAY NO.
THANK YOU.
HI AM ELAINE STILTON AYE OPPOSED
FIFTEEN NO SIX I'M A SMALL TIME
A PROPERTY OWNER. AND.
I THINK THIS WILL BE A DISASTER
THINK.
HI THERE MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
MARKETS AND FROM SACRAMENTO
PLEASE VOTE NOW.
BECKY THATCHER VARIA PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT PLEASE VOTE NO.
I'M BRIAN RAIN I RUN A REAL
STATE.
APARTMENT REVITALIZATION
COMPANY EMPLOYING TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY PEOPLE DIRECTLY AND
HUNDREDS MORE INDIRECTLY.
OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME'S ADAM MUST FILLED
AN A SACRAMENTO RESIDENT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS RUSHED SEE SHABAZZ
I'M A RESIDENT OF ALAMEDA
CALIFORNIA.
MY ORGANIZATIONAL AFFILIATION IS
I'M THE SON OF DEBORAH JANE'S
LIFELONG CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND
UNFORTUNATE FUTURE AIRS ON A
RESIDENT.
AND.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB ONE FIVE
ZERO SIX.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW MONEY WAS LEFT
TO DIXON. A MEMBER OF IT ALL
MALCOLM MADE TRANSIT UNION ONE
NINETY TWO. AND ALSO A MEMBER OF
OUR ALAMEDA WRITERS COALITION.
AND YES.
ONE FIVE ALL SIX SAY YES.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
MICROPHONE AGAIN PLEASE.
MY CHECK.
THERE WE GO ALRIGHT TRYING IT
AGAIN RICHARD MARCANTONIO PA A
MANAGING ATTORNEY AT PUBLIC
ADVOCATES PLEASE VOTE YES TO
RESTORE LOCAL CONTROL TO.
ADDRESS THESE CRITICAL ISSUES.
MY NAME IS HIGH MAKE KATTER I'M
HERE WITH MY MOTHER EVA KATTER
WE LIVE IN CONCORD. AND WE ARE
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK
YOU.
BRIDGET GONZALEZ.
LOS ANGELES LANDLORDS RENT
CONTROLLED.
I COMPLETELY SUPPORT.
A B. FIFTEEN NO SIX THERE ARE
MORE VENT VOTERS AS TENANTS THAN
LANDLORDS.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EQUALLY WRONG I AM AT
THE COLD LAND R. INVADE THE CPU
WHO NEVER RACED UP THE RED.
NARAL AB ONE FIVE ZERO SIX THANK
YOU.
FRANCISCO TORRES PITTSBURG BAY
POINT ACE CHAPTER SUPPORT THE
REPEAL OF COSTA HAWKINS THANK
YOU.
I'M GREGG LINES FROM OAKLAND AT
WHERE I AM A REALTOR AND
PROVIDER OF RENTAL HOUSING.
I OPPOSE REPEAL OF CONTACT COSTA
HAWKINS.
I'M JIM LOFGREN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY. WE REPRESENT OWNERS AND
MANAGERS OF VOTE FOR EIGHTY
THOUSAND UNITS IN THE REGION.
WE SUPPORT BUILDING MORE HOUSING
AND WE POSE THIS BILL.
BY KATHY SNOWDEN AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BERKELEY
PROPERTY OWNERS ASSOCIATION. WE
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
JOBS DEL APARTMENT OWNER
PROPERTY MANAGER JUST VOTE NO ON
SOCIALISM.
NEXT SPEAKER.
AND EARLY SELLING ANY DEL
HOUSING PROVIDING SAN JOSE VOTE
NO ON AB FIFTY NOTICE SIX.
WHO'S LANDLORDS OR LET ME HAVE
THE LAST WORD LARRY GROWTH VEKIC
OF DIRECTOR OF COALITION FOR
ECONOMIC SURVIVAL IN LOSS AND
TRUTH. VOTE YES ON FIFTEEN NO
SIX REPEAL COSTA HAWKINS NOW.
VICKI ABI BETTER HOUSING FOR
LONG BEACH WE URGE YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE NO ON AB FIFTY NO SIX THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER.
JODY WHERE WITH BETTER HOUSING
FOR LONG BEACH WE CAME ALL THE
WAY OUT HERE WE ARE A NO VOTE
I'M ALSO A. PROPERTY OWNER IN
WEST HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA SOME
OF THE WORST RECORD TOLL IN THE
COUNTRY. AND I'M A DEFINITE NO.
MAYBE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WEEK A PLEASE.
RYAN ADDRESSED.
BRIAN AGAINST ARMY OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SANTA
MONICA RENT CONTROL BOARD AND
THE BERKELEY WERE CONTROL BOARD
IS PART.
THANK YOU MAKE SPEAKER ON YOUR
LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN CHU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SIMILAR BONTA.
I'M GAMING GIVEN.
OF LOS ANGELES SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES MY FAMILY LIVED OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS EXECUTIVE ACTOR
THE CRENSHAW SO WHAT COALITION.
AND THE HOUSING IS A HUMAN
RIGHTS PROJECT DIRECTOR OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION.
WE STRONGLY URGE YOU.
PASS
SPILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET ME ASK ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT HAVE
NOT HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK IN
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT WISH TO.
GOING ONCE
GOING TWICE.
AT THIS TIME PUBLIC COMMENT IS
CLOSED MATTER IS BACK IN THE
HANDS OF THE COMMITTEE ALLOWS
THE. SURGEONS TO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BACK FOR DISCUSSION. OUR
COLLEAGUES.
DISCUSSION.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
MR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM. I AM
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY I THINK IT'S LONG PAST
TIME. THAT WE TAKE THE HANDCUFFS
OFF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND GIVE
THEM THE ABILITY TO DO THE
APPROPRIATE ANALYSIS NECESSARY
TO LOOK AT AT WHAT HOW WHEN. TO
DEAL WITH WITH RENT CONTROL IN
THEIR OWN JURISDICTIONS AGREE
THAT THIS IS JUST A A TOOL IN
THE TOOLBOX.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO BE.
ENSURING THAT WE'RE HANDING AS
MANY TOOLS AS POSSIBLE DOWN TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DO WHAT
THEY WHAT THEY KNOW THAT THEY
NEED TO DO. OF I'M ALSO A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED SINCE I HEAR SO
MUCH
FROM THE OPPOSITION AND OTHERS
THAT THERE ARE POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS HERETHERE ARE WAYS TO
LOOK AT COSTA HAWKINS AND.
AND MAY BE SIX INCUMBENT
AMENDMENT RATHER THAN JUST AN
APPEAL. THIS BILL WAS INTRODUCED
ELEVEN MONTHS AGO AND I I KNOW
YOU VERY WELL MISTER BLOOM I
KNOW YOUR DOORS OPEN AND THAT
YOUR.
VERY ACCESSIBLE TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND IT IN AND
WHY WE HAVE TO WAIT.
THIS LONG TO HAVE THAT NOTION
BROUGHT FORWARD IS IS A LITTLE
BIT FRUSTRATING AND SO FOR I
KNOW THAT THERE IS SOME CONCERN.
AND SOME SOME INTEREST AMONG
MEMBERS HERE IN LOOKING AT SOME
OTHER WAY OF APPROACHING IT AND
MAY BE MODIFIED COSTA HAWKINS
OUTSIDE THE ONLY WAY FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN IS FOR US TO PASS THIS
BILL HERE TODAY. BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T ALL THIS THE OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE GOING TO STOP.
HOW SUPPORT AN ABSOLUTE REPEAL
ANYWAY BUT IF YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN?
KING THAT EXTRA STEP AND
CONTINUING TO TALK THEN THAT'S I
THINK VERY LAUDABLE IN IN ORDER
TO KEEP THIS CONVERSATION A
POLICY MOVING FORWARD BUT THE
ONLY WAY WE MOVE IT FORWARD
TODAY IS TO PASS IT OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE SO I ASK ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS. TO SUPPORT.
THIS BILL TODAY THIS EFFORT AND
EVEN IF IT IS FOR YOU AN INTERIM
STEP.
THAT'S FINE BY NICK REPEALING
COSTA HAWKINS IS AN APPROPRIATE.
STEP FOR CALIFORNIA THIS TIME TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE. OTHER
COMMENTS MISTER STEINORTH.
I HAVE A QUESTION AND I HAVE A
STATEMENT YOU WHEN MY MISTER
BLOOM FIRST THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PRESENTING THIS TODAY. I'M
YOU SAY YOU'RE ADVOCATING FOR
LOCAL CONTROL ON THAT THIS BILL
ESSENTIALLY DOES ACT LOOK WHAT
IS THE POSITION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE CITIES AND
ALSO SEES ACT.
I'M NOT CERTAIN.
OKAY BECAUSE I I MEAN THEY'RE
THE CHAMPIONS OF LOCAL CONTROL.
THE NO POSITION AS FAR NO
MUSICIAN VERY GOOD.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
SERGEANTS FOR DOING AN ADMIRABLE
PROFESSIONAL JOB IN AND MANAGING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY I THINK
WE ALL WILL AGREE THAT THERE IS
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF.
OPINIONS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
ISSUE AND I THINK THIS ARTIST OF
DONE AT A GREAT JOB IN KEEPING
THAT. MOVING FORWARD AND I LIKE
TO THINK THE AUTHOR ALSO FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD IT'S IT'S A
LOT OF WORK IT'S HEAVY LIFTING I
UNDERSTAND.
THEY CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THIS AND
AND TO BOTH THE PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS FOR MAKING VERY GOOD
ARGUMENTS.
FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD TODAY
THOUGH I BELIEVE TO RECONCILE
COULD BE THE TIPPING POINT
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME THAT THE
SOLUTION TO THE HOUSING CRISIS
IS INCREASING THE SUPPLY OF
HOMES.
REPEALING COSTA HAWKINS DOES NOT
SOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS.
IT POTENTIALLY COULD EXACERBATE
IT.
AGAIN I ASK EVERYONE TO PLEASE
IF YOU NEED TO TALK.
TAKE IT OUTSIDE
MR STEINORTH THANK YOU.
AND IT HURTS SMALL PROPERTY
OWNERS THE MOST
BY EXTENDING RENT CONTROL THE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND CONDOS
AND ALLOWING RENT CONTROL ANY
UNIT FOR LIFE WITH ONLY MINOR
INCREASES. THIS WILL HURT SMALL
OWNERS IS THE MAJORITY OF THE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND CONDOS
ARE OWNED BY INDIVIDUALS NOT BIG
CORPORATIONS.
THERE ARE A COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SINGLE FAMILY RENTALS.
NOW I APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
AUTHORS OF PROPONENTS INTENTIONS
TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE AFFORDABLE
AND SAFE OUT OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA BUT I'M. I'M
CONFIDENT THAT AB FIFTEEN NO SIX
WILL DO THE. OPPOSITE OF THE
DESIRED GOALS I'LL BE VOTING NO
TODAY.
THANK YOU OTHER COMMENTS MISTER
DOCTOR WHAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN HERE
IT THE AUTHOR FOR THIS WORK ON
THIS I BELIEVE WHICH IS A VERY
VERY COMPLICATED TOPIC.
WE'RE FACING A CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA THERE'S ABSOLUTE NOTE
ABOUT NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
MAJORITY RATHER SPEND MORE THAN
THIRTY PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME
ON RENT COSTS AND THAT'S CLEARLY
NOT SUSTAINABLE.
BUT I TO BELIEVE THE ROUTE
CRISIS BECAUSE OF THIS CRISIS
OUR FAILURE TO BUILD ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND KEEP UP
WITH OUR GROWING POPULATION.
WE TOOK STEPS LAST YEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE HURDLES THAT CREATED
THIS DYNAMIC BUT WE'RE STILL
VERY FAR BEHIND.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT'S AT
COMING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
CONSIDER SETTING ASIDE
REDEVELOPMENT SOLELY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GET BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE. IN MY COMMUNITY
THE LAST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WAS BUILT WHEN WE
HAD DEVELOPED HAD REDEVELOPMENT
WE DON'T HAVE THAT CRITICAL
RESOURCE NOW AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY HURT US. AND HURT PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
PRIOR TO THE WILDFIRES INCIDENTS
NUMBER COUNTY.
AND MENDOCINO COUNTY.
R. VACANCY RATE IN BOTH
COUNTIES WAS ABOUT OR LESS THAN
TEN TWO PERCENT.
AND THIS IS ONLY WORSENED IN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT OVER.
FIVE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
HOMES THAT NEED TO BE REBUILT IN
MY TO COUNTIES.
AND MANY OF THESE SERVE OUR
MULTI FAMILY HOMES.
AND I I SUPPORT BECAUSE I THE
MEASURES TO CONTAIN RISING
COSTS.
BUT I'M NOT CONFIDENT CAUGHT A
COTTON QUITE CONFIDENT.
THAT A COMPLETE REPEAL OF COSTA
HAWKINS IS THE ANSWER.
IN MY DEBT DISTRICT WERE
DEDICATED TO REBUILDING.
I'M CONCERNED THAT THE BILL DOES
NOTHING TO FACILITATE AN
INCREASE IN THE SUPPLY OF
HOUSING IN ME MAY TH AND MAY IN
FACT.
HAVE THE OPPOSITE EFFECT BY
DISCOURAGING NEW CONSTRUCTION
DURING A TIME WHEN WE NEED IT
THE MOST.
WITH RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR I
THINK THE MESSAGE FROM ADVOCATES
AS THIS IS A TAKE IT OR LEAVE IT
APPROACH. THAT IS IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IN MY OPINION DOES NOT
RESULT NECESSARILY A GOOD
POLICY.
WELL I'M SYMPATHETIC TO THE
ISSUE OF RISING RENTS AND ITS
IMPACT ON PEOPLE. AMONG ABLE TO
SUPPORT A PRO PROPOSAL THAT IS
REPRESENTED IS ONE THAT NEEDS NO
FURTHER WORK MODIFICATION A
COMPROMISE AND FOR THAT REASON.
I CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM.
OTHER.
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
AGAIN.
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
IT'S ABOUT A.
I'M MISTER BUT MY I DIDN'T MAKE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
TO CLARIFY A COUPLE THINGS THAT
MAY OF GOTTEN LOSSES IN IN THE
US SOME OF THE DISCUSSION IN AND
APPRECIATE EVERY SINGLE PERSON
WHO.
CAME HERE IS STILL HERE WHO
STOOD UP TO SPEAK OF TO COMMENT
YOU'RE BUSY DAY. TO SHARE WITH
US YOUR INPUT I'M IT'S IT'S VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED HELP MAKE
TODAY'S THAT DISCUSSION MORE
ROBUST AND MORE RICH.
MR BOMBS NOT A COUPLE QUESTIONS
DO.
DO CITIES. OR COUNTIES.
FOR IT LOCAL LEADERS WHO DO NOT
WISH.
.
TO.
CHANGE
OUT. THAT THE CURRENT STATUS OF.
SINGLE SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND
CONDOS BEING EXEMPT.
THE RULES UNDER CONSTRUCTION
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS WITH THE
BAR.
AND AND DON'T WISH TO CHANGE
VACANCY HE CONTROLLED IT WOULD
WHAT PAKPATTAN AB FIFTY NO SIX.
REQUIRE THAT THEY DO THAT.
NO.
AND AND FOR THOSE WHO DO WISH TO
BECAUSE.
THEY BELIEVE IT'LL SOLVE A
PROBLEM IN THEIR IN THEIR CITY
OR THEIR LOCALITY.
DO THEY HAVE TO.
TO.
ADOPT ALL COMPONENTS
OF.
.
REPEAL OF EVERY ONE OF THE THREE
COMPONENTS THAT IS CURRENTLY
COSTA HAWKINS TOUCHES KNOW ME
THEY COULD THEY COULD TAKE SOME
OF THE COULD LEAVE SOME RIGHT.
THAT'S THE WHOLE IDEA AND THEY
COULD ARM PROVIDE. A SET OF
NUANCE
TO.
THE SOME OF THE COMPONENTS FOR
EXAMPLE PROVIDING EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT ROLLING DEFINITION OF WHAT
NEW CONSTRUCTION HAS.
SO THAT IT'S NOT STUCK IN IN IN
IN CEMENT AT A MOMENT IN TIME
AND A HUNDRED YEARS FROM NOW.
.
SOMETHING BUILT AFTER NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE IS STILL CONSIDERED
NEW CONSTRUCTION ONE IT'S NOT.
AND IF YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT A
A REASONABLE.
PERIOD OF TIME FOR RETURN ON
INVESTMENT I MEAN ALL ALL THAT
CAN BE PART OF THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WOULD GO ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
RIGHT THAT'S CORRECT.
AND MOM AND POPS
IF A LOCAL DISTRICT JURISDICTION
CHOSE TO DO THEY CAN BE
EXEMPTED.
AND AND FOCUS COULD BE PUT ON
WALL STREET ARE CORPORATIONS
WITH INVESTOR OWNED SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES AND CONDOS CORRECT
TRIP. TO OFFICE OKAY SO I MEAN
IT.
THE POINT HERE IS THAT THERE'S
THERE'S THERE'S A WORLD OF
POSSIBILITIES.
.
FROM DOING ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
TO.
I'M TAKING A AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE CHANGES IN ALL THREE OF THE
LOWER LEGS OF THE THREE LEGGED
STOOL R. COSTA HAWKINS AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN.
CAN.
CRAFT.
A TAILORED SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM FITS IN THEIR IN THEIR
JURISDICTION RIGHT YES.
AND AND IF THE BABY FIFTY NO SIX
DOESN'T PASSED TODAY.
I'M WE KNOW THIS DISCUSSIONS
CANNOT CONTINUE I I APPRECIATE
THE. ITEM OVERTURES THAT WERE
MADE THAT THAT THE COMMITMENTS
TO ONGOING DISCUSSION BUT.
IF AB FIFTY KNOWS IT DOES MOVE
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY.
THE NUMBER TIME FOR FOR THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND.
.
AT I AGREE THAT THERE ARE ARE
ARE MANY FACETS TO THE
DISCUSSION ON THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS.
.
BUT THE DISCUSSION HAS IS
ABSOLUTE IMPORTANT AND NEEDS TO
CONTINUE IT MUST CONTINUE I DO
IF. I DO SUPPORT FULL REPEAL
COSTA HAWKINS AND I CERTAINLY
SUPPORT. OUR CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION AS WE GO FOR THIS IS
THE FIRST HOUSE THIS IS THE
FIRST COMMITTEE.
.
THEY WILL BE OUT MUCH MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO.
UNRAVEL SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED TODAY TO
DISCUSS THEM TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO ACCOMMODATE THEM AND CREEK
FIXES THAT WORK FOR FOLKS.
TOM BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
CONTINUES TO BE.
THAT.
CALIFORNIANS.
AND DESERVE.
.
FOR US TO DELIVER TO THEM SOME
EASEMENT OF OF THEIR PAIN.
OF THEIR SUFFERING OF THEIR
ANGUISH OF THEIR HURT AND
WEAVING OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
TODAY.
UP SO I WILL BE PART I WILL BE
A VOTE FOR IT FOR THAT. AND
STANDING UP FOR CALIFORNIANS IN
AND PROVIDING A RELIEF TO THEM.
AND I HOPE THIS DISCUSSION CAN
CONTINUE AND AGAIN APPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP MISTER BLOOM. AYE AS
WELL AS YOURS I'M MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER.
DISCUSSION.
MISTER CHOI.
I CHAIRMAN I AM CURIOUS WHETHER
ANYBODY HAS TAKEN TO TALLIES OF.
UP PUBLIC SUPPORT IN THE POLLS.
THERE HAVE BEEN A COUPLE OF
ATTEMPTS TO BUT THEY HAVE AN
ADDED UP ALL THE HASH MARKS YET
SO WE'LL WE'LL TRY TO DO THAT
LATER ON.
THERE'S NO WHICH IS THE VISUAL
OR. WITHOUT ACTUALLY COUNTY IT'S
ACTUALLY FROM WHAT WE CAN.
IT FROM WHAT WE CAN TELL IT'S
ACTUALLY QUITE CLOSE.
SO THAT'S.
OKAY I.
.
IT IS WHAT IT IS. I YEAH I ACT I
CAN I CAN TELL QUITE.
.
SUPPORT AND GLOW.
OPPOSE. NECK AND NECK. IS
SOMEBODY HAS SWELLED COUNTER.
I APPRECIATE THE WITH THE
PUBLIC FOR COMING OUT AND
EXPRESSING I THINK.
WE ARE TRULY.
WITNESSING A DEMOCRACY.
AT WORK A.
IS A VERY.
R. DIFFICULT FOR US SO WE OR
INDIVIDUAL. A MEMBERS HERE. HOW
WE HAVE A CERTAIN POSITIONS ARE
AND ON DIFFERENT A PORCH?
BUT I HOPE WELL WE OR HALF US IN
COMMON.
MY. A IN OUR HEART TO. IT
INCLUDING MYSELF LAW.
AS I STATED R. O. DURING THE
QUESTION SESSION THAT SAW A AYE
I TAKE IT AS A VERY SERIOUS
HEALTH CRISES SO IN CALIFORNIA
FOR RISING. UP COST OF A HOUSING
AND A LOT OF HOMELESS PEOPLE OR
AND NOW. ALL OF A FIFTY PERCENT
OFF AUDIO INCOME.
IS SO USED TO FOR A HOUSING AND
THE LIVING VERY LATER FOR OTHER.
.
LIVING EXPENSE IS SOUGHT THIS
IS SO.
.
BAKER PRICE IS SARAH AND THE WE
NEED TO ADDRESS HOW WE CAN COME
UP WITH AND I'M AS I MENTIONED
AWHILE AGO. THRUST IF SO
CONCERNS ON THAT.
AT LEAST I HAVE A AND A
SOMEWHAT THE EXPRESSIONS OF THAT
I HAD THE FROM MY MEMBERS.
BUT TODAY I'M NOT TOTALLY
CONVINCED US ALL. ARE I'M NOT IN
THE POSITION TODAY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
AT THIS TIME.
LET ME ASK IS THERE A MOTION.
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD SO MOVED.
MOTION MADE BY MISTER BONTA
SECOND BY MISTER STONE I HAVE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS AND I WILL
ASK THE AUTHOR. TO CLOSE BEFORE
WE TAKE A VOTE. UP LET ME ALSO.
START MY COMMENTS BY THANKING
ALL OF YOU FOR.
THIS DISCUSSION WHAT I THINK
THE SERGEANTS FOR THEIR HARD
WORK TODAY I WANNA THANK THE
AUTHOR. AND YOUR STAFF AND AND
THAT AS WELL AS MY STAFF AND AND
MISTER BONTA STAFF.
THE CO AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
AFTER MOVING THIS FORWARD ONE
THANK ALL THE WITNESSES AND ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS AROUND HOUSING
ISSUES HERE IN OUR STATE
CAPITOL.
OF FREE WORK.
.
AS HAS BEEN SAID THIS IS WHAT
DEMOCRACY LOOKS LIKE IT IS NOT
ALWAYS NEAT. IT IS OFTEN MESSY
BUT THANK YOU FOR TAKING PART IN
THIS DEMOCRATIC PROCESS BELLS
ONE THANK ALL OF MY CONSTITUENTS
ON BOTH SIDES THEY'RE PROBABLY
HUNDREDS OF SAN FRANCISCANS.
THAT CAME OUT ANNA ON THIS ISSUE
ARE AND.
AND IN AND SAY I VERY MUCH
RESPECT THE PERSPECTIVE THAT
EVERYONE BRINGS TO THIS TABLE.
I THINK IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT
EVERY MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
LAST MONTH UNANIMOUSLY PASSED A
RESOLUTION TO SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
SIX OR SIX.
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I THINK THAT
IS BASED ON WHAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON. ARE THAT WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF THE MOST INTENSE
HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR CITIES AND
OUR STATE THAT WE'VE EVER
EXPERIENCED.
I AND MY DISTRICT HAS BEEN ONE
THE EPICENTERS OF OF THAT
CRISIS.
LET ME ALSO SAY.
THAT I DON'T THINK ANYONE
BELIEVES THAT RENT CONTROL IS
PERFECT
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT IS ONE OF
THE FEW THINGS THAT WE HAVE FROM
A POLICY PERSPECTIVE THAT IS
PROTECTING.
SOME ECONOMIC DIVERSITY IN OUR
CITIES.
ARM WHEN CAREFULLY CRAFTED. WEEP
I BELIEVE THE RENT CONTROL CAN'T
OFFER MUCH NEEDED RELIEF TO
TENANTS WHILE STILL ENSURING THE
PROPERTY OWNERS RECEIVE A FAIR
RATE OF RETURN.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT EVERY CITY
EVERY COUNTY EVERY LOCAL
JURISDICTION IN CALIFORNIA IS
UNIQUE.
AND THIS IS WHY I THINK THAT
EVERY CITY COUNTY SHOULD HAVE
FLEXIBILITY IN DECIDING WHAT
STRATEGIES WORK FOR THEM. ARE WE
KNOW HISTORICALLY IN THE PAST
THAT NOT EVERY CITY WILL DECIDE
TO ENACT RENT CONTROL.
AND THAT'S APPROPRIATE.
NOR WILL THERE BE CITIES THAT
HAVE EXISTING POLICIES THAT MAY
I UP TO WERE NOT UP TO MEND THEM
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO ALLOW CITIES TO HAVE THOSE
CHOICES.
AM I WANT TO SAY TO THE
OPPONENTS I APPRECIATE THE
PERSPECTIVES
I HAVE CERTAINLY BEE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THEM AND ALL OF
US I THINK ARE OPEN TO OTHER
IDEAS AND HOW WE ADDRESS THIS.
BUT AS I WAS TRYING TO MAKE THE
POINT EARLIER TODAY I THINK
WITHOUT OTHER IDEAS.
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS BILL NON.
I'VE LIVED FOR ALMOST MY ENTIRE
LIFE ADULT LIFE HAS ATTENDANCE
AND I KNOW. I'VE SPOKEN TO
THOUSANDS OF TENANTS
WHO ARE SUFFERING IMMENSELY.
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN EVICTED OR
WHETHER THEY ARE ON THE VERGE OF
BEING EVICTED.
IMMIGRANT TENANTS.
FAMILIES WHO ARE TENANTS
CHILDREN WHO ARE TENANTS.
SENIORS DISABLED WHO ARE
TENANTS.
LGBT YOUTH.
FROM AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
A LATINO COMMUNITY OUR API
COMMUNITY.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
SUFFERING
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THIS DISCUSSION MOVE FORWARD AND
THAT IS WHY I'M A CO AUTHOR.
THAT'S WHY COLLEAGUES I DO HOPE
YOU CONSIDER MOVING THIS FORWARD
IN WITH THAT.
MISTER BLOOM FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THIS HAS BEEN A LONG ARDUOUS
HEARING BUT I I I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
CAME HERE TO TESTIFY ON THIS.
VERY IMPORTANT BILL PEOPLE CAME
HERE TODAY FROM ALL CORNERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND MR CHAIRS YOU
REFERENCE THIS.
EXERCISE IN DEMOCRACY.
DEMONSTRATES MUCH ABOUT WHAT WE
ARE ALL ABOUT.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK GOD THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS WHO'VE WEIGHED IN
ON THIS ISSUE OUT. OF THE.
THE PROPONENTS SIR. OF
SUPPORTING THE REPEAL OF.
OF FLORA COSTA HAWKINS HAVE
WEIGHED IN WITH BROAD
ORGANIZATIONAL SUPPORT AND I
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR THAT.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
RISING RENTS.
CONTINUE TO BE A MAJOR ISSUE
FACING SO MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS AND. WE CAN ALSO
AGREE THAT IT'S NOT ONE THAT'S
EASY TO ADDRESS
BUT.
ADDRESS IT WE MUST AND THERE ARE
VERY FEW TOOLS AVAILABLE TO US.
THIS IS OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
AND THE MOST OBVIOUS ONE AND AYE
A REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOME
TODAY.
I THINK THERE IS A NO CHOICE
BUT FOR THE CONVERSATION TO
CONTINUE AND FOR US TO.
CONTINUE TO TRY AND FIND COMMON
GROUND
A WIN LOSE OR DRAW I.
COMMIT TO DO THAT GOING FORWARD.
FINALLY I WANT TO SAY THAT.
COSTA HAWKINS.
ITSELF WAS ADOPTED OVER TWENTY
TWO YEARS AGO TO ADDRESS
CONDITIONS THAT EXISTED AT THAT
TIME.
QUITE CLEARLY TIMES HAVE CHANGED
CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE CHANGED
BOB WE SEE THAT THE FACES OF
PEOPLE WHO TESTIFIED HERE TODAY.
A WE SEE THAT A IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE AS
LEGISLATORS NEED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE AND ACT.
SO I ASK THAT YOU VOTE I TO MOVE
THIS BOOK FORWARD AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
WITHOUT ALL JUST REITERATE ONE
THING THAT THE AUTHOR JUST SAID
REGARDLESS OF THE OUTCOME.
THIS WILL NOT BE THE END OF THE
CONVERSATION.
IT IS PROBABLY THE BEGINNING.
AND.
IT'S A CONVERSATION THE WILL BE
CONTINUED.
WITH THAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER BONTA
SECOND BY MISTER STONE MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS BILL PASSED CHIU AYE
CHIU AYE.
STEINORTH STEINORTH NO.
CHILD.
CHAO NINE FORTY.
CHOI NOW SHOWING NO.
STONE.
STONE AYE.
BONTA AYE.
I.
WOULD.
WOULD NON.
SPELL REQUIRED FOR VOTES TO GET
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE THREE SO AT THIS
TIME EIGHTY FIFTEEN NO SIX.
FAILS PASSAGE
TODAY.
I. MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED